YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME PERFECT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING WALKING
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION TODAY'S THURSDAY
MAY TWENTY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. THE PRIMARY PURPOSE OF
TODAY'S HEARING IS TO RECEIVE
PUBLIC COMMENT THIS LIKELY WILL
BE THE ONLY OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. WILL NOT BE
TAKING TO THIS. TODAY IN ORDER
TO ATTAIN PHYSICAL DISTANCING
WE'LL BE USING TECHNOLOGY TO
TAKE TESTIMONY FROM PANELISTS
REMOTELY AND PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELEPHONE. I WANT TO THANK THE
SPEAKER STAFF ASSEMBLY RIPPLES
ISN'T SERGEANTS SPECIAL
SERVICES AND THE LEGISLATIVE
DENTIST THEIR THEIR HARD WORK
PICKERING AND CONFIGURING NEW
TECHNOLOGY AND PROCESS IS TO
MAKE IT POSSIBLE. I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO RECENT DIRECTIONS
REPUBLIC PATIENT. IS HEARING IN
TO HELP ASSURE THE PUBLIC
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE HEY. A
FAULT WELL ALLOWING PUB FULL
ACCESS TO DISCUSS. YEAH PUT IN
THE- HAVING A SICKLY DISTANT
AND PURSE HERE. WHICH ONLY
CAUGHT A FEW MEMBERS A MIDDLE
CAN IN THE STAFF IN A LIMITED
NUMBER OF THE- AND MEDIA WE CAN
KEEP SIX FEET OF. FACING
THEY'RE ALL STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCE PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE TO
MAKE A COMMENT AT THE- TIME. A
RESTATEMENT WHEN PUBLIC SUMMIT
BEGINS. BUT IF ANY MEMBER THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WHICH TO
SPEAK THEY WILL RAISE THEIR
HANDS NOW ASSN TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. I WOULD AT THE
PUBLIC TREES PHYSICAL DISTANCE
IN AND NOT. THE MICROPHONE YOU
HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT UNDER REITERATE THAT
YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. YOU CONNECTS THE
HEARING ROOM TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IS DONE OR RETURN TO YOUR SEAT
BUT PLEASE OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCE THING. UPON LEAVING
THE CAPITOL INCLUDING
LIBERATING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. FOR A PANEL
AT. ALL OUR PANELISTS- PEERING
REMOTELY TODAY FOR ME WROTE
REMOTE WITNESS ROOMS WITH STAFF
MODERATING THE CONVERSATION.
THE MEMBERS HERE IN THE ROOM.
REMOTE PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION. ARE COLOR NUMBER IS.
ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN WHAT
CAN THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEC. ANY ACT CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN
THAT NUMBER SHOULD BE POSTED ON
THE LIVE STREAM SCREEN. YOU CAN
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE HEARING
AGENDA ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR
WEBSITE IT IS ALSO POSTED AS AN
ANNOUNCEMENT ON THAT WEBSITE.
EACH PERSON WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. I
WILL STRICTLY ENFORCE THIS
LIMIT. THOSE WATCHING THIS
HEARING REMOTELY SHOULD KNOW
THAT THE LIVE STREAM AS A
SLIGHT DELAY FROM THE BROADCAST
TO THE ACTUAL EVENTS GOING ON
IN THE ROOM. IF YOU'RE CALLING
IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE LIKE YOUR
BROADCAST LIVE STREAM TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2099. 916-319-2099 IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS AND
DEATH WILL BE HERE TO TRY AND
HELP BEGIN PUBLIC. BUT AFTER
ALL MEMBERS HAVE INCLUDED THEIR
QUESTIONS. THE OPERATOR WILL
GIVE INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE WHEN THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD BEGINS. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THE RECEPTION
WRITTEN FEEDBACK THE BUDGET SUB
FOR AT ASM DOT CA DOT GOV. SO
THE WORD BUDGET FOLLOWED BY SUB
ISSUE BE THE NUMBER FOUR AT ASM
ADAM SAM MERRY DOT CA DOT GOV
EMAIL ACCOUNT. WHICH IS ALSO ON
THE HEARING AGENDA. ANY EMAILS
RECEIVED BY THE CLOSE OF
BUSINESS TODAY WILL BE COMPILED
AND SENT TO ALL THE MEMBERS
HERE AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE. SAID
BEFORE TODAY'S HEARING RESERVE
MOST THE TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. I ALL OUT ALL MEMBERS
TO MAKE OPENING COMMENTS. THEN
TURNED TO OUR PANELIST. WE HAVE
ONE PANEL TODAY WE'LL DISCUSS
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSALS.
WE'VE ASKED THE LA JOH TO WALK
US THROUGH ALL THE PROPOSALS
AND THEN THE ADMINISTRATION TO
PROVIDE SOME BRIEF COMMENTS IN
RESPONSE. MOONSET PETALS
CONCLUDED WHO HAVE NEVER
QUESTIONS AND DIALOGUE WITH THE
PANELIST. FINALLY ONCE MEMBER
QUESTIONS OF CONCLUDED I WILL
OPEN UP THE HEARING TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. I WILL FIRST
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM THOSE
IN THE ROOM AND THEN I'LL OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
PHONE. WE HAVE ROLL CALL PLEASE.
COOPER PRESENT TO. LACKEY YOUR
NAZARIAN WHAT. I HAVE A QUORUM
TODAY WE'RE HER MORE IN DETAIL
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISED WHICH INCLUDES
DIFFICULT CUTS A LOWER LEVELS
OF FUNDING AS WELL AS NEW
PROGRAMS THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
IS INTERESTED IN. BECAUSE THE
CORONAVIRUS SHUT DOWN OF THE
STATE WE'VE SEEN IMPACTS TO ARE
HOMELESS POPULATION. OUR STATE
WORK FIRST WORKFORCE ARE
EMPLOYMENT ARTS SKEWS ME OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND.
OUR PENSION SYSTEM IN OUR STATE
REVENUES. EVEN THOUGH THE
IMPACTS HAVE BEEN DEVASTATING
WE NOW HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RETHINK HOW STATE GOVERNMENT
LIVER SERVICES AND MOVES
FORWARD. TODAY WE WANT TO HEAR
FROM THE PUBLIC SINCE THIS MAY
BE OUR ONLY OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THESE ISSUES.
THIS IS DEFINITELY NOT IDEAL
AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO SEND
ALL THE MAILS. VOTE IN CONCERNS.
I ASKED ABOUT THE PROPOSAL'S.
YEAH BUT NOT. THAT WE BASED TO.
IN THIS UPCOMING BUDGET. I KNOW
THERE PROPOSALS BUT I WANT MORE
DETAIL ON INCLUDING PROJECT
ROOM KEY FUNDING IN ORDER FULLY
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY WILL WORK
I'M ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT HAVING
ENOUGH TIME FOR ADEQUATE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN A NUMBER OF
THE REORGANIZATIONS AND
CONSOLIDATIONS INCLUDED. IN THE
BUDGET. I'M HOPING THAT IT IS
SPEAKERS BE MINDFUL OF OUR GOAL
TO MAXIMIZE TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT THEY KEEP IT UP TO
REMARKS AND QUESTIONS TO A
MINUTE TO A MINIMUM- COMMISSION
MEMBERS. OKAY READY GO HERE.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND START. FIRST
WE'RE FROM THE L. L. GOOD
MORNING MORNINGS CAROLINE'S MY
NAME IS CAROLYN CHIU FROM
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE A COPY OF
OUR HAND UP BEFORE YOU FOR
THOSE WATCHING REMOTELY IT'S
ALSO AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE
AT LA JOH DOT CA DOT GOV UNDER
THE MAYOR REVISION BUTTON AT
THE TOP OF THE SCREEN. TURNING
FIRST PAIR MANY ASKED US TO
GIVE AN UPDATE ON THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CLAIMS
TO DATE. IN PARTICULAR
CALIFORNIA HAS EXPERIENCED AN
UNPRECEDENTED INCREASE IN YOU
AYE CLAIMS SINCE THE ONSET OF
THE PANDEMIC. NATIONAL AND
STATE EMERGENCY IS AND STAY AT
HOME ORDERS. ROUGHLY THREE
POINT SIX MILLION CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVING YOU AYE BENEFITS AND
THE STATE HAS PAID TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS TO THE
INDIVIDUAL SO FAR. THE STATE
TRUST FIVE BECAME INSOLVENT
SEVERAL WEEKS AGO THIS ALSO
HAPPENED DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PROVIDES LOANS TO
THE STATE WHEN THIS OCCURRED.
SO FAR THE GOVERNMENT HAS
ADVANCED THE STATE ONE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN LOANS.
THESE LOANS ARE INTEREST FREE
THROUGH THE END OF THE CALENDAR
YEAR. AS PART OF THE MAYOR
VISION THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
REQUESTED INCREASED EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY FOR THE U. I. AT FUND
OF THIRTY EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
OF WHICH THIRTY FOUR BILLION
OLLARS ARE FEDERAL FUNDS TO
FIND THE- TEMPORARY SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR PER WEEK INCREASE IN YOU
I BENEFITS. EIGHT EXTENSION OF.
WEEKS OF YOU I BENEFITS AND THE
BENEFIT THE NEW BUT THE NEW
EXCUSE ME PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM PROVIDED BY
CONGRESS. THE SECOND PAGE THIS
GIVES YOU A SHORT UPDATE ON THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT WHICH ADMINISTERS
THE U. I. FACT CLAIMS PROCESS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MADE
ADDITIONAL ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS
AVAILABLE AS PART OF ITS
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE. THE STATE
IS TO RECEIVE TO AYE
INSTALLMENTS OF THESE
ADDITIONAL ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS
BOTH FIFTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS
THE STATE HAS RECEIVED THE
FIRST OF THE IT. IT'S BEEN USED
TO PAY FOR CALL CENTERS VENDOR
ACOSTA SET UP THE NEW YOU WHY
PROGRAMS STAFF OVERTIME AND
REDIRECTED STAFF SALARIES.
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE
PANDEMIC SO FAR EDT HAS
REDIRECTED FOURTEEN HUNDRED
STAFF FROM WITHIN ITS OWN
DEPARTMENT AND ACROSS THE REST
TO ASSIST IN YOU AYE CLAIMS
PROCESSING. EIGHTY ALSO PROPOSE
AS AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY PER AT POSITIONS AS PART
OF THE MAYOR VISION TO DEAL
WITH THE INCREASE IN YOUR LIFE
CLAIMS. IF POSITIONS WOULD BE
FEDERALLY FUNDED UNDER THE
EXISTING PROGRAM IN WHICH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PAYS THE
BASIC ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS OF
THE U. I. PROGRAM. DESPITE THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES PROVIDED
THERE CONTINUE TO BE CONCERNS
REGARDING EDC EIGHTY DAYS
CAPACITY TO ADMINISTER THE U.
I. PROGRAM. UNDER NORMAL
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS EDT WOULD
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE ABOUT 80% OF
FIRST BENEFIT PAYMENTS WITHIN
THREE WEEKS. AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE DOES THERE'VE BEEN
REPORTS ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
HAVING TROUBLE ACCESSING EDT
AND RECEIVING THEIR BENEFITS IN
A TIMELY FASHION. WE UNDERSTAND
THAT EDT STOP- ARE AVAILABLE
FOR YOUR QUESTIONS ON THIS
MATTER. TURNING TO THE THIRD
PAGE PAID FAMILY LEAVE. ARE
UNDER EXISTING LAW EMPLOYERS
WITH FIFTY EMPLOYERS ARE MORE
MUST PROVIDE TWELVE WEEKS OF
JOB PROTECTED FAMILY AND
MEDICAL LEAVE BENEFITS. IN
ADDITION EMPLOYERS WITH TWENTY
EMPLOYEES OR MORE MUST PROVIDE
TWELVE WEEKS OF JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE FOR CHILD BONDING. AS
PARTISAN AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED TO EXTEND THESE JOB AT
PROTECTIONS TO ALL BUSINESSES
REGARDLESS OF SIZE. PACIFIC WE
BUSINESSES WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE TWELVE WEEKS OF JOB
PROTECTED LEAVE FOR ANY
SITUATIONS COVERED BY THE
STATE'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE. LOOK
AT THE GOVERNOR ALSO PROPOSED
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANTS
TO BUSINESSES FOR JOB REFER
BACK EMPLOYEE RETRAINING DUE TO
THESE ADDITIONAL LEAVE BENEFITS.
TURNING TO PAY FOR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS THIS CHART WALK
THROUGH THE CHANGES IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN THESE
AREAS. I'LL START WITH THE NEW
PROPOSALS AND MAY. SPECIFICALLY
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR PROJECT ROOM KEY EITHER
FEDERAL FUNDS PROVIDED THROUGH
THE COURT CORONAVIRUS RELIEF
FUND. OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WOULD
BE PROVIDED TO PURCHASE THE
HOTELS THAT HAVE BEEN YEARS
THROUGH AT THE EXISTING PRODUCT
ROOM KEEP- AT PROGRAM.
REMAINING HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD GO TOWARDS
REPAYING THE STATE AND LOCAL
RENTS FOR COST ALREADY INCURRED.
TO RESPOND TO THE BED A MARGIN
CA AMONG THE HOMELESS
POPULATION. IN ADDITION THE
GOVERNOR CONTINUE A PROPOSES TO
CONTINUE AT THE EXPANSION OF
THE STATE'S LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
HOWEVER THREE EARLIER GIVEN TO
ACCOUNT FOR THIS EXPANSION IT'S
AFTER OF ITS REVENUES. THE REST
OF. PACK UP THROUGH PROPOSES
WITH JOHN JOHN FROM JANUARY OR
CHANGE FROM PRIOR YEARS. IN
PARTICULAR THE ADMINISTRATION
WITHDRAWS ITS PROPOSAL FOR
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. IN ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT. ADDRESS
THE- AS- IT ALSO WITH US IT'S
TEN MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TO COMPLY
WITH THE STATE'S NEW HOUSING
LAWS. OUR NUMBER VERSIONS THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO PROPOSES IN
PARTICULAR THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES TO WITHDRAW TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING PROGRAM PROVIDED IN
LAST YEAR BUDGET. AND RIVER
ABOUT HALF OF THE FUNDING
PROVIDED FOR THE INFO
INFRASTRUCTURE OP PROGRAM RIGHT
AT LAST. LASTLY THE UNMET.
SISTER I. WHICH UPPER PULL BACK
ALL FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE HOUSING NAVIGATOR PROGRAM.
THE LAST TWO ITEMS ON THIS
CHART HAVE TO DO WITH SPECIAL
FUND LOANS AND TRANSFERS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES AS
PART OF ITS EFFORT TO DEAL WITH
THE DETERIORATING GENERAL FUND
CONDITION. IT DOESN'T HURT FROM
A VERY OF DIFFERENT HOUSING
RELATED PROGRAMS. TURNING TO
THE NEXT PAGE WE HIGHLIGHT A
FEW QUESTIONS FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION. UP PARTICULARLY
ABOUT ROOM KEY I'LL HIGHLIGHT A
FEW OF THEM HOW WOULD LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN THE FACILITIES WHAT
SORT OF SERVICES WITH A BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE INDIVIDUALS
RESIDING IN THE- ALONG WITH
INDIVIDUALS BE ABLE TO
STANDING. WHAT SORT OF
OVERSIGHT WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND STATE HAVE OF HOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE UTILIZING THESE
RESOURCES PURCHASED BY THE
STATE. PAGE SIX EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION. THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSED
INCREASE EMPLOYEE NON
RETIREMENT BENEFIT IN PLAY
COMPENSATION BY ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT
ALL OF THE PROVISIONS OF THE
EXISTING MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE STATE'S
BARGAINING. THE MAYOR VISION IT.
IN DOLLARS TO PAY FOR INCREASES
IN HEALTH PREMIUMS AND SOME OF
THESE PAY INCREASES HOWEVER THE
MAYOR VISION ALSO PROPOSES TO
REDUCE EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION BY
A POINT EIGHT BILLION. THE
ASSOCIATED WITH TO- IS ROUGHLY
EQUIVALENT TO FURLOUGH DAYS PER
MONTH FOR STATE EMPLOYEES. THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES HOWEVER TO
ACHIEVE THESE SAVINGS THROUGH
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WITH THE
STATE'S BARGAINING UNITS.
TURNING TO PAGE SEVEN FOR
APARTMENTS WE AGREE THAT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IS THE
PREFERRED METHOD FOR ACHIEVING
THIS THINGS. AT FOUR AM FOR
ACHIEVING SAVINGS AT. FROM
IMPOSING EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION
REDUCTIONS HOPEFULLY THAT WILL
HELP MAINTAIN THE RELATIONS
BETWEEN THE STATE'S BARGAINING
UNITS AND THE STATE. WE ALSO
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ADVISE THE
ADMINISTRATION EMBARKING
BARGAINING UNITS TO USE
ALTERNATIVE OTHER THAN FOR LAWS
TO ACHIEVE THESE SAVINGS AS
FOLLOWS HAVE IMPLICATIONS FOR
THE STATE'S LONG TERM
LIABILITIES. TURNING TO PAGE
EIGHT ON PENSIONS. AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL RECALL THE
STATE MADE NEARLY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS TO CALPERS AND CAL
STIRS LAST YEAR AS PART OF THE
BUDGET. IF SUPPLEMENTAL MEN'S
FOR OVER AND ABOVE WHAT THE
STATE WOULD NORMALLY BE
REQUIRED TO CONTRIBUTE TO THESE
PENSION SYSTEMS. THERE ALSO WAS
A PLAN TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS TOTALING
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
CAL HERS OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS AS PART OF THE JANUARY
BUDGET THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED TO
ACCELERATE HE- IN MAY THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO REPURPOSE
ALMOST. THE ENTIRETY OF THE
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS FROM SOME
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
DISAPPOINTING PAYMENTS FOR BOTH
CALPERS AND CASTERS. BY TURNING
THESE PAYMENTS AND
DISAPPOINTING PAYMENTS IT WOULD
REDUCE STATE COSTS AND SCHOOL
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE AFFECT US
FOR REQUIRED PENSION PAYMENTS
FOR THE NEXT FEW. IN ADDITION
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
SUSPEND CASTERS ABILITY TO
INCREASE THE STATE'S
CONTRIBUTION RATE FOR THAT
PENSION SYSTEM FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS. IN TERMS OF OUR
COMMENTS THE ADMINITRATION'S
PROPOSAL DOES ACHIEVE SOME
SHORT TERM FIX SOME SHORT TERM
SAVINGS BY TURNING THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS INTO THE
PLANTING PAYMENTS HOWEVER.
STATE COST BURKE WOULD BE A
LIKELY HIGHER IN THE LONG TERM.
WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
SUSPEND MCALISTER'S RATE RATE
INCREASE AUTHORITY AND WORRY
THAT IT WOULD WEAKEN THE
FUNDING PLAN ACHIEVED BY THE
STATE AND TWENTY FOURTEEN.
PENSIONS SOME. PAGE NINE
GOVERNMENT REORGANIZATION AND
RESTRUCTURING. AT THE CHAIR
NOTED THERE ARE A NUMBER OF A
PROPOSALS FOR RESTRUCTURING AND
NEW DEPARTMENTS AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET SOME
OF THESE CONTINUE INTO MAY. IN
PARTICULAR IN JANUARY THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED A NEW
DEPARTMENT OF BETTER JOBS AND
HIGHER WAGES. THIS WOULD
CONSOLIDATE ITS ACTIVITIES
WITHIN THE LABOR AGENCY. THE
GOVERNOR HAD BUDGETED TWO
POINT. IN ONE TIME RESOURCES TO
AN EXECUTIVE TEAM. THE MINARET
REVISION WITHDRAWS THE FOR A
THE FUNDING FOR THE NEW
DEPARTMENT BUT DOES CONTINUE
THE PROPOSAL TO FORM THE NEW
DEPARTMENT. TERMS OF OUR
COMMENTS GIVEN THE CURRENT-WORKLOAD EDT RELATED TO THE ON
PRESIDENT AND UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CLAIMS INCLUDING
RAPPER RAPID IMPLEMENTATION OF
NEW FEDERAL PROGRAMS. IT'S
UNCLEAR WHETHER THE LABOR
AGENCY AND DEPARTMENT STAFF
COULD DEDICATE AND RESOURCES
NEEDED. AT THIS TIME. MOVING TO
THE CANNABIS LICENSING
DEPARTMENT IN JANUARY THE
GOVERNOR HAD EXPRESSED INTENT
TO CONSOLIDATE THE CAMP
CANNABIS RELATED LICENSING
FUNCTIONS OF THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL PERMIT. OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC IN NEW
DEPARTMENT OF CANADA TROLL
STARTING IN THE BUDGET YEAR. IN
THE MAYOR VISION THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES TO DELAY THIS
CONSOLIDATION UNTIL NEXT YEAR.
FIND THE CONCEPT OF THE
CONSOLIDATION TO BE PROMISING
WE FIND THAT THE DELAY ALSO IS
REASONABLE GIVEN CURRENT
CONDITIONS. MOVE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT. THREE NAMING THE
OVERSIGHT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION AS
WELL AS EXTENDING ITS
AUTHORITIES INCLUDING AND
ABILITY TO TAKE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS AGAINST FINANCIAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS FOR UNFAIR
DECEPTIVE OR ABUSIVE ACTS OR
PRACTICES AND REGISTER
PROVIDERS OF CONSUMER IT'LL
START AS- I HAD. WAS TEN POINT
MILLION DOLLARS SPECIAL FUND
FOR THIS NEW EXPANDED
DEPARTMENTS. THE MERIDEN
CONTINUES THIS PROPOSAL HOWEVER
IT DOES MAKE THE FUNDING
CONTENT CONTINGENT ON THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTING THE
STATUTORY CHANGES. WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
THIS PROPOSAL THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE POLICY PROCESS TO
ENSURE ITS ABILITY TO
EFFECTIVELY SCREWED NEITHER
CHANGE X. SCRUTINIZE THE
CHANGES AND ALIGN THE FUNDING
WITH ANY WITH THE FINAL SET OF
RESPONSIBILITIES. LASTLY THE
SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION IN
JANUARY THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
TO TRANSFER THE SEISMIC SAFETY
COMMISSION TO THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES FOR ROUGHLY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS. ACOSTA
ROUGHLY MORE MET. THE GOVERNOR
CONTINUES THIS PURPOSE AT THIS
TRANSFER PROPOSAL IN MAY BUT
THE FUNDING AMOUNT IS REDUCED
BY ABOUT HALF. WE AGAIN REMARKS
AND DELAYING THIS DECISION TO
NEXT YEAR TO OPEN TO ALLOW FOR
MORE OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH THE
TRADE OFFS. OTHER COULD BE SOME
EFFICIENCY. IT DOES REDUCE THE
SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION'S
INDEPENDENCE WHICH HAS BEEN OF
AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. TURNING TO PAGE
ELEVEN WRITING IN SEARCH OTHER
ISSUES STATE OFFICE BUILDING.
THE MAIN REVISION WITHDRAWS A
PROPOSAL FOR ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN LEASE REVENUE BONDS
FUNDING FOR THE DESIGN BUILD
PHASE RENOVATIONS OF THE BATES
SENT. JESSE UNDER NATURAL
RESOURCES BUILDINGS TO ALLOW
THE STATE TO REEVALUATE ITS
OFFICE AT SPACE NEEDS IN A LONG
REASONABLE YES NO THE GENERAL
FUND AND THE VALUE OF THE
PROPOSED REEVALUATION.
SIMILARLY FOR THE STATE PROJECT
INFRASTRUCTURE FIND THE MAY
WERE VERSION AB PROPOSES TO
TRANSFER ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
STATE PROJECT INFRASTRUCTURE
FIND ACT THE GENERAL FUND.
THESE FUNDS HAD BEEN LOCATED
FOR THE WILL ANNEXED CHECKED
AND NOT BE FUNDED WITH WE
SPENDING BOND FUNDING. WHEN THE
CHANGE IT OFTEN CONDITION WE
FIND THAT PROPOSAL IS
REASONABLE. TURNING TO PAGE
TWELVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. THE MAYOR
VISION PROPOSAL IS TO BORROW
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM NOT ABLE
BOARD FOR A SPECIAL FUNDS. IN
GENERAL THE FUNDS IDENTIFIED BY
THE MINISTRY TO BORROW FROM. A
LIKELY WOULD BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THE LOANS AND THEN IN THE NEAR
TERM. IN SOME CASES HOWEVER.
CAMPER THE FUNDS ABILITY TO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL ACTIVITIES
IN THE FUTURE. SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH TO CONSIDER A
DIFFERENT MIX OF OUR OF
BORROWING WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ASSIST. MOVING TO DC A FEE
INCREASES THE MAYOR VERSION
ALSO PROPOSES TO INCREASES
INCREASED FEES FOR FIVE OR TEN
BUREAUS. AS PART OF THE
MARRIAGE AND- WELL THE FEE
INCREASES APPEAR NECESSARY AND
ARE CURRENTLY SUPPORTED BY THE
COMMISSION FEET STUDIES. THESE
TYPES OF INCREASES ARE
TYPICALLY CONSIDERED THROUGH
THE POLICY PROCESS RATHER THAN
THE BUDGET. MOVING TO PAGE
THIRTEEN. ELECTIONS THE
GOVERNOR ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT
REQUIRES ALL COUNTIES TO
CONDUCT VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS IN
PERSON VOTING WOULD BE
RESTRICTED TO A CERTAIN OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH CERTAIN LIKE
THOSE. PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES NEED A DISTANCE TO
VOTE. THE MAYOR VETERAN DOES
NOT PROPOSE ANY FUNDING FOR
COUNTIES TO HELP THEM WITH THIS
TAX. WE FIND THAT COUNTIES ARE
VERY LIKELY TO NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO CONDUCT A
PREDOMINATELY VOTE BY MAIL
ELECTION. MOREOVER GIVEN THE
REVENUE LOSS TO STAND BY COUNTY
IS AS A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC
INDUCED RECESSION AND THE
STATE'S CLEAR INTEREST IN WELL
ADMINISTERED ELECTIONS. WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER PROVIDE PROVIDING
FUNDING TO COUNTY GOVERNMENTS
FOR ELECTIONS ADMINISTRATION.
IT COULD BE PROVIDED THROUGH
LOW INTEREST LOANS ARE MATCHING
ON A MATCHING BASIS AS IT'S
BEEN DONE IN YEARS PAST. MOVIE
VETERANS HOMES THE MAYOR VISION
PROPOSES TO CLOSE THE BARSTOW
VETERANS HOME AT A NET COST OF
TWO POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. BUT WITH ANNUAL
SAVINGS OF FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ONCE THE CLOSURE IS
COMPLETE. WELL WE FIND THAT THE
PROPOSAL HAS MERIT IN CONCEPT.
GIVEN THAT THE FACILITY HAS
HAVING CHALLENGES AND IS ONLY
OPERATING AT HALF CAPACITY THE
DEPARTMENT HAS NOT YET FULLY
ENGAGE WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
DEVELOP A CLOSURE PLAN AND
RESIDENT TRANSFERS. GIVEN THE
POINT FOR POSTPONING ALTHOUGH
WE'RE NOT FOREGO ANY SAVINGS
THE LEGISLATURE COULD REJECT
THE PROPOSAL AND INSTEAD POTS
ADMISSIONS INTO BARSTOW AND
DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT TO
DEVELOP A CLOSURE PLAN OVER THE
NEXT YEAR. I IN TERMS OF OTHER
CANNABIS RELATED PROPOSALS THE
MERE VISION INCLUDES FOR A
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN MONTHLY ONGOING
FUNDS TO THE CANNABIS CONTROL
FUND. TO BE SIXTIES C. S. C. D.
F. A. AND DPH FOR CANNABIS
ACTIVITIES AS IN PAST YEARS THE
MAYOR THE BUDGET ALSO- IS
PROPOSED TO INCLUDE UNLIMITED
AUGMENTATION SO THE
ADMINISTRATION. FOR LICENSING
AND FOURTH INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SUBJECT TO JAIL BC
NOTIFICATION. THE MAYOR HAS
BEEN ALSO PROPOSE A STATUTORY
CHANGE CHANGES TO SHELVE SWORN
OFFICERS FROM DC IS DIVISION OF
INVESTIGATION TO BCC AND DELAYS
A JANUARY PROPOSAL CHANGE THE
POINT OF COLLECTION FOR
CANNABIS TAXES. GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING NEEDED WE RECOMMEND
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR BCC CDF
MD PHD ON A ONE YEAR RATHER THE
ON GOING BASIS. WE ALSO WRECKED
REJECTED ABOUT THE PROPOSED
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE. AT TO
PROVIDE UNLIMITED AUGMENTATIONS
OF THAT IT DOES NOT PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE SUFFICIENT
OVERSIGHT OVER THE DEPARTMENT
GETS. WE FIND IT'S REASONABLE
TO SHAPESHIFT SWORN OFFICERS TO
BCC AND DELAYING. CHANGING THE
POINT OF COLLECTION FOR
CANNABIS TAXES UNTIL NEXT YEAR.
ON THE LAST PAGE FIFTEEN
REVENUE PROPOSALS. THE MAYOR
VISION INCLUDES TWO SIGNIFICANT
REVENUE SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
THE BUDGET PROBLEM SPECIFICALLY
THE MEROVINGIAN WOULD LIMIT THE
USE OF CREDIT THAT IS-
BUSINESSES COULD ONLY USE UP TO
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN CREDITS
TO AGAINST THEIR TAXABLE INCOME.
AND IT ALSO SUSPEND THE USED.
FOR READING LOSSES THIS IS ONE
BUSINESSES CAN. OFFSET THEIR
TAX LIABILITY WITH LOSSES THAT
THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED IN PRIOR
YEARS. IF PROPOSALS GENERALLY
SHIFT THE TIMING OF PAYMENTS
FOR BUSINESSES FROM FUTURE
YEARS INTO THE BUDGET YOU'RE-
RATHER THAN INCREASE TAXES OVER
THE LONG TERM IN TOTAL. IN MANY
ASIAN ESTIMATES THAT THESE TWO
CHANGES WOULD INCREASE REVENUE
BY A TOTAL OF FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS. WE BELIEVE
THESE TWO PROPOSALS ARE
REASONABLE STARTING POINT FOR
DELIBERATION. BUT WE ALSO BUT
WE HAVE LOWER F. THROUGH THE
TERMS OF THE AMOUNT OF REVENUE
THAT WE EXPECT TO BE RAISED IN
THE ADMINISTRATION.
SPECIFICALLY THAT THE TOTAL
REVENUE RATES WOULD LIKELY BE
BETWEEN TWO POINT. THREE POINT
SIX DOLLARS. WE ALSO HAVE
SUGGESTIONS ABOUT HOW TO CHANGE
THE PROPOSAL TO TREAT
BUSINESSES MORE EQUITABLY.
THERE ALSO ARE ARE SOME OTHER
SMALLER REVENUE PROPOSALS
INCLUDED ON THIS CHART THAT THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSAL PROPOSES AND
ALSO NOTE THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
MAINTAINS HIS VAPE TAX
PROPOSAL. FOR JANUARY IN THE
MAYOR AND- THAT IS NOT INCLUDED
ON THE CHART. THE BOTTOM HALF
OF THIS FIGURE LAYS OUT SOME OF
OUR ALTERNATIVE REVENUE
SOLUTIONS I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
TALK FOR ANY OF THOSE TO THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
WITH THAT I CONCLUDE- MY
PREPARED AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU ANY
COMMENTS FROM FINANCE. MINOR
ONE ZERO FOR OUR PHONE
PARTICIPANTS. A GOOD MORNING
CHRIS STILL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THINK THE LA ALL GAVE
A VERY COMPREHENSIVE OVERVIEW
OF THE SITUATION LIES THE AND
ON I JUST NOTE THAT COLLEAGUES
AND I ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS A MEMBERS. OF.
ACTUALLY COUPLE QUESTIONS FROM
EVERY DAY MY OFFICE GETS TEN TO
TWENTY DESPERATE CALLS FOR
ASSISTANCE. DID A COVER
NINETEEN THIS FROM MCCARTY DD.
ADDRESS THESE CALLS ALL FOCUS
ON THE SAME PROBLEM. WELL I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A VERY
CHALLENGING TIME FOR YOU. CAN
NEVER PLACE THIS POINT. OUT THE
PRO. TO BE. AND LIVING THE
BENEFITS NAY TOP MANNER. AS A
GOVERNOR PROCESS. HER SOME EXAM
THE TOPIC ALL BY DISTRICT THE
RECEIVING. REGARDING THE
CHALLENGE BENEFITS. WE GOT A
WORKER FROM CARD ANY THAT IS
HAVING APPLYING FOR YOU I CAL
HER CAL'S BEEN FROZEN SINCE
FEBRUARY SECOND. IN THOSE LAST
FEW I CHECK SHE'S RCEIVED YOU
ARE ALIGNED SHOW THAT SHE
EXACERBATE IF IT'S MUCH YES NO
LACKEY WHAT. SHE THINKS MAYBE I
DIDN'T. JUST CAN IT CAN. MEN
CALLING BOTH IN THE TWO SUPPORT
LINE FOR HELP TO NO AVAIL. HER
DARK SCHOOL CLOSED IF YOU STOP
WORKING BECAUSE SHE CAN'T TAKE
HER DAUGHTER TO WORK WITH HER.
CORRECT SO THE LOST HIS JOB ON
MONDAY. SO HE CAN'T PAY CHILD
SUPPORT. SHE'S DOWN. TO OUR
LAST TWO DOLLARS IN ITS CAL
FRESH. YEAH CAN YOU TYPICALLY
HOW MANY STAFFERS CLAIM SUPPORT
LINE. AND HOW MANY TO A
TECHNICAL HOTLINE. THIS IS KIND
OF WHAT IT'S LIKE TO CALL THE
D. RIGHT NOW IS. GOOD MORNING.
HI MY NAME IS SHERRIN HIRED I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF. THE MOMENT ALL
DEPARTMENT I ALSO HAVE MICHELLE
SUTTON RIGS ARE. THAT THE
DIRECTOR OF THE U. I. BRANCH AS
WELL AS AT ALL RIGHT AND- WHO
IS OUR ADMIN DEPUTY. SO I THINK
I HARD YOU WANTED TO ASK
PACIFIC WE ABOUT THE- AND THE
NUMBERS THAT WE HAVE- FOR. OUR
TWO LINES CORRECT WE HAVE A
TOTAL. WE HAVE A TOTAL OF
ELEVEN HUNDRED PEOPLE. AND
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF HIRING
SIX HUNDRED- ADDITIONAL STAFF
FOR THE CALL CENTER WE HIRED
WITHIN THE NEXT TWO WEEKS. AT
WILL TURN AROUND AND DO A MEDIA
TRAINING GET THEM ON THE PHONE
BUT EARLY JUNE AS WELL. ARE
THERE ANY PLANS HOURS OF A
HOTLINE. WHAT WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT DOING WE'RE STARTING
TO LOOK AT THEM SORRY ABOUT
THAT- EMERGING ARE TO CALL
LINES WERE AND- INTO ONE SO WE
PROVIDE EIGHT TO PROVIDE FULL
SERVICE. UP AND LOOK AT A
SKILLED FIFTH. UP TO ENSURE THE
CONSISTENCY OF ANSWERS- AMONG
ALL THAT. ASIAN BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THAT HAS BEEN AN ISSUE FOR
SOME CLAIMANTS THAT SOMETIMES
IF CALLED AND OF GOTTEN
DIFFERENT ANSWERS. SO WE'RE
LOOKING- WORKING WITH THE
VENDOR TO DO HOW ARE CALL
CENTERS. IN ORDER TO BETTER
RESPOND TO OUR CUSTOMERS WE'VE
ALSO- INCREASE THE TRAINING-
FOR OUR- NEW. OUR NEW AGENTS SO
THEY CAN HANDLE UP 272% OF ALL
CALLS RIGHT NOW- SAVING
EXPERIENCE YOU AYE CLAIM
PROCESS THERE. YOU HAVE ALL THE
MORE COMPLEX CALLED. EVEN
THOUGH THE HOURS ARE STILL
THERE FROM EIGHT AM TO EIGHT PM
I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT THE CLAIM
HOTLINE ONLY OPERATES FROM
EIGHT AM TILL TWELVE NOON. IN
THE ALWAYS EAT THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE LINE WHICH DEALS
WITH PETER FILLING OUT THE
FORMS PETER ISSUES. GOES REST
THE TIME IS THAT CHIU THE
QUICKLY MAKE CLAIMS FROM EIGHT
O'CLOCK TILL TWELVE PM WHICH IS
A SPELL FOR HOURS I'M- WHAT. IT
I'M ARE A EIGHT LINE AS
PRIMARILY FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND IT DOES NOW.
PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF CLAIM
INFORMATION. BUT IF A CUSTOMER
NEEDS TO HAVE THEIR- THEIR YOU
APPLICATION FILED OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS ELEVATED OR
ESCALATED. INTO FOR THE MOST
PART DURING THIS PANDEMIC THE
CLAIM HOTLINE IS ONLY BEEN OPEN
FOR HOURS IS THAT WOULD THAT BE
CORRECT. UP WELL WHEN WE
STARTED THE EIGHT TO EIGHT
WHICH WAS WHAT- AND MID APRIL-
WE'VE HAD THAT ESCALATION
ABILITY THAT THE ENTIRE TIME-
FOR THOSE. FOR THOSE CLAIMS
THAT ABSOLUTELY NEEDED TO SPEAK
TO. A REPRESENTATIVE IN ORDER
TO HAVE THEIR CLAIM FILED ON
THEIR BEHALF. OF THOSE ARE
RELATED. WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
SAME FOLKS THAT SWITCH OVER IT
AT TWELVE O'CLOCK THE SAME
FOLKS THE SAME CALL TAKERS AT
SWITCH FROM THE CLAIM OUTLINED
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SO IN
ESSENCE THEY DIDN'T HAVE A
CROSS DUTIES. SO OUR CLAIM
PROCESSORS HAVE- I HAVE ALWAYS
WORK THAT WAY- WE HAVE BEEN
USEFUL- PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC.
BETWEEN EIGHT AND TWELVE
THEY'VE BEEN ON THE PHONES AND
THEN FROM THE PRESS THE DAY ON
IS WITH WHEN THEY PROCESS ALL
THE- SO. UNDER VERY HIGH
TECHNICAL LEAD. OF SO THAT THAT
WAS FOUND AT THE MOST. WAY IN
ORDER TO PROCESS AS MANY CLAIMS
AS AS WE CAN. MR GLORIA THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IT IN THIS
ORDER PLEASE STAND BY BECAUSE I
THESE ARE QUESTIONS FOR YOU AND
YOUR YOUR COLLEAGUES BY PJ
MISTREATMENT CHANCE TO BE HERE
THE COMMITTEE TO ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT MY CONSTITUENTS
OBVIOUSLY- I HEARD YOU TALK
ABOUT THE ADDITIONAL STAFF IT'S
COMING ON LINE IN THE MEN'S TO
PURGE THE CALLS. YOU HAVEN'T.
FOR HOW CAN EXPECT TO BE ABLE
TO GET OF APPLICATIONS FOR
RATHER THAN JUST REPORTED THE
CALL CENTER WELL WE'LL BRING IN
FOR THE NEXT SIX HUNDRED-
ONLINE THEY SHOULD BE
EXCITEMENT CHEN. AND WE'RE
GETTING READY ALTHOUGH WE'RE
GETTING READY TO HIRE TOTAL
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE RIGHT
NOW- IN ORDER TO PROPERTY CLAIM
IS AN ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT I
THINK I'VE- EARLIER. UP AND
WERE AROUND A GOING INTO
ANOTHER STE SECOND BIG HUGE
FIRE TO- BE SURE THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS ALL THE ISSUES. OF WE
BELIEVE THAT WITH THE FUNDING
THAT'S COMING NEXT FISCAL YEAR
THAT WILL HAVE PLENTY OF BUT IN
ORDER TO. CONTINUE TO QUICKLY
AMP UP- OUR SERVICES BOTH IN
THE CALL FOR HER AS WELL AS
WITH PROCESSING. SO THAT'S
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE GOING SO-
ARE HIRING RIGHT NOW WE SHOULD
HAVE EVERYONE ON BOARD IN THE
NEXT TWO WEEKS. EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED AND THEN. LIKE I SAID
RIGHT AROUND AND OTHER BIG
THING OF. ASSISTANCE ABOUT ART
AND CAL HR HAVE BEEN. I'M A
VERY A GARAGE HIGHER. FIRING UP.
TO UNDERSTAND THAT EIGHT IF YOU
IF YOU CAN ONE STARTED WE WERE
AT THE LOWEST AND THREE POINT
9% UNEMPLOYMENTRATE WELL OUR
STAFF WAS AT THAT SAME LEVEL.
SO WE HAD TO TURN ON A DIME IN
ORDER TO START PROCESSING
CLAIMS. THAT INSTEAD OF TWO TO
FIVE THOUSAND EVERY DAY UP TO I
THINK OUR OUR HIGH STATE WAS
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND A DAY. SO I THINK WITH
THE SAME AMOUNT OF. SO I MEAN
THAT'S OUR MAIN TEACHER WHAT
WE'RE REALLY. RIGHT NOW IS TO.
CONTINUE TO RAMP UP
SIGNIFICANTLY- ADDRESS ALL
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS
STREAMLINED OUR PROCESSES. WERE
HITTING IT FROM THREE ANGLE-
IMPROVE COMMUNICATIONS- IMPROVE
OUR WEBSITE- WE PUT- A
PANDEMIC- AT ALL WEBSITE. WITH
DENSER FAQS THE SOONER SO AN
ACUTE I'M SURE. THANK YOU AS- I
AM SYMPATHETIC TO THE SITUATION
THE DEPARTMENT FIND YOURSELVES
AND I RECOGNIZE THAT JUST A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO THERE WAS NOT
A HUGE IF YOUR SERVICE IS. A
THAT IS CHANGED RADICALLY I
RECOGNIZE AT THE SAME TIME.
PROBE OFFICE CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL CARES THAT. BUT
ULTIMATELY WHAT I THINK WE HAVE
TO BE THINKING ABOUT GO FORWARD.
AND SO THAT'S THE CLAIM. FOR
PHONE CALL TO BE. IF YOU COUNT
BEFORE FOR CLAIM SUPPORT TO BE
GOING FROM EIGHT TO EIGHT AT
THE CALL CENTER. I CAN'T GIVE
YOU THAT DATE RIGHT NOW- AGAIN
WE DO ALREADY HAVE THAT IT UP
PEOPLE ARE ESCALATED IF THEY
NEED ASSISTANCE DURING EIGHT TO
EIGHT. SO IT'S NOT IT'S NOT THE
DATE. IT'S NOT AVAILABLE WITH
IT IT IS. BUT THE PRIMARILY USE
FOR ASSISTANCE THAT WE DID
INCREASE THE ACCESS SYSTEM
ACCESS FOR ALL THE- AGENTS THAT
WORK EIGHT TO EIGHT. AS WELL AS
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL TRAINING. SO
HOW THEY WERE WHEN THEY STARTED
VERSUS HOW THEY ARE NOW IS MUCH
DIFFERENT. UNDERSTOOD IT MAYBE
YOU CAN GO BACK IF YOU CAN
PROVIDE US SOME SORT OF TIME TO
LET FOLKS. RIGHT NOW WILL
CONSTITUENTS TELL. THEY CALL
NUMBER. GO THE PHONE THREE. AND
THEN THEY HUNG. IN I RECOGNIZE
THAT YOU SAID YOU HAVE TO
PASSED FOR GETTING THE PERCENT
OF A CALL CARE WHEN THEY COME
IN BUT MAN I IT'S NOT WHAT MY
ALL. IF I CAN TO TRY TO ANOTHER
PART OF BECAUSE MY ALL AND I
I'M A CO OFFER BECAUSE THE FACT
OF CENTERS FOR DE WHAT WE'RE
FRESH BY IS THAT THE WE'RE TAKE
ON THAT WAS WHICH IS OUR JOB WE
DON'T HAVE A GOOD RISK TIME
TERMS ARE ENCOURAGED ON BEHALF
OF OUR CAN. HELLO CAN YOU SPEAK
TO YOU HAVE. HI WE- ALL RIGHT
IT WILL WHEN THIS WE THE FIRST
OFF WITHOUT WITH CONSTITUENTS.
AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO BRING
THAT INTO IT THESE LIKE A WEEK-
TO BE MUCH MORE RESPONSIVE
BECAUSE WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THAT I MEAN PEOPLE ARE NEEDING
ACOSTA AND I DO WANT TO ALL OF
YOU FOR ASSIST US IN AND
GETTING THE WORD OUT AND
HELPING CLAIMANTS TO WORK
THROUGH EASY. ANSWER YOUR- LAST
NIGHT. WE EXPERTS WERE HAVING
NOW WE PRESUMABLY WILL BE DOWN
TO A WEAK RESPONSE TIME.
STARTING TODAY STARTING NEXT
WEEK THAT WE JUST ADDED TWENTY
MORE PEOPLE STORE UP TO FORTY
FIVE NOW SO WE'RE HOPING TO GET
THROUGH THE BACK LOT THE NEXT
TO YOU KNOW COVER TWO THREE
WEEKS. AND REALLY GET THINGS
CAUGHT UP. ON OKAY SO THEN I
RECOGNIZE THAT A BIG PART OF
THIS CHALLENGE IS THE
ANTIQUATED- INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM THAT'S BEING
USED ONE GETTING DONE TO
IMPROVE TECH. SO THAT THAT
MEANS THE BANK WE ARE HOLDING
UP CATIONS CAN BE ACCEPTED I IN
SOME FORMAT OTHER THAN NECK
PAIN AFFECTS OUR OUR- CURRENTLY
EXCEPT. UHHUH SO PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC. IN. THE PROCESS OF
LEARNING HOW THE- SINCE MODERN
PROJECT. SO THE C. P. THAT THIS
FOR A COMING FORWARD WE ARE
READY TO- AWARD VENDOR YEAH.
LATE FALL AND WE'RE DOING A
FULL SCALE. PLACEMENT THE- YEAH
SOME. OF UP WHAT YOU CAN
BECAUSE WERE DEAL WITH THE IN
ARE YOU ARE ACTUALLY MAY UP OF
A FOUR FIVE DIFFERENT THAT ARE
BOLTED ONTO A MAIN FRAME SYSTEM
THAT STILL USE BALL PROGRAMMERS
YOU KNOW WHICH IS A FIFTY YEAR
OLD FROM. SO GOT A LOT. WE
BROUGHT AND VENDORS AND
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY AND OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION TO ASSIST US
DURING THIS TIME IN TOLL- RBS
THEM PROJECT IS ROLLED OUT-
UNFORTUNATELY THE PANDEMIC IT
PRIOR TO THIS ROLL OUT AND- AND
THAT'S WHAT'S BECAUSE SOME OF
THE LADIES IN GETTING THINGS
UP. AS YOU KNOW QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE HAVE A VERY
FLEXIBLE SYSTEM AND THAT'S A
VERY CHALLENGING SO FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THIS COMMITTEE
WHICH LOOKS AT THE BUT PROPOSED
BUDGET YOU THIS BUDGET IS
INCLUDE WHAT YOU NEED TO
MODERNIZE EIGHTIES TECHNOLOGY
PROGRAM. YES AND LIKE I SAID
WE'RE GETTING READY TO OF A-
AWARD A VENDOR HERE IN THE FALL
SO IT'S CRITICAL I MEAN THIS IS
WE HAVE BEEN ON THAT PATH FOR
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND- BECAUSE
WE- THE INFLEXIBILITY IT'S NOT
SUSTAINABLE LONG TERM OR- ANY
COBALT PROGRAMMER. WHAT WE
GOING ON IN. GOLDEN FOR A SMART
AND FOR OUR STAFF SO- WE ARE ON
TARGET- WITH OUR WITH OUR-
MODERN SYSTEM- PROJECT WE'VE
BEEN PARTNERING WITH CD TIANA
UP CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY TO EXPEDITE- THIS
WHOLE PROJECT IN THE PAST YEAR.
SO WE'RE ACTUALLY COMING OUT
AND OF AWARDING OF VENDOR. A
YEAR EARLIER THAN WE ORIGINALLY
ANTICIPATED SO WE'RE THRILLED
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE DEFINITELY
WE WANT TO MOVE TO A PLACE
WHERE WE NEED TO BE THAT ARE
RESPONSIVE TO HELP THE CITIZENS
THE CALIFORNIA. WHAT WE HAVE
NOW IS AND TO AND I'M RIGHT
THERE WITH YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER RIGHT AND ARE THE CHAIR-
WE HAVE A COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
MY PAST QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO
SEE MY TIME AND MAYBE COME BACK
TO THE SO YOU'RE TO FIVE. IF WE
ARE VICIOUS AT A TIME THANK YOU
MISTER TO. THANK YOU HELLO ME
FOR START BY. HAVE BEEN SERVING
ON A BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NOW
FOR SIX YEARS AND I'VE NEVER
BEEN TOLD UNTIL THIS HEARING.
BY COLLEAGUES THAT THEY'RE
JEALOUS THAT I SIT ON THIS
COMMITTEE BECAUSE- I. ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT EDTA AT THE
MOMENT. LET ME JUST START BY
SAYING THAT- YOU KNOW AGAIN WE
ALL APPRECIATE THE
UNPRECEDENTED PLACER AND BUT I
THINK WE'RE ALL EXPERIENCING
INCREDIBLE FRUSTRATION BECAUSE
NOT ONLY ARE OUR DISTRICT STAFF
WORKING ROUND THE CLOCK NOT
ONLY HAVE WE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE
HAD TO- IT INSTANCE AND MANY
OTHERS. PUSH OUR CAPITAL STAFF
TO ALSO BUT THIS UP BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE THERE ARE SOME A
NUMBER OF DECISIONS THAT COULD
BE MADE TO SORT OF ADDRESS THE
SITUATION RIGHT NOW SALUTE.
COUPLE QUESTIONS AT THE LAST
BRIEFING FOR LATEST STAFF EDT
SAID IF THEY WERE TO ANSWER THE
CURRENT LEVEL CALLS YOU NEED.
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND FOUR STEP.
IN THEM TO A- SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
RIGHT. OKAY SO I JUST WANNA SAY
I LOVE THE FACT THAT WERE ABOUT
TO GET I THINK EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
STAFF AND MAYBE SOME MORE THAT
WOULD MEAN WE WOULD HAVE ABOUT
6% OF THE STAFFING THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THE CHECK RIGHT OKAY
JUST WANT TO. SIT THERE NOW. I
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT 73% OF
YOUR CALLS. ARE SEEKING BASIC
INFORMATION ABOUT THE STATUS OF
CLAIMS. IT SEEMS TO US. THAT
YOU SHOULD BE DEVOTING A LOT
MORE TIME TRYING TO EDUCATE.
CLAIMANTS FOR HELPING TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH TOOLS TO
PROVIDE BASIC INFORMATION. AND
GET THAT YOU WANT TO HIRE
PEOPLE THE FRONTLINE AND I
SUPPORT THAT I WANT SUPPORT AS
MUCH AS WE NEED AT THIS TIME.
BUT IT IT'S A BIT BAFFLING TO
SEE HOW IT IS THAT WE'RE NOT
SPENDING TIME FOCUSING ON
PROVIDING THAT. INFORMATION SO
THAT WERE NOT ANSWERING THE
SAME QUESTIONS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN- AND GET. PERMISSION SO.
YOU'RE DOING IN THAT REGARD. SO
WE'VE GOT A LOT. BASS I'M-
HAVE. OUR ONLINE VIEWERS WATCH
WE'VE ALSO. DONE A WEB IN OUR-
BOTH. HOUSES WE- RESERVE OKAY.
WHAT MANY DIFFERENT. YOU WE
ALSO HAVE A NEW BEEN. GUIDE TO
HELP WALKS. THE PEOPLE UNDER.
WHICH IS ON OUR- WEBSITE. DO
THE PRESS. COMING PEOPLE THAT.
I'VE DEEP DOWN BY TO ANSWER
PEOPLE UNDER WE DONE WE'VE
RAMPED UP ALL OUR SOCIAL MEDIA
AT PROVIDING UPDATES. WE
STARTED JUST THIS LAST WEEK- A
PILOT FOR TEXTING MESSAGES OUT
TO PEOPLE. THAT SAYS YOU KNOW
YOUR PLANT WE RECEIVE YOUR
CLAIM AND OKAY HERE'S YOUR FOR
PAYMENT. I JUST STARTED IN THE
LAST WEEK AND THAT IS GOING TO
EXPAND. SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THAT WILL
KEEP PEOPLE INFORMED- WERE ALSO.
OLD A CHAT BOT A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO THAT PEOPLE CAN USE TO HELP
TRY TO ANSWER THOSE BASIC
QUESTIONS- AND WE CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT EVERYTHING AND ANYTHING
TO EXCESS- THE PUBLIC IN MAKING
SURE THEY KNOW HOW TO NAVIGATE
OR SYSTEM. AND I KNOW OF THIS
IT IS VERY CHALLENGING BECAUSE
YOU AYE PROGRAM IS COMPLEX AND
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME MANY
MANY PEOPLE ARE ON ARE
UNEMPLOYED. AND IT'S THEIR
FIRST- EXPERIENCE WITH THAT. SO
EVERYTHING YOU CAN POSSIBLY DO
TO MAKE IT EASIER TO- HOPEFULLY
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS PEOPLE
HAVE BEFORE THEY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THOROUGHLY FRUSTRATING
EXPERIENCE TO TRY TO GET.
THROUGH ONE AREA AND I KNOW OUR
COLLEAGUES TOUCH ON THIS IS
AROUND ID VERIFICATION WHICH-
WE HAVE HAD CONSTITUENTS WHO
HAD FOR FOUR WEEKS BEFORE
THEY'RE EVEN NOTIFIED OF AN ID
VERIFICATION ISSUE. AND THEN
AND SOME OF THOSE CASES IT
TAKES ANOTHER THREE WEEKS
BEFORE THEIR ID'S BEEN VERIFIED
AND IT SEEMS THAT A LOT OF THE-
COULD PREVENTABLE YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE A REVIEW PAGE TO PROP
CONSTITUENTS. TO CHECK THAT
INFORMATION SPEND CLEARLY- AT.
ENTERED CORRECTLY. BUT
WONDERING YOU KNOW REVIEW PAGES
DIFFERENT FROM SAY POP UP
WINDOW SOME SAY OF A- WARNING
UP OF P. SEE THEIR A- ABOUT THE
LAST AND PERSONAL. IF YOU
THOUGHT ABOUT WAY IS. THIS
TWEET THE RESPONSES SO THAT WE
LET PEOPLE KNOW. THE YOU HIT
THAT BUTTON YOU GOT A MAJOR
EVERY. APPS CORRECT BECAUSE
THAT IS CLEAR HANGING UP AN
AWFUL RIGHT NOW. RIGHT AND WE
DO HAVE THAT BILL TO THIS AND
WE ENCOURAGE PEOPLE LOOK AT YOU
KNOW WANTED IT ALL IN. TO GO
BACK AND LOOK AT EVERYTHING
AND- WE AND WE DO HAVE CHECKS
AND BALANCES TO MAKE SURE IN
OUR SYSTEM SO PEOPLE DON'T MAKE
ERRORS BUT AT. UNFORCED LINK
PEOPLE STILL CONTINUE TO
MEDICARE'S- BUT IF YOU HAVE
SPECIFIC SUGGESTIONS I YOU'LL
PLEASE SEND MY WAY. AND WOULD
LOVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT HIM AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANYTHING WE CAN
DO TO FINE TUNE OUR OUR SYSTEM.
I THINK I THINK THIS. IS JUST
JUST UP WINDOW OR SOME SORT OF
WARNING BEFORE PEOPLE SUBMIT
THEIR APPLICATIONS IF THEY GET
IT ON. DRAMATIC RIGHT IDENTITY
IS A PRESSURE POINT FOR US-RIGHT NOW- THAT'S ABOUT 1% OF
ALL OF OUR CASES WE DO HAVE A
BACKLOG BUT WE ARE MAKING
SUBSTANTIAL EFFORTS TO-
LIQUIDATE IN CLEAR AND GET
CAUGHT UP ON THAT BACK LAW
BECAUSE WE KNOW- WHEN WE
STARTED WE THIRTEEN WILL NOT
UNIT WE NOW HAVE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN THAT I JUST TRAIN
DIRECTED AND WE HAVEN'T. AND
TRAIN. EIGHT SWEET BECAUSE WE
WANT THAT WE KNOW THE CRITIC OF
IT- UNFORTUNATELY YOU KNOW ALL
CUSTOMERS GO THROUGH AN INITIAL
AUTOMATED- IDENTITY REVIEW- BUT
AS 3% KICK OUT OF FOR SECOND
LEVEL REVIEW IF YOU KNOW
THERE'S A SECURITY NUMBER
DOESN'T MATCH OR THE BURDEN AT
IT DOESN'T MATCH UP AND FROM
THERE BASS FOR SPECIFIC
DOCUMENTS- FROM FOLKS AND WE
HAD ABOUT 70% OF THEM BACK AND
THE OTHER THIRTY EIGHT IT'S
EITHER THERE FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
OR PEOPLE'S SITUATIONS OF
CHANGE OR OR WHAT NOT. SO BUT
BUT BUT IS OUR MAIN AND THEIR
PRIMARY BACKLOG COOL AIR YEAH
AND WE'RE HERE IT AND HITTING
IT HARD- OUR OVERALL CLAIMS WE
CONTINUE TO PROCESS WITHIN. THE
THREE WEEKS- BUT THIS IS
DEFINITELY A OUR PRESSURE POINT
BUT WE'RE IT IS ALL IS ON DECK
RIGHT NOW AROUND. THIS IDENTITY
BECAUSE BEEN WAITING TOO LONG
AND WE WERE BY THAT BUT WE NOW
HAVE PEOPLE TRAINED. AT WHICH-
DIRECTED AT TRAINED AND THEY'RE
UP AND RUNNING AND LIKE I SAID
WE HAVE NOW TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN WITH ANOTHER HUNDRED
AND FIFTY. BEING TRAINED NEXT
WEEK AND- LIKE I SAID PART OF
THE- OVERALL HIRING OF THE
EIGHTEEN BUT STAFF WILL
INCREASE IN THIS AREA. AND
WE'RE GONNA TURN AROUND AND DO
ANOTHER HIRING- CAN WE'RE JUST
GONNA CAN RAMP UP AND RAMP UP
AND FULL WEEK IN SURE THAT.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE YOU KNOW WE'RE
MOVING PEOPLE AROUND JUST TO
YOU KNOW KEEP UP THE BALLS IN
THE AIR RIGHT BECAUSE WE HAD
THE STAFF WE HAD EVEN THOUGH
WILL BE RE DIRECTED HUNDRED AND
HUNDREDS. STAFF FROM OTHER
STATES. BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY WE HAVE TO EXPAND OUR
CAPACITY SIGNIFICANTLY. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON-
AND WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF
CALYX ARE. BECAUSE LIKE IT'S
HOW MANY OF HOW MANY COBLE
CODERS YOU HAVE AT THIS POINT.
HOW MANY I WANT TO SAY FIFTEEN.
OKAY TEAM IS OUT OF MY PUTS OUT
A HALLMARK. I ONLY KNOW- ONLY
GET THAT THE SYSTEM ITSELF- YOU
KNOW. AT BECAUSE ARE
INFLEXIBLE- WE HAD TO DO THINGS
THE FINANCIALLY AND COULDN'T DO
THEM CONCURRENTLY SUCH AS LIKE
THE SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR STIMULUS
PANT WE HAD TO DO FIRST AND
THEN- PA YOU WAITED TO SECOND
AND THEN- NEXT ON THE TWENTY
SEVENTH WILL BE ROLLING OUT OF
THE EXPECTATIONS. OF THE
THIRTEEN WITH EXTENSIONS SO
WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT
AND I WILL SAY YESTERDAY TO WE
ARE PROGRAMMING WAS FINISHED SO
START RECALCULATING FOR THE
SELF EMPLOYED UNDER THE
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM- WE ACTUALLY
PAID OUT THE FIRST HUNDRED
SIXTY SEVEN. BUT NOW BE READ
RECALCULATED THEIR FAITH BASED
INCOME THEY TESTED. YEAH WILL
PAY THEM THAT THERE SO IF
THEY'RE ALL UP TO THE FOUR
FIFTY MATH. THAN THAT WHAT
THEY'LL GET AND I. THAT'S ON
TODAY TODAY. IF I COULD JUST
MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS AND THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE KNOWS MY FOCUS
WHEN IT COMES TO I. T. BUT- BOB
YOU KNOW RECENTLY THE HEAD OF
EDT PSYCHOLOGY DURING THE LAST
RECESSION WAS INTERVIEWED AND
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE FACT
THAT EDT AS A THIRTY YEAR. OLD
COMPUTER SYSTEM USING THIS. OLD
COMPUTER LANGUAGE THAT SO
OUTDATED THAT PEOPLE AGENCIES
ARE NOW FORCED TO BRING PEOPLE
OUT OF RETIREMENT. AND WHEN HE
WAS A CODER IN ET DE YEARS AGO
THEY HAD A HUNDRED FIFTY CODERS
AND NOW YOU'RE SAYING THAT THEY
HAVE FIFTEEN- AND- I UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE LOOKING TO MODERNIZE
YOUR SYSTEM I TOOK A LOOK AT.
THOSE PLANS- JUST FOR
COLLEAGUES TO KNOW- IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN YOU STARTED
THIS ELEVEN YOUR PROJECT. WORK
FOR YOU AND THERE'S ANOTHER STE
AND YOUR STICK WELL. I RED AND
ONE ANY AMOUNT OF MONEY BUT THE
TIME WE'RE DONE WITH THAT
TECHNOLOGY THAT WAS DECIDED ON
IS GOING TO BE OUT OF DATE. AND
SO KNOW FOR MY PERSPECTIVE I'M-
AYE THIS IS OBVIOUSLY.
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING I THINK-
IT YOU KNOW AS I'VE BEEN IT'S
BEEN SUGGESTED TO ME STARTED IN
OUR TEAM WITH THIS TECHNOLOGY
AND MEDIA EXPERIENCES LITTLE
BIT. HI AMY STILL. BACKED EACH
YEAR WELL AND- YOU KNOW IT'S A
LOT. BUT I'M SO SORRY- SO I
AGREED SO TO PREVENT THAT
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT SEVERAL
OUT OF SYSTEM THAT WAS JUST
GOING TO BE OBSOLETE IN DAY ONE
SO- PART OF OUR PROCESS AS WE
ARE GOING FOR OUR SHOW OFF THE
SHELF. OFFICIAL ON PRODUCT. OF
WHICH IS USED IN MANY OTHER
STATE SENATE SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
USE FOR OUR TAX SYSTEM. SO IT'S
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE VENDOR
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO UPGRADE
AN UPDATE AND BEST PRACTICES.
LIKE FOR LIKE A MOCK MICROSOFT
WINDOWS- YOU KNOW WE CONTINUE
GET UPGRADES AND BEST PRACTICES
THE SYSTEM THAT WE ARE LOOKING
TO. UTILIZE WILL BE A SYSTEM
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO STAY
CURRENT AND FLEXIBLE- I THINK
BACK WHEN WE HAD ALL THOSE
PROGRAMMERS WAS WHEN WE ONLY
HAVE- ME TRAIN SYSTEM. WE DID
DO SOMEONE CAN NINE YEARS AGO
WE'RE ADDED ON ALL THE ONLINE
FEATURES WHICH DOES NOT REQUIRE
FALL WE DON'T DON'T NEED A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMMERS. NOW THAT
WE NEEDED BACK THEN- BUT I WILL
TELL YOU WE'VE HAD TO TRAIN OUR
OWN COBALT PROGRAMMERS IN OUR
OWN PRO. DOES YOUR- BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW FINDING FOOTBALL
PROGRAM IS A- IS A DIFFICULT
TASK IN. BACK TO THE FUTURE YOU
KNOW LISTEN MY ONLY COMMENT ON
THIS IS THE IDEA THAT A
MODERNIZATION PROJECT IS GOING
TO TAKE ELEVEN YEARS IT'S
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE. AND WE
PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY WILL BE ON THIS
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS BUT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO HAVE SMALLER
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE TIME
THAT PASSING ON AT IT AROUND
LANGUAGE ACCESS SUCH. JUST CALL.
NO FULL WELL. WE HAVE. SO MANY
HIS EMPLOYER FROM ENGLISH AS
THEIR FIRST LANGUAGE. OUR IN
RIGHT THE CHALLENGE. FACING
THEM HOW OFTEN. AND HOW DOES ET
SS LANGUAGE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR STATE.
TIMELY ALATORRE ACT. SO YES SO
WE PARTICIPATE IN A TIMELY
AUDITORY- ERR I THINK EVERY FEW
YEARS AND IT'S GETTING READY TO
LAUNCH RIGHT NOW AND WE'VE HAD
A VERY GOOD COMPLIANCE RATE
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS- WE DO
OFFER FOR YOU I AN ENGLISH AND
SPANISH- A LOT. SITE ALL A CALL
CENTRE WE HAVE ENGLISH SPANISH
AND A FEW OTHER- DIRECT NUMBERS
FOR DIFFERENT LANGUAGES BUT WE
ALSO HAVE AN INTERNAL
DIRECTORY- FOR ALL LANGUAGES
THROUGHOUT OUR DEPARTMENT SO IF
SOMEONE CALLS AND LANGUAGE
ASSISTANCE WE HAVE SOMEONE THAT
WE CAN CONNECT THEM TO. WE TAKE
A LANGUAGE ISSUE AREAS BECAUSE
THAT YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T
NAVIGATE IF YOU CAN'T
UNDERSTAND PROPERLY THAT- AND
WITH THE HIRING OF EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE WE SPECIFICALLY
PLAN ARE AVERAGE. MEN YELL
DIFFERENT TOP BLANK DOES THAT
WERE SEEKING AND- UP SO WE'RE
LOOKING TO HIRE A LOTS OF A
BILINGUAL PEOPLE THAT'S OUR
HOPE. WELL I HEARD AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT PART OF THE
SYSTEM IS ON. SPANISH AND THEN
AS YOU REFER TO OTHER PART OF
THE SYSTEM IS ENGLISH AND
SPANISH AND A FEW OTHER
LANGUAGES WELL THE FEW OTHER
LANGUAGES AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
ARE THE APL LANGUAGE IS. THE
RIVER THANK NUMBER OF. TWO WHO
I AM HEARING ARE NOT BEING
SERVED BY YOUR DEPARTMENT SO- I
HAVE WONDERED IF EDT IS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH- WITH ACT AND
WHETHER WE NEED TO DO MORE. TO
PUT THAT I'VE WONDERED. OTHER
IN AGES. SHIFT LANGUAGE ACCESS
PERSON. TO ASSIST YOU GUYS
DURING THIS TIME BUT A DEVICE
TO SAY YOU KNOW THERE REALLY IS
A TREMENDOUS OR- MOMENT. TO
FOLKS GETTING AND I KNOW YOU
GET THAT BUT- BUT A SAID. NO
LASTING AND I'M GONNA TURN OVER
TO COLLEAGUES. YOU KNOW THAT
THERE'S AN INCREDIBLE
PERCEPTION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THAT EDIE'S WORK. IS
NOT JUST WAY TOO SLOW BUT IN
THEIR INTERACTIONS WITH YOUR
STAFF. SENSE OF URGENCY. THERE
IS A TREMENDOUS BUREAUCRACY
WERE NOT GETTING A CUSTOMER
FOCUSED WORKER FOCUSED- SORT OF
PERSPECTIVE WHEN OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE CALLING YOUR
OFFICE. AND I GET THAT THERE IS
AN UNPRECEDENTED WORKLOAD BUT I
BELIEVE THAT GOVERNMENT CAN DO
BETTER AND IT HAS TO DO BETTER
DURING THIS TIME. I KNOW YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT- YEAH WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS
THAT IS AN IMPERATIVE WE'VE NOT
HEARD THE TYPE OF. THE
SUFFERING PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING NOW JUST. WITH
REGARD TO THE SPEND BUT ONE
CALL YOUR- BUREAUCRACY IT SO
I'VE I'VE I'VE THAT THE
FEEDBACK ORGANIC IS TREACHEROUS
AND I BELIEVE WE CAN DO BETTER.
OUTLOOK COVERS US. CAMERA THE
POSITION IS THERE OF MY COLLEGE.
FOUR HUNDRED IN THE KEY. PART
STOP IT ONE OF BECAUSE OF THEIR
HEARING THIS ROOM. TO VACATE.
SO. TIME BECAUSE OF THE OTHER
SUBS TALK ABOUT SO WITH HIS
AREA. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
MIKE. THE TO CALL BEFORE ME WHO
A VERY AS MANY. AND SO I DON'T
MEAN TO BELABOR THE POINT
BECAUSE THERE'S JUST SO MANY
WAYS MULTIPLE WAYS YOU CAN CUT
A CERTAIN ISSUE BUT YOU'RE
STILL GOING TO BE PROVIDING THE
SAME ANSWERS TO US. SO I WANT
TO JUST. SEE IF THERE ARE SOME
AVENUES THAT WE CAN BE TAKING
THAT COULD HELP. ADDRESS SOME
OF THESE ISSUES FOR MY
COLLEAGUES. MR CHIU ASKING
QUESTIONS YOU ANSWERED WITH
FIFTEEN COBLE PER MY NEXT
QUESTION. CHECK OUT MY CALL WAS
WHAT THE RICH. WHAT IT. IS
GONNA PROMPT BUT WILL BE THAT
FOR NOW DAY. SO JUST GIVE YOU A
SNAPSHOT AND I'VE I SPOKEN OF
THIS WITH MISS SECRETARY AS
SOON AS WELL BUT JUST TO GIVE
YOU A STAFF. I AM MY STAFF TO
GIVE ME NO FOR THREE DAYS.
STARTING WITH THE TO A AND- IN
APRIL TWENTY ON APRIL TWENTY
EIGHTH THREE UNDER TWENTY SIX
CALLS ON THE TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ON THE
TWENTY NINTH AND THEN IT
TAPERED DOWN TO EIGHTY NINE BY
THE THIRTIETH AND EMAILS WERE
RESPECTIVELY FOR THE DAYS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR SEVENTY
FIFTY EIGHT. OF ROUGH IN FIFTY
UNIQUE MALES AND CALLED. IN
THREE D. IT HASN'T LET UP. OF
IT DOESN'T EVEN COUNTING SOCIAL
MEDIA AND ALL THE DIFFERENT
AVENUES OF COMMUNICATING WITH
OUR OFFICE OR INDIVIDUALS
WITHIN THE OFFICE NOW THIS IS
ALSO BEING BORN ON PRIMARILY
FOR FULL STAFF IS ONE DIRECTOR
THREE STAFFERS THE REST OF THE
CAPITOL OFFICE HAS ALSO BECOME
FIELD STAFFERS FIELDING ALL
TYPES OF CONSTITUENT. CASES I
APPRECIATE YOU SAYING THAT
WE'VE BEEN GOOD PARTNERS THE
PART OF THE CHALLENGE AND WHY
EMPHASIZE AND QUANTIFY THESE
NUMBERS. IS THAT. WE'VE WANTED
TO BE PARTNERS WE WANTED TO
BETTER BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
THE TIME LINES AND THE ISSUES
AND TO TRY TO GIVE AS MUCH
ANSWER TARKAN STATEMENTS AS
POSSIBLE SO THAT NOT ONLY ARE
WE MAINTAINING THEIR LEVEL OF
CONFIDENCE AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING. BUT TO ALSO BE ABLE
TO SHOW TO THEM THAT THERE IS A
LIGHT AND THE AT THE END OF THE
TUNNEL. AND THE PROBLEM. BECAME
EXACERBATED WHEN WE STOP
GETTING CALLS. TO OUR OFFICE
OUR CALLS RETURNED BY EDT. AND
YEAH. I AGAIN WE'VE ASKED ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY WE'VE ASKED
ABOUT WHAT WHEN WE CAN EXPECT
CERTAIN THINGS TO HAPPEN BUT I
THINK IT BEHOOVES YOU ANY
BECOMES EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
THAT OUR COMMUNICATION NEVER
BREAKS DOWN. SO THAT WE KNOW
WHAT WE ARE ALSO EXPLAINING TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND THAT WHAT
WE EXPLAIN TO THEM IS ACCURATE.
AND CONTINUES TO MAINTAIN THAT
LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE. SO THAT'S
ONE POINT ANOTHER POINT WAS I
THINK MR GLORIA TOUCHED ON THIS
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF IT IF HE
EXACTLY MENTIONED THIS BUT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT DIFFERENT
WAYS OF COMMUNICATION AND IT
SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A LACK TIME
WHEN THE COMMUNICATION TAKES
PLACE THROUGH MAIL. WHY AREN'T
WE EMPLOYING AN EMAIL SYSTEM SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN AND IT'S A
CHEAPER MORE COST EFFECTIVE WAY
AS WELL. THERE MIGHT BE
SECURITY RELATED ISSUES THAT
YOU'RE CONCERNED WITH AND I'D
BE INTERESTED TO KNOW IF. THAT
IS ONE OF THE REASONS BUT- WHY
AREN'T WE BETTER EMPLOYING
EMAILS SO THAT THE
COMMUNICATION CAN HAPPEN MUCH
QUICKER YOU SAID SOMETHING
ABOUT TEXTING. BUT STILL. AT
WE'RE NOT SEEING THAT EMAIL IS.
AS MUCH AS WE EXPECTED TO SEE
ESPECIALLY AT A TIME LIKE THIS
WHEN YOU ALSO WANT TO BE COST
EFFECTIVE. RIGHT THAT IS
SOMETHING WE JUST STARTED
EXPLORING WE- HAVE STARTED U.
UTILIZING EMAIL FOR- OUTBOUND
COMMUNICATIONS AND WE INTEND TO
DO MORE OF IT. SO FIFTH SO YES
I AGREE. TO THE DEGREE WE
CANNOT TO GET DEPENDING ON WHAT
THE DOCUMENTS ARE IN THE
COMMUNICATION. BUT IT IS
SOMETHING WE JUST STARTED AND
MORE WILL COME OF THAT. OKAY.
BY WELL AGAIN I DON'T BELIEVE
IT THE POINT BUT BY EXACTLY
WHEN DO YOU FEEL YOU'RE GONNA
BE AT A CERTAIN CAPACITY THAT
IS ADDRESSING A GREAT MAJORITY
OF. THE CLAIMANT'S QUESTIONS.
ALL ALL THE CLAIMANTS QUESTIONS
I MEAN AT THIS POINT I MEAN.
AND BY THE WAY TO A AYE I S.
THIS. BECAUSE IN IN NORMAL
TIMES WEEK FOR HER THAT THE
PRESENT AND DURING THE
PRESENTATION AND DURING OUR
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE HERE AS
WELL IT TAKES ABOUT THREE
WEEKS. RIGHT NOW MY STAFF IS
GETTING RESPONSES FROM BETWEEN
SIX TO SEVEN WEEKS AGO. I DON'T
KNOW IF MY OFFICE IS UNIQUE UP
I DON'T THINK IT IS. BUT SIX TO
SEVEN WEEKS AT A TIME WHEN.
SOMEONE YOU HAVEN'T HASN'T EVEN
HEARD. WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THEIR FATE. WHILE BLATTER ARE
BUY OLD TILING OR OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THEY FIND
THEMSELVES IN. A I AGAIN THIS
ISN'T THIS ISN'T TO BERATE EDT
IT'S JUST THAT- YOU ALSO CAN
UNDERSTAND AND YOUR EMPLOYEES
CAN UNDERSTAND THE PLIGHT
DIFFERENT PEOPLE CAME IN. A
GOOD. RESULT 80% OF THE
CHALLENGES. AND THAT'S WHERE I
AM I'M- THE YOU HEAR MY FIRST
OF ITEM UNDERSTAND. THAT
COMMUNICATION. ISN'T TAKING
PLACE IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
THAT. LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE ISN'T
BROKEN DOWN BECAUSE IT'S
COMPLETELY BROKEN AT THIS POINT
AND WE'RE JUST I THINK ALL
TRYING TO DO OUR PATCH OF WORK
TO MAKE SURE THE DAM DOESN'T
CRUMBLE ENTIRELY. IN THE TALK
ABOUT WANTING UP NEW AGENCY
NEEDY EVEN THOUGH THERE.
EMPLOYEES WORKING IN YOU I HAVE
DROPPED OVER TIME THE NIGHT OF
CLAIMS. IT IS HAS A REDUCED
EMPLOYEES EMPLOYEES WENT
SOMEWHERE ELSE AND IF YOU DE.
BOB LINE THERE STILL THERE. SO
THIS IS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE.
AND THAT AND WE'RE CAUCUS
CALLED MEMBERS NUMBER ONE ISSUE
HANDS DOWN I MEAN PEOPLE
EVERYONE ME TO DON THIS THAT IT
IS A BIG ISSUE. YEAH ACCIDENT
MISTER GLORIA SAID WE GET CALLS
EVERYDAY IF MARKETS WITH A IT
AND THEN GAP OF THE AMONG THE
RATE WE- FOR THIS THE I MEAN
IT'S RIDICULOUS SHOULDN'T Y. UP
THAT'S WHAT YOU THE THEREFORE.
AND WE'VE TO MORE FOR FOLKS
THAT WANNA SPEAK MISTER LACKEY
MISS WICKS MISS LACKEY AND MIND
YOU HAVE FOUR FORTY SOME
WITNESSES. I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT.
OKAY SORRY ABOUT THEIR. AS YOU
CAN HEAR THE DESPERATION OF
FRUSTRATION. EXTREME AND THE
OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE DESPERATE
FOR INCOME THE ONES WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- THEY HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS THEY HAVE VERY VERY.
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHEN
THEY WHEN YOU YOU GO AND YOU
MAKE YOUR PHONE CALL TWO ET D.
WHICH IS YOUR LIFE LINE. I KNOW
ONE OF THE BIGGEST FRUSTRATIONS
THAT I'M HAVING- EPEATED OVER
AND OVER OUR HANG OUT. BEACH
SAKE. OF PEOPLE CALL IN AND
THEY GET A RECORDED MESSAGE AND
BLUE YOU CAN'T LEAVE A MESSAGE
YOU CAN'T. GET ANY INTERACTION
AND EVEN SOME OF THE LIVE CALLS
WE'VE HAD HANG UPS. THAT IS
REALLY UNACCEPTABLE AND I'D-
ARE YOU AWARE OF THIS AND IS
THERE ANY PLAN IN PLACE TO TRY
TO MINIMIZE THAT. SO YES YOU
HAVE A QUALITY CONTROL PROGRAM
THAT WE JUST STARTED TO ENSURE
BETTER CONSISTENCY- AROUND THAT
AND- YES WE UNDERSTAND THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME COMPLAINTS. AND
WE ARE CONTINUING TO SEND OUT
DIFFERENT BULLETINS AND
MONITORING- WE'VE ALSO- JUST
EMPLOYED VENDOR TO HELP US. OUT
WITH HOW WE- SHARE OUR
PROCEDURES AND- YEAH
COMMUNICATIONS WITH OUR STAFF
SO THEY CAN MORE READILY DIGEST
THEM AND BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
GOOD CONSISTENT ANSWERS- THAT'S
ACTIVE LEVY WORKING ON RIGHT
NOW AS WELL. AND I SHARE YOUR
FRUSTRATION TOTALLY AS A LONG
TIME EMPLOYEE OF ET DE TO BE IN
THIS SITUATION IT'S JUST
DEVASTATING FOR ALL OF US- WE
ARE WORKING SEVEN DAYS A WEEK-
WE'LL BE OUT WORKING ALL
WEEKEND WILL BE WORKING MORE
MEMORIAL DAY. IS A CAPACITY FOR
US AND WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING
UNDER OUR POWER TO GO AND PROVE
OUR CAPACITY AS WELL AS
IMPROVED COMMUNICATIONS AT. AND
SYSTEMS AND WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO HIT IT FROM EVERY DIFFERENT
DIRECTION I I'M I DON'T LIKE IT
EITHER I TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU
IT'S NOT. ARE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE ADDRESSING ALL THE
CONCERNS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
OKAY FINALLY ARE I HAVE FOUR
PAGES ACOSTA BUT OBVIOUSLY I'M
NOT GOING TO BE LABOR THOSE
POINTS SOME OF THEM HAVE BEEN
ANSWERED BUT- THIS VERY
FRUSTRATING TIME FOR ALL OF US.
BUT WE HAVE A- WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO REPRESENT OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO SHARE
WITH YOU. THE EXTREME
FRUSTRATION AND THE SENSE OF
URGENCY AS REALLY UNPARALLELED
AND- MANY OF THESE PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND HOPEFULLY. FOREVER
BUT ALMOST HALF OF THE CALLS MY
OFFICE RECEIVES ABOUT BEING
DISQUALIFIED FOR BENEFITS. THEY
GET NO EXPLANATION FOR HOW TO
RESOLVE ANY RESOLUTION AND- I'M
HOPING THAT THERE MIGHT BE
SOME- A PLAN IN PLACE TO CHANGE
THAT. SOME AS TO WHY. ALL FIRED
ON THEY MIGHT THERE ARE SOME
OTHER OPTIONS IS THAT POSSIBLE
YEAH WE ARE- WE ARE EXPLORING
THAT AND ONE OF THE WAYS- LET
THE TEXTING CAMPAIGN THAT I
MENTION THAT IS ONE OF THE WAYS
WE'RE LOOKING TO SEE IF THAT
FEASIBLE TO HELP- BY THE END.
OF MORE READILY AND GIVE MORE
SPECIFICS SO OF YES WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING AT THAT AS WELL BECAUSE
WE UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION
AND I JUST I TELL YOU YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT YOUR COMMUNITY
YOUR COMMUNITY IS MY COMMUNITY.
FORUMS MY COMMUNITY UP I. AND
WE'RE AGAIN AND WE ARE A- IN
OUR POWER. TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
DOING RIGHT BY THE CITIZENS. MR
OR WE CAN HAVE A CHANCE THE US
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND A
QUESTIONS. WHAT WE LIVE IN ON
TIME AND ALL OF THE HONEST WITH
YOU WE NEED TO LEVEL OVERSIGHT
HEARING FOR THIS WOULD BE OUR
BEST AND COME BACK AND ACTUALLY
DO THAT OKAY REALLY GET ANSWER
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE'RE NOT
DOING JUSTICE TO THE MAY REVISE
SO BRING IT BACK TO ME REVISED
WE KNOW AS A NEW PROPOSAL FOR A
NEW DEPARTMENT OF BETTER JOBS
AND HIGHER WAGES. SEE OUR WAS
DVD. NEED TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T
LOSE SIGHT. OF WAS IN FRONT OF
US. MISS WICKS. YOU HAVE IT SO
MAYBE VICE QUESTIONS. NO I
WANTED TO JUST. A VERY BRIEF GO
AHEAD THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I'LL KEEP IT SHORT BECAUSE I
THINK THE POINT IS WHEN
EXPRESSED ADEQUATELY- BUT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE. I GET A NIGHTLY
CONSTITUENCY REPORT OF ALL
CALLS AND EMAILS OF COME INTO
MY OFFICE. FOR A LITTLE HAVE
PEOPLE WHO ARE FIGURE OUT HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO FEED THEIR
FAMILY. HOW THEY CAN FEED THEIR
CHILDREN. AND THEY'RE NOT
GETTING HELP WHERE THEY KNOW
THEY THEY SUS ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE GETTING AT. SO THAT IS A
SENSE OF URGENCY PEOPLE
LEARNING HOW THEY'RE GONNA PAY
THE RENT. AND SO THE FIX IS ON
THIS IS ARE SO CRITICAL- I I'M
I'M SORRY YOU PRICE A LITTLE
GANGED UP ON HERE BUT WE'RE
JUST REFLECTING WHAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE TELLING US. SO
PLEASE DO EVERYTHING IN YOUR
POWER TO MOVES ALONG IF YOU CAN.
SYMPATHIZE AND THE ELDERS YOUR
BEING WITH NO TO SAID THIS.
I'VE MISTER LITTLE SYMPATHY BUT-
I HAVE MORE SYMPATHY FOR. FOLKS
MIGHT JUST TO OR WERE ALREADY
MANY OF WHOM ALREADY LIVE BREAK
A POVERTY. OR EXPRESSING- DOOR.
PAVING TO BEGIN WITH- ARE NOW-
ARE ARE GOING THROUGH A TOUGH
TIME SO I JUST WANT. TO JUST.
MOMENTS WELL. THANK YOU. SO
YOU'RE QUESTIONS FOR YOU HAVE
YOU RESPONSE SELECT COMMITTEE.
L. OKAY THANK YOU SO MOVING ALL
THE MAY. A QUESTION FROM
MEMBERS. MISTER JIM ALBERT RUN
MY COLLEAGUES- BEVERLY WOULD BE
MUCH APPRECIATED TO GET AS MUCH
PUBLIC COMMENTS POSSIBLE I'M
GONNA ASK I HAVE A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS FROM HOUSING AND I
LIKE TO ASK THE QUESTIONS- AND
RATHER GO BACK AND FORTH AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC
COMMENT- WOULD LOVE TO GET
ANSWERS TO THEM SO- THE FIRST
HAS TO DO WITH THE PROJECT ROOM
KEY. GOOD CONCEPT- BUT I THINK
THEY'RE A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
WHETHER IT'S ACTUALLY GONNA
TURN HOTELS INTO SUPPORT OF
HOUSING PEOPLE NEED WRAPAROUND
SERVICES UP THEIR ESTIMATES IS
GOING TO COST OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT TO-
AND READ. I AND EACH OF THESE
UNITS ARE GONNA NEED ONGOING
FUNDING IT TERRACES ON A TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND- THERE IS
A PART OF THAT AT MATH JUST
WORK THAT WAY. OPERATING COSTS
THE GOVERNMENT ARCHITECT THIS
AND- WOULD LOVE THE ADMIN
ESTIMATES ON WHAT THE PER UNIT
COSTS ARE BECAUSE JUST SEEMS
LIKE IT'S NOT GONNA RELATED TO
THE WONDERING IF WE COULD
CONSIDER RENTAL ASSISTANCE TO
MASTER LEASE FROM PRIVATE
MARKET LANDLORDS PAYING RENT AS
A LUMP SUM- WITH CAPITALIZE
OPERATING ASSISTANCE FOR
SUPPORT OF HOUSING OR- OR OTHER
WAYS TO PRODUCE PERMANENT
HOUSING- AND JUST. LOOKING FOR
ANSWERS AND HOW THIS FUNDING IS
GOING TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE GET
SHELTERED DON'T RETURN TO THE
STREETS. ALSO WANT TO MENTION
THAT- I KNOW THAT THERE IS-
PROPOSED BUDGET TRAILER
LANGUAGE ON PRESERVING EXISTING
SUBSIDIZE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STOCK BY STABILIZE AN EXISTING
DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND GUARDING IT. AS
DIRECTORS PLANE UP DISTRESSED
ASSETS WONDERING WHAT THAT
MEANS THERE IS A- A REAL
CONVERSATION THAT PRESERVATION
OF HOUSING COULD BE SAY TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A UNIT RATHER
THAN TO ON A WINDOWS UNIT. JUST
WANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT SO
THAT'S ONE SUB. SECOND SUBJECT
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT FUNDING. IT
SAYS ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION. TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FOR QUOTE HOMELESSNESS PUBLIC
HEALTH PUBLIC SAFETY AND OTHER
SERVICES TO COMBAT COVERED
NINETEEN. THE QUESTION IS THAT
PHRASE OTHER SERVICES TO COMBAT
COVERED NINETEEN. DOES THAT
MEAN TO STOP FUNDING HAVE TO BE
DEVOTED TO HOMELESSNESS OR
COULD BE USED FOR ANY PURPOSE
AND I THINK. IF IT'S IF IT'S
THE LATTER THERE'S A LOT OF
CONCERN THAT THIS ONE POINT
SEVEN FIVE MILLION IS NOT
REALLY JUST FOCUSED ON
HOMELESSNESS. ALL RELATED. I WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS MONEY HAS
TO BE SPENT BY THE END OF THE
YEAR. AND CLEARLY SAYS THANK TO
END ON GERMAN FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. SO WONDERING WHAT THAT
REALLY MEANS. A THIRD QUESTION
AND I'LL JUST AND HERE IS A-
VERY GRATEFUL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SUPPORTING
THE CONTINUATION OF THE LIGHT
TECH- THE TEXTURE. OF FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION- THEIR CONCERNS
AT THE PROPOSED FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR CAP ON TAX READY CLAIMS.
WOULD UNDERMINE OUR GOALS. THAT
MAJOR INVESTORS IN THESE OFTEN
BY MORE THAN THAT- WE'VE HEARD
THAT THE MERE PROPOSALS
ACTUALLY DECREASING INVESTOR
APPETITE FOR THESE TAX CREDITS.
AND PUTTING PROJECT FINANCING
IN JEOPARDY AND SO. I WANT TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH YOU
OFTEN OTHERS ABOUT WHETHER AND
I WOULD THINK WE MAY NEED AN
EXCEPTION. FROM THIS FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR CAP FOR LIKE TO
CRACK SO. SUBJECTS SOME ANSWERS
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR. SURE FOR
CONTENT WITH MEMBERS ASKING
QUESTIONS IT IS RESPOND. ALL
THIS WILL I HAVE A BUNCH OF
HOUSING FOR TO BE I'LL TRY TO
LAY IT BECAUSE I KNOW WE'VE GOT
A BUNCH OF FOLKS SO WANTED TO
SEE IF- I'M- FRIEND TO PROVIDE
CLARITY IN THE SIX AND MILLION
ARE. YOUR MARKS PROJECT A ROOM
KEY. HELL BE USED- HOW MUCH
EACH CITY WILL RECEIVE- ALONG
THOSE LINES- IF THERE'S
FLEXIBILITY THAT FUNDING FOR
RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND WHAT THE
PLANS ARE FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE
MORE BROADLY. YOU KNOW I THINK
YOU KNOW WHEN THE WHEN GOVERNOR
NUISANCE EVICTION MORE TIMES
LIFTED. I THINK THERE'S GOING
TO BE A REAL SERIOUS CONCERNS
AROUND MASSIVE ACTIONS IN THE
STATE SO WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
ADDRESS THAT. AND WHAT IT CAN
THESE FUNDS BE USED FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT EITHER THE
PROJECT ROOM KEY FUNDS OR THE
MORTGAGE SETTLEMENT FUNDS AS
WELL- AND WITH THAT. POTENTIAL
RENTALS IS. THAT MAY BE. A OF
HOW WE TRACKING THAT
INFORMATION- IN TERMS OF THE-
AND PROVIDING ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THOSE MONIES. BEING SPENT.
I DO OF THE- FIRST. WOULD
TRACKING EL TO THAT WHICH I
WOULD WE I THEIR SUPPORT
ELEMENTS OF OUR OR WHOLE
HEARTEDLY SO THOSE ARE MY
QUESTIONS SORT OF AROUND-
PROJECT ROOM KEY AND HOW WE'RE
GONNA BE SUPPORTING ARE
HOMELESS COMMUNITIES. JUST FOR
FUN DE OBVIOUSLY SOON NUMBERS I
THINK ONLY HALF OF THE ROOMS
AND THEN. TAKEN BY FOLKS AND- I
STILL BELIEVE ALL. OF THEM A
LOT OF THOSE KINDS OF MENTAL
ILLNESS SO THE FOLKS ARE
TURNING DOWN NOT ACCEPTING TO
COME INDOORS. IS BECAUSE AN
ENORMOUS SOTHEBY'S ISSUES NOT
ONE TO FOLLOW RULES THEY HAVE
PETS SO WE'VE GOT TO GET. MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT ON WHY MOVE
MORE FULL START COMING IN THAT
PROGRAM. UNLESS IT'S STILL BE
FREE DIMINISH THAT. MISTER
GLORIA. YEAH ON THE FINANCING
MATTER I JUST IT'S BEEN UNCLEAR
TO ME TO THE EXTENT THE ROOMS
THAT ARE RESERVED. IF THEY'RE
NOT UTILIZED OUR IS THE
TAXPAYER STILL PAYING FOR THAT
I THINK DIFFERENT ACCOUNTS
WITHOUT HAVING A DEFINITIVE
ANSWER WOULD BE BENEFICIAL- AND
THAT JUST FOR THE RECORD I HAVE
A NUMBER OF. UNEMPLOYMENT A
RELATED QUESTION I'LL BE
SENDING TO THE DEPARTMENT I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WAS
QUITE UNDERSTOOD THAT THERE WAS
AN EXPECTATION AND A COMMITMENT
TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS BUT-
ON THE ROOF. KEY QUESTION I
THINK THAT THAT'S PRETTY
IMPORTANT SURE AND THEN ON THE
SICK TAX I DO THE GOVERNOR'S
FULL TO RAISE THE CIGARETTE
TAX. THIS OF. THE PACK OF
CIGARETTES. AND IF YOU CAN
ABOUT SIMPLE IN. ARM HAVE
EXPECTED REVENUE. BUT THE COST
IMPLEMENTTHE PROGRAM HOW KNOW
FOR TO TOOK TWO YEARS TO COME
UP ON THAT. IT LOOKS. YEAH THE.
FIFTH HAVE FINANCE TENS OF THE
HOUSING OKAY WE FINANCE IT AS
THE HEALTH QUESTIONS FIRST OF
CERTAINLY KRYSTLE APARTMENT
FINANCE- HEARING A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT PROJECT ROOM
KEY AND I'M HERE TO ADDRESS-
THOSE- THE IDEA HERE IS BIRDS
THE A SUCCESSFUL PARTNERSHIPS
WE'VE HAD SO FAR WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN TERMS OF USING
THE- SOME OF THE CORONAVIRUS
RELIEF FUNDS AND SOME OF THE
STATE GENERAL FUND. TO HELP GET
PEOPLE IN THE HOTELS AND MOTELS.
THE MOST BOND POPULATIONS. AND
THAT YOUR PROJECT ROOM KEYS WE
HAVE SIX HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL CREDIT BY
RITUALLY FUNDS WILL BE MADE
AVAILABLE. THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. AND THEY WILL GO
AHEAD AND THEY WILL- WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO IS ARE
GOING TO- STRAIGHT OUT IN THE
FORM OF GRANTS AS WHAT RENT
DISSIPATING WHERE- CITIES AND
COUNTIES WILL COME TO A- CD. IT
WILL HELP YOUR PROPOSAL FOR
HELL TO THEY WOULD DELIVER TO
SIX HUNDRED NO. THIS MONEY TO
GO AHEAD. SECURE HOUSING FOR
FORTIES ARE ON A MORE PERMANENT
BASIS STATE HOUSING ON A
PERMANENT BASIS IT DOES NOT
HAVE TO BE LIMITED ONLY TO
PROPERTIES THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING CURRENTLY PROJECT
FROM KING I CAN BE ANY SORT OF
PROPERTY THAT CAN BE PERSONS TO
WAIT PROVIDE SAFE HOUSING FOR
PEOPLE ON A PERMANENT BASIS.
AND ANOTHER THING I WOULD NOTE
IS THAT THERE IS. TERMS OF ROOM
KEY THERE IS. ALSO IT'S A
LIMITED POOL OF MONEY THAT HAS
TO BE SPENT BY DECEMBER THIRTY
AT THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY SO
WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
MONTHS IN WHICH TO WORK SO WHAT
CD IS GOING TO DO IS WE'RE
GOING TO WORK WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. WHAT'S THE- A SET
UP YEAH IT'S- SO TO SPEAK
SOLICIT- INPUT FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT WANT TO
PARTICIPATE. AND EIGHT CITIES
IN A CAST AS WIDE AS POSSIBLE
TO GET ALL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CITIES AND COUNTIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT WISH TO
PARTICIPATE. AND EIGHT CITIES
GOING TO WORK WITH THAT. FIVE
POST PROPOSALS ARE THE MOST
APPLICATION YOU'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO LEVERAGE THE- BEST.
RETURN ON THE- THE SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. AND I WILL GO
AHEAD AND AT LEAST. THE HELP
THE LOCALS THESE PROCUREMENTS.
AND HAVE TO BE FINISHED BY
DECEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY. AND PART OF THE REVIEW
PROCESS WILL BE TO WORK WITH
LOCALS TO ENSURE THAT. THOSE
THAT ARE SELECTED HAVE. OF
MEANS. AND TEEN THE CIVIL ON.
CAN I IS THAT. THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY AS THE MEMBERS OF OUT
THERE'S GOING BE AN ONGOING
NEED SERVICES TO MAINTAIN THE
CIVIL TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
LIVING IN OTHER HOTEL DEPART
PROCESS AS WELL AND THIS IS
STILL BEING DEVELOPED BUT- WE
DO ANTICIPATE THAT EACH C. D.
WILL BE PREPARED. TO BEGAN IN
BUSINESS LISTENING INPUT FROM
LOCALS WHICH TO PARTICIPATE- ON
JULY FIRST. SO OBVIOUSLY THIS
MONEY TO BE SPENT BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR THURMOND AFTER ACTION
REPORT DETAILING THE
INFORMATION WHO- SUBSCRIBE THIS
WE TOOK IN I MEANS WE HAVE A
SNAPSHOT OF WHAT. TRANSPIRED
THAT SHOULD BE THE EIGHT YES
I'D LIKE WILL BE THE CITY WOULD
BE ABLE TO PURCHASE PRICE OF
THE- I THINK THE IMPORTANT PART
ABOUT THAT IS WHY FOLKS ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF IT SO WE
KNOW WHY. IF IT IS BECAUSE OF.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE OTHER RETURNS
THEN IN SEVERAL OTHER
JURISDICTIONS ON THEY'VE
OFFERED IT OTHER PROGRAMS A LOT
OF FOLKS HAVE A TAKE ADVANTAGE
FOR ME TO REASONS AND HAPPY
TACKLE THAT. IN CHANGE THAT. TO
GET IN IN IN IN AND GET HELP
WITH SO MUCH NEED. THAT IS
ACCORDING THE FIGURES I'VE
THERE'S BOUT SIXTEEN THOUSAND
CONTRACTED ROOMS A ON.
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT THOUSAND OF
THE BILL RIGHT NOW. AND ONE OF
THE COFFEE US ON THAT IS THAT
THIS. EFFORT REALLY ONLY
STARTED ABOUT TWO MONTHS AGO
SO. GRANTED ONLY HALF THE ROOMS
ARE FILLED IN THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF CHALLENGES INVOLVED
IN GETTING PEOPLE TO TAKE IT
AND I JUST. BE PROVIDED. BUT
HAVING SAID THAT. I THINK IT'S
ALSO TO THE- OF OUR LOCAL. THE
PART OF THE SOCIAL. IN GENERAL
SERVICES THEY'VE- MANAGED TO%
ACHIEVE AS MUCH AS THEY HAVE SO
FAR AND- SO. THE TRACK RECORD
FOR SUCCESS IS BEEN LATE AND WE
THINK THAT. BUT BROWN RIGHT.
GLORIA TOOTE TO THAT POINT IF
EIGHT THOUSAND TO FIFTEEN
DOLLARS ARE BEING USED ARE WE
PAYING FOR SIXTEEN THOUSAND
REPAINT FOR EIGHT THOUSAND I
DON'T HAVE. THAT THE ANSWER
EXACTLY FOR YOU BUT WE'D BE
HAPPY TO GET THAT. ADDITIONAL
THAT THANK YOU. MR TO THE BY I
APPRECIATE YOU STARTED ANSWER
NUMBER QUESTION ABOUT THIS BUT
I'M STILL LIKE AND HOPE TO
RECEIVE ANSWERS TO THE
QUESTIONS I ASKED IF IT
REQUIRES ANOTHER FOLLOW UP
MEETING HAPPY TO DO THAT TOO I
KNOW WE JUST I JUST FIRED A
BUNCH OF QUESTIONS BUT- LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT. THAT THESE
TERMS OBJECTS THANKS. MORE
QUESTION WITH WICKS YEAH AND
JUST- A COUPLE FOLLOW UPS I
ALSO WOULD LOVE TO HEAR- SOME
ANSWERS ON THE QUESTION AROUND
IF ANY OF THIS MONEY CAN BE
SPENT FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE-
FOR THAT THERE'S ANYTHING IN
THERE. AND THEN ALSO WHO
ULTIMATELY MAKES THE DECISION
ON HOW THE- PRESERVING THE BAT
IS THAT DEAL FOR. REGARDING THE
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS-
AGAIN THIS IS A LIMITED POOL OF
MONEY THAT HAS TO BE EXPENDED.
NOT ENCUMBER BUT ACTUALLY SPENT
UNDER FEDERAL. GUIDELINES AND
RULES BY. DECEMBER THIRTIETH
SO- WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
RENTAL SYSTEMS WOULD BE AN
APPROPRIATE USE FOR THESE
MONIES BECAUSE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE IS MORE ABOUT.
ONGOING FUNCTION AND THESE DO
HAVE TO BE SPENT TO GET BY THE
END OF THE YEAR. AND IN TERMS
OF THE USE THE MONEY- GONNA
HAPPEN. CD IS GOING TO WORK
WITH. THOSE VOCALS WHO WISH TO
REACH OUT AND THEN. PUT IN AN
APPLICATION FOR THESE FUNDS IN
EACH CITY WILL- WEIGHING
FACTORS AT WORK THAT I
MENTIONED BEFORE- YOU KNOW THE
EFFICACIOUS NOUS OF. THE
PROPOSAL- THE BILL YOU TO
MAINTAIN THE- THE FUNDED ROOMS
ON ONGOING BASIS THAN EIGHT CD
WILL GO AHEAD AND SELECT THOSE
WHO ARE ON. THE TOWARD THE BEST
WAY TO ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS.
CARE QUESTIONS ON. OPERATION
HERE HOMELESSNESS. OKAY WELL I
REQUEST ABOUT EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION OF THESE COUPLES
YOU'RE ASKING STATE EMPLOYEES
TO TAKE A 10215% CUT A
COMPOSITION OF THE NEXT YEAR
WE'RE NOT THERE TO WORK STATE
WORK FORCES- ACTUAL STATE
EMPLOYEES NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
OF WHOM LIVE IN MY DISTRICT
THERE THOUSANDS OF OTHER
POSITIONS SO CALLED P. Y. EASE
WHICH ARE PERSONAL YEAR
EQUIVALENTS THEY'RE OUTSOURCED
A COST OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO DO STATE WORK EVERY YEAR.
ARE THE ARE WE ASKING THESE
COMPANIES AND THE PEOPLE A THE
PROVIDE TO TAKE A 10% PAY CUT.
SO MERRY HALTER AND APARTMENT
OF FINANCE I AM. WHEN IT COMES
TO USING CONTRACTORS FOR-
SERVICES THAT. I WE MAY NOT
HAVE ENOUGH. STATE EMPLOYEES
FOR I'M I DON'T HAVE ANY
INFORMATION ON THE CONTRACT
HOSPITABLY CONTRACT COSTS
CHANGING. CAN YOU BACK TO IS
NOT EASY GOING FORWARD ON A NEW
CONTRACTS I'M SURE THOSE WILL
BE ADJUSTED. BUT COULD YOU LET
US KNOW. OR CLASSES FOR THAT
WHEN THE CONTRACTOR WRITTEN.
GET BACK THAT BE GREAT. AND THE
QUESTION THE COMMITTEE. THEN
I'LL TALK ABOUT- THE CIGARETTES
AS I SAID EARLIER ON THE
CIGARETTE TAX- I AGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR ON THAT BUT- WHAT IS
EXPECTED REVENUE AND WHAT IS
THE COST AND WITH THE PROGRAM.
AND WE'RE OTHER PROGRAMS IT
TOOK TO. MEN SO. ONE OF THE
THOUGHTS ON THAT. GOOD MORNING
NO CHANGE CHAMBER AND CORPORATE
FINANCE SO OF THE EXPECTED
REVENUE FROM THE HIS CIGARETTE
TAX IS THIRTY THREE MILLION IN
THE BUDGET HERE. HOWEVER I HAVE
TO CARRY OUT THAT THAT THAT IS-
WE DON'T HAVE REAL GOOD DATA
ON. OF THE AMOUNT OF. HI E.
CIGARETTE CONSUMPTION
SPECIFICALLY AND PARTICULARLY A
BY NICOTINE LEVEL OF WHICH THAT
THIS TAXES NICOTINE BASED. SO
THAT THAT THAT- HER THIRTY
THREE MILLION ESTIMATE IS
SUBJECT TO A WIDE RANGE OF A
BRIGHT WHITE VARIANTS- AND AS
FAR AS THE COST EMPLOYMENT I
REALLY DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION WITH BUT I CAN
CERTAINLY GET BACK TO YOU. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
PROGRAM OF THE CONSUMER 40% OF
THE REVENUE RAISED BY TAXES.
THAT SEEMS TO BE HIGH WHY IS
THAT. HELLO THANK YOU I AGAIN I
BUT I'M I'M NOT REALLY I HAVE
BEEN FOCUSED ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION SO. HOME I'LL
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
YEAH I'VE BEEN TOLD IS OVER 40%
WHICH IS TO ME IS IT'S
ASTRONOMICAL SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE ADMINISTRATION WORK
THE STAKEHOLDERS. TO THE FIVE
WAYS TO MINISTER THIS TAX MORE
PERSONALLY SLIPPING GET BACK TO
ME. I WOULD DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE THAT. CERTAINLY.
PAID FAMILY LEAVE- LIKE THIS
ALL IMPORTANT- THIS
LEGISLATURE'S VERY SUPPORT OF A
WORKING FAMILIES BUT WE KNOW
WITH COVER NINETEEN IS HAD A
HUGE EFFECT SMALL BUSINESSES
WHICH ARE PREDOMINATELY
MINORITY EARNED MINORITY- AND
IT'S A COUPLE QUESTIONS THIS
PROPOSAL WILL POST A TWELVE
WEEK WE BALANCE ON EMPLOYERS
WITH ONLY ONE EMPLOYEE- ALLEY
SMALL EMPLOYER PAGE THAT LEAVE
AND FIND REPORT FOR TWELVE
WEEKS. MR TURNED OUT BRENT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND TO
ASSIST IN THOSE COSTS THE MAY
PROVISIONAL CAN USE OF ONE
BILLION DOLLAR GRANT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES TO HELP WITH
RETRAINING COSTS WHILE THE-
INVESTORS ARE TAKING THAT PAID
LEAVE. YOU'RE WEARING SÝ MASK
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER LACKEY YOU
GUYS HAVE BOTH OF EXCELLENT EH
THANK. AND THEN WHEN I TELL THE
FREE. HI LESTER FOGGING UP TO
THIS MAN ONLY PUT DOWN A LITTLE
BIT. OF HOW DOES THIS WORK WITH
FEDERAL LEAVE LAWS THAT WERE
JUST PASSED AND THE CARES ACT.
WILL THIS LEAVE RUN
CONCURRENTLY WITH A LEAF PASSED
AND THE CARES ACT. IN HOW MUCH
LEGAL THAT WILL THAT TOTAL. I'M
GONNA HAVE EFFECT YOU'RE NOT
INTERESTED. YOUR QUESTIONS FOR
A MONTHLY ONE ASKING QUESTIONS
RIGHT NOW. OKAY I JUST GOT A
COUPLE MORE THAN WE HAVE FOLKS
TO CALL AND. BUT A LOT OF CALLS
ON THE DEPARTMENT BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT THE RE OREGON AT- I
GUESS THE BIG ISSUE. IN FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WHAT I'M HEARING IS
THAT THE BRAND ORGANIZATION.
THAT DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF
RULES AND AS WE'VE SEEN WITH
CARBON OTHER. STATE AGENCIES-
JUST LET UP THEIR OWN DEVICES
THEY GO IN CREE RULES AND LAWS
THAT. REALLY ARE DONE BY
BUREAUCRATS AND NOT BY THE
LEGISLATURE SO IT'S BEEN VERY
VAGUE AND- LAWTON OVERSIGHT- IS
IT DOESN'T TAKE THE DRILL DOWN
ON THAT IS LEAVE IT VAGUE
BECAUSE- OBVIOUSLY IN THIS
COVER NINETEEN EPIDEMIC THERE'S
MUCH TIME TO HAVE POLICY. AND
REALLY VET THE GPL. THIS IS
KIMBERLY HARBISON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND ANSWERED YOUR
QUESTION. A LEGISLATURE WOULD
STILL HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
CREATE NEW LICENSURE CATEGORIES.
WE ARE LOOKING AT- REGISTERING
NEW USERS SO WHAT THE DIFFERENT.
A DIFFERENT UP CATEGORY AND YOU
WOULD STILL HAVE OVERSIGHT OVER
THE LICENSURE. WITH RENTAL
SIMPLY FOR KERR BUT IT INACTION
IF CAN POLICY CHANGES THE
LEGISLATURE HAS NOT HAD
SUFFICIENT TIME TO CONSIDER.
THE PROPOSAL ALSO DIFFERS TOO
MUCH AUTHORITY TO NEW. WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT LEGISLATIVE INPUT IN
OVERSIGHT- IT'S TOUGH TO-
OBVIOUSLY CLUB BACK WITHOUT
THEIR SO. WE SEE THAT WITH
OTHER STATE AGENCIES SO THE
SAYING THIS WHOLE THIS WHOLE
PROCESS IS YOU CAN SAY WE START
WITH EASY THIS MORNING A LOT OF
QUESTIONS TO ASK YOU THINK
ABOUT THE HEARINGS HE'S
COMMITTEES HAD ONE HEARING SO
FAR. THE NEXT TO THE COMMITTEE
THE WHOLE THE REPORTING THE
BUDGET IN JUNE SO NORMALLY WE
HAVE OVER A HUNDRED COMMITTEE
MEETINGS. IN A SESSION THINK
ABOUT THAT ONE HUNDRED
COMMITTEE MEETINGS WERE LIKE IN
THIS COMMITTEE MAY MEET FIVE
SIX SEVEN EIGHT TIMES IN OTHER
COMMITTEES WE TEND TO TEN TONS
OF BEING TOLD BY STAFF WE MEET
ANOTHER COMMITTEES MEET. SO
COMING BACK HERE IS COMMITTEES
MET ONE TIME. THE ME THE WHOLE
NEXT AND THE BUDGET. IN JUNE
AND I REALIZE ARE UNDER
TREMENDOUS PRESSURE AND TRYING
TIMES BUT STILL THE LEGISLATURE
THE JOB TO DO TO MAKE SURE THE
RELEASE OF A BRIDGE THE
GOVERNMENT THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH JUST ABOVE ME EXECUTIVE
BRANCH TO DO THOSE TYPE OF
THING SO. IT'S TROUBLING
SITTING HERE A LOT OF ANSWERS
THAT- FOLKS CAN ANSWER AND I'M
NOT BEING UP ANYBODY BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE STILL HAVE OUR JOB
TO DO I REALIZE THE GOVERNOR
HIS STAFF HAS THEIR JOB TO DO-
BUT IT'S TROUBLES. IT IS A CHEN
PAUL EGGS THE- IT HAS A GLOBAL
THIS. THE D. DOT. NOT BECAUSE
OF THESE AUTHORED ACTED WE'VE
SEEN NUMEROUS TOP PLANS IT'S
VERY HARD TO CLUB AFTER FULL.
THAT SO QUESTION MY COLLEAGUES
AT ALL. MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY
MAKE A COMMENT TO YOUR QUESTION
SURE OF WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS
IS A VERY DETAILED PROPOSAL AND
WE HAVE INCLUDED A LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD MAKE THE WORK OF A
THING THAT'S NOW IN THE BUDGET
BECAUSE OF THE- TICKET.
CHANGING POSITIONS AND DOLLARS
I HAVE PLAYED IT LIKE THAT
WOULD CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE OVER THE SUMMER SO
THERE WAS A TIME TO MEET WITH
BILL AND FOR YOUR INPUT- TO
WORK OUT THE LANGUAGE AND ON
THE FUNDING. WOULDN'T GO INTO
EFFECT UNTIL AN AGREEMENT IS
REACHED ON THE LANGUAGE SO WHAT
WOULD BE THE DIFFERENCE IF WE
STARTED IT AND PUT OFF TILL
NEXT YEAR I MEAN WHAT IS THE
AGENCIES ARE UP AND RUNNING
RIGHT NOW SEPARATELY IS NOT
THIS AGENCY BUT WHAT WOULD BE.
THE HARM IN PUTTING IT OFF
UNTIL. NEXT YEAR. THE HARM
WOULD BE GOOD. IN OF A- IF WE
WAIT AND- AS THE LA- SUGGESTED.
ANALYST IN THE POLICY
COMMITTEE- WE WAIT FOR THE
POLICY PROCESS THEN WE COME
BACK WITH THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL. SUBSEQUENT TO THAT-AND THEN THERE'S HIRING SO
WHAT'S UP MUCH LONGER
IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD. WHEREAS
WE THINK ESPECIALLY NOW IN THE
GOVERNOR VARMINT. THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY FOR BAD ACTORS TO
BE DOING THINGS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO GO OUT AND PROVIDE
CONSUMER PROTECTION FOR. WE'VE
GOT A LOT OF FOLKS THAT WANT TO
COMMENT ON THE PUBLIC COMMENT
AND WE'RE GONNA RUN OF TIME SO.
THIS IS A MORE QUESTIONS. MR
SHOOT I CANNOT QUESTIONS BUT-
BY I APPRECIATE THE CHAIR'S
COMMENTS ABOUT HOW- HOW SHORT
THIS IS AND HOW FRANKLY LITTLE
OVERSIGHT WE'RE GETTING TO THIS
PROCESS I'M JUST GONNA MENTION.
THREE QUICK THINGS I KNOW
THERE'S SOME DISCUSSION AROUND-
EXPANSION OF DROP PROTECTION
AROUND FAMILY A PAID FAMILY
LEAVE. I AND THAT'S SOMETHING I
VERY MUCH SUPPORT I THINK WE
ALL. KNOW HOW CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AS IS DURING THIS
TIME PERIOD SO I HOPE THAT
CONVERSATION CONTINUES. RELATED
TO THAT- I KNOW THEY SAID THIS
PAID. LEAVE BENEFITS ARE TIED
TO RESOURCES THAT HELP SUPPORT
SMALL BUSINESSES. SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF I THINK MILLIONS OF
SMALL BUSINESSES PRACTICALLY.
FROM DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
IMMIGRANT ON BUSINESSES. OUT
THERE REALLY HAS BEEN VERY
LITTLE FOCUS ON HOW WE'RE
HELPING THEM THERE'S BEEN MUCH
MORE. FEDERAL IN A CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW TO HELP ESTABLISHED-
SORT OF MAINSTREAM BUSINESSES
BUT THESE THE BUSINESSES THAT
MAKE UP CALIFORNIA. I KNOW
THERE'S SOME PROPOSALS- TO MOVE
FORWARD SPECIFICALLY AROUND.
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES AND
OTHERS AND I WANT TO JUST
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR THAT. AS
WELL SUPPORT FOR- ANYTHING WE
CAN DO AROUND THE EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT DURING THIS TIME
PERIOD. WE ALL PROBABLY LOTS
AND ALL THESE TOPICS BUT JUST
WANTED TO. THROW THIS OUT AND
HOPE MORE TIME IN THE FUTURE TO
DISCUSS THIS. THANK YOU MISTER
TO. THIS WICKS ONE TO ONE THING
I WANTED TO ADD ON TO WHAT NOW
MISTER TO SAID. I AM MEN FOR
GREAT. ALSO UNDER THE- NUMBER
ELECTION PROPOSED NOT THE
FUNDING FOR OUR AND GIVE THE
CHANGE VOTE BY MAY THAT'S VERY
CRITICAL- I I'D BE HAPPY TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS OFFLINE WITH
THE OFF ON THAT BUT THAT'S IN
THE QUESTION TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING FULL
ENFRANCHISEMENT THIS NOVEMBER
SURE SO IF YOU ARE FAMILIAR
QUESTIONS A STAFF AND OBVIOUSLY
WITH THE FINANCE WILL QUESTION
SIR UP AHEAD OF THE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE NUMBER SPEAKERS ARE
MINOR SPEAKER OF. PERSONAL ARE
YOU ABLE MINUTE TIME LIMIT-
WE'VE A HARD STOP TIME OF ONE
O'CLOCK SO IF YOU CAN SAY IT-
IN LESS THAN ONE MINUTE THAT
WOULD BE MUCH APPRECIATED US
WILL START WITH OUR FOR
SPEAKERS. MISTER CHAIR AT ALL
YES THEY ARE MINDFUL JUST TELL
US YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
OR WITH AND AS A CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE QUESTIONING KAYLEE
ON BEHALF OF KHN TV THE
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND I WANT TO BRING
TO YOUR ATTENTION. ON THE LAST
PAGE OF THE LA OF ANALYSIS IS
THE TAX REVENUE SOLUTIONS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
AND I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
WHILE THE STATE HAS IN PREVIOUS
BUDGET- DOWNTURNS SUSPENDED THE
NET OPERATING LOSS DEDUCTION
AND LIMITED- THE USE OF TAX
CREDITS IN THE PREVIOUS.
INSTANCES WHERE FOR TWO YEARS
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
THREE SO WE'D LIKE YOU TO RE
VISIT THAT. AND MAYBE DO A TWO
YEAR INSTEAD OF A THREE. THE
OTHER POINT IS THAT THERE WAS
SOME SORT OF TRADE OFF IF YOU
WILL ON THE BACKEND. FOR
EXAMPLE AFTER THIS FIRST IN
AWHILE SUSPENSION. WE DID A AN
INCREASE FROM 60% UTILIZATION
TWO HUNDRED PERCENT. AND THEN
IN THE SECOND SUSPEND CAN AN
UPDATE NINE. WE DID A TWO YEAR
CARRY BACK. SO WE WOULD URGE
YOU TO ENTER SOME ALTERNATIVES
AND THAT ARE TAKING. CARE.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JAMES A MARGIN ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN PATROL AND COULD BE IN
STORE SO CATION. ARE A MINORITY
ON SMALL BUSINESSES ARE OPPOSED
TO THE HIGHER RATE TAX THINK
ABOUT SCHOOL CIGARETTES. THIS
WOULD AFFECT NOT ONLY OUR SALES
THE SALES CALIFORNIA LOTTERY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. A MORE
SPEAKERS. SO WE GOT A PHONE
LINE ALLEN WILL GO TO OUR FULL.
SPEAKERS IN THE PHONE LINE.
THANK YOU LEADING GERMAN PRESS
ONE ZERO FOR COMMENT FIRST WE
GO TO LINE ONE ZERO LINE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS SABRINA
BILL SIR I'M WITH THE
RESTAURANT OPPORTUNITIES IN OF
LOS ANGELES NOW WE DON'T POWER
WITH PEOPLE WHO WORKED IN BARS
RESTAURANTS AND FOOD SERVICE-
TO PROVE THEIR LIVES- I WANTED
TO RAISE THE- ISSUE ABOUT THE
REVISED. BUDGET IT DOES NOT
INCLUDE- INCOME SUPPORT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIA. WEEK
UNACCEPTABLE. EXCLUDING ONE AND
CAN TELL FROM THE BASIC SAFETY
NET DUE TO THE IMMIGRATION
STATUS IT'S COMPLETELY
UNSUSTAINABLE IN A CRISIS OF
THE SCALE. IT IS NOT COOL- I
FEEL THAT IS COOL JUST OFFER
HARD WORKING PEOPLE THAT ARE
YOU CONTRIBUTE SO MUCH TO THE
STATE NOTHING MORE THAN TO
DESPERATION WORRY SO WE NEED TO
DO MORE. WE'RE HERE TO DEMAND
THAT I'M A WEEKLY INCOME
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS HE-
INCLUDED IN THE CAN BUDGET.
WHO'VE BEEN AFFECTED BY A COP
IN NINETEEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE ONE TWO NINE
ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
WE HAVE LINE SIX SEVEN POINT
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU HAVE. EIGHT BOOK GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR COMMENT. YEAH. THE
GOOD. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
WE HAVE LINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD MORNING- THIS IS DAVID
NELSON AND WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASIAN PACIFIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND I'M JUST CALLING
TO- PERSPECTIVE THAT BUT
SHARING AND THE TWENTY PUTS
ROBUST HEARING AND- REALLY
APPRECIATE- MEMBER CHOOSE. THAT
KNOWLEDGE OF THE NEEDS OF SMALL
BUSINESS AND AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW WHERE CARRYING- I REQUEST
TO INCREASE. A SUPPLE FUNDING
FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROGRAM. THE PROGRAM IS- NOTED
IN THE MAY REVISED AND WE PAID.
FOR A COUPLE MINUTES OF BEING
OVER THE SEVERAL YEAR FOR. OUR
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS. I'M TO PAY
ITS FOR OF OUT ARE THEY RECOVER
FROM THE CURRENT CRISIS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE THE
LINE ONE ZERO NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BERNANKE LOW AT THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YEARS
WELL PROJECT ROOM HERE LAUDABLE
IT WILL NOT THERE ARE AND A
COMPANY KIDS AND WILL CONTINUE
TO LEAVE THEM ON THE STREET.
AND BUT THE SHARP RELIEF TO
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES EXPERIENCING
HOME ARE. IT DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE TO SHELTER IN PLACE
STOCK UP AND SAVE IT OR EVEN
FIND A PLACE IF THE RESTROOM IF
YOU HAVE NO PERMANENTLY EARLIER
HAD. PROVIDED THE WRITTEN
COMMENTS THE CONCRETE
SUGGESTIONS THE LEGISLATURE. IN
YEARS TO CONTINUE ITS
LEADERSHIP TO ADDRESS NEED THE
COMIC KIDS AROUND THREE TODAY.
THE CRISIS OF THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY HAS. ALMOST FIFTEEN
THOUSAND KIDS ON THE STREET
COULD NOT PERMANENT HOME. ONLY
UNDERSTAND THE SEVERITY OF THE
ECONOMIC CRISIS THE STATE UNDER
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A BIGGER
ISSUE. AT THE ECONOMIC AND
EDUCATIONAL POLLOCK HER BED.
LIKE THE LAST DEFECTION
DISPROPORTIONATELY WILL HAVE ON
YOUNG PEOPLE. PARTY THING EARLY
TREND. FROM UNEMPLOYMENT DATA
THAT YOU CAN YOUNG PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY.
SUFFERING AND LOSING THEIR JOBS.
YEAH BUT PART OF POLLUTION
REALLY WORKS YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BUT BUT THE NOT WITH
ANOTHER HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
KUN NEXT WE HAVE THE LINE
TWENTY THREE THE LINE IS OPEN.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON CARE AND
MEMBERS LAURIE KAMMERER ON
BEHALF OF SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER. WE
ARE URGING THE FULL FUNDING OF
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
EXPANSION PROGRAM AND WE HOPE
THAT WE CAN COUNT ON YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE ONE FORTY ONE FOUR
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. REMEMBER
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE AFTER
THE CALIFORNIA FUEL THE
CONVENIENCE ALLIANCE. WE
REPRESENT OVER HALF THE TOLL
THOUSAND GAS STATIONS AND
CONVENIENCE STORES THEY WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED NEW TACK BUT BABY
PRODUCTS. OUR MEMBERS OKAY
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES DURING
THE PANDEMIC NOT ONLY AT THE
CENTRAL DOES IS PROVIDING
CRITICAL FOOD AND FUEL TO THE
GREATER PUBLIC. BUT ALSO AT THE
SMALL FAMILY MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES REQUIRED TO COMPLY
WITH THE OWNERS YOU. PUBLIC
HEALTH REQUIREMENTS WE'RE
CONCERNED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. THE FURTHER CáC
THEIR CUSTOMERS AND THAT THIS
DURING A DIFFICULT TIME.
FURTHERMORE WE BELIEVE IT IS
BAD PUBLIC POLICY THE TAX PAPER
PRODUCTS HIGHER THAN CAN BUT
WE'LL FIGURE IT. DRIVE YOU TOLD
TO EIGHT LEFT HEALTHY PRODUCTS.
WITHOUT THE COMMITTEE TO REJECT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HAD
WRITTEN. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE ONE ONE TWO THREE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FINANCIAL
GIVEN THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE THE FIFTIES THAT
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT THE STATE NO
LONGER SUPPORTED THE POLICY
AROUND CREATING A NEW BEEPING
TAXPAYERS THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER PROVIDING A BACK. UP
NINETY NINE ABOUT THE
EXTRAVAGANZA LATER WHAT WAS
DONE UNDER PROPERTY THICK AND
UTILIZING THAT STRUCTURE AT
BACK OF TAX REVENUE FROM
PROBABLY NINE O'CLOCK PACIFIC
FUND VITAL TOBACCO PREVENTION
AND CONTROL PROGRAMS AVAILABLE
FOR ALL HEALTH PROGRAM. AND
GIVEN THE INCREASE IS AROUND
THE RISK WITH CO THEN IT'S
IMPORTANT AT THE PROGRAMS
REMAIN FUNDING THAT FUNDED SO
WE APPRECIATE THE VAPING PACK
BUT WE THINK IT LET THAT BE
HELPFUL TO HAVE MORE TIME TO
DELIBERATE. AND THOUGHTFUL AND
THE APPROACH IN TERMS OF HOW
THE REVENUE GROWTH. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE ONE THREE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
CHAPSTICK THE STATUS THE ALL
WORKERS UNDERSTOOD BROKE
REGARDLESS OF THE EMPLOYERS
FIVE HOURS BURKE WORKING YOUR-
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE INCLUSION
OF ADDITIONAL BY AND THE
PACKAGE. SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION TO THE I. R. THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION. YOU FOR
EIGHTY FIVE ENFORCEMENT THIS IS
GONNA BE CRITICAL FOR WORKERS
PARTICULARLY DURING THIS
CRISIS- HOWEVER WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE GOVERNOR'S- PROPOSE
REALLOCATION OF A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
LABOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
FUNDING TO THE GENERAL FUND.
THESE ARE FUND BETTER THAT COME
FROM HOW TO CASES THAT ARE AT
OUR STATUTORY OBLIGATED TO BE
USED FOR- LABOR CODE
ENFORCEMENT OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION- AND LASTLY THE
IMMIGRATION PROPOSALS THAT HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED BY THE MEMBER US
CALL WERE FOR. UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
WE ARE SO LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT
THAT ADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
PROGRAM AND ALSO AS THE
LEGISLATURE- EXPEND COUNT YET
PEOPLE DIED IN ORDERS TO VOTE
WILL BE. SUBMITTED HIS NO
COMMENTS- TO THE COMMITTEE BUT
THOSE ARE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE ONE SIX ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MAYBE ON ME BEFORE ONE NINE ONE
SIX ONE. THANK YOU BUT THE
THERMIC DATE CAME FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THE URBAN COUNTY THE
CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVE OF CALIFORNIA WE
WANT TO EXPRESS PERSONAL
CONCEPTUAL REPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL THAT THEY GET. THE
KIND OF MILLION TO PURCHASE
HOTELS AND MOTELS- FOR PART OF
PROJECT ROOM KEY WE KNOW THAT
THE STATE AND COUNTIES HAVE UP
THE CARRIER REVENUE AND THE
NATURE OF OUR HOW THE STOCK IS
IN A PRECARIOUS SITUATION WE
WANT TO PARTNER WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA MAKE
MAXIMUM USE. OF THE SIERRA
FUND- THEY'RE NOT AS FLEXIBLE
AS WE HAD HOPED SO WE WANT TO
WORK TOGETHER ON THAT AND THEN
WE'D LIKE TO INCREASE- INCLUDE
THE PARTNERSHIP AND STRUCTURING
THE PROPOSAL AND BE PARTNERS IN
THAT WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
PURCHASES THAN IN CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT. BEYOND JUST THE
PROJECT THREE KEY LEASES ARE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
EQUITABLE ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A VARIETY OF
FACILITY TYPE THAT CAN BE
PURCHASED OR LEASED WITH THE.
FUNDING THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WOW AND THREE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CARE NUMBER
BY ANY OPERATE PRESIDENT OF
GOLDEN STATE OPPORTUNITY AND
NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO ENDING
POVERTY I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT
THE INCLUSION OF I TEN HOLDERS
AND THE COUNTY I TT AND THE
CALL FOR INCLUDING TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE STATE BUDGET TO THE PARTY I
TT EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
EFFORTS AND PRE TAX CRAP. TODAY
HAVE HEARD YOUR DEDICATION TO
FINDING INCOME FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS BY MAINTAINING THE
EITC I REACH FUNDING THE STATE
WILL BE ENSURING THAT MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS CAN ACCESS UP
TO EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS BY
KNOWING ABOUT RECLAIMING THEIR
CREDIT. EVERY YEAR CALIFORNIA
DOES NOT CLAIM ONE POINT FIVE
TO TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL EITC DOLLAR BUT IN THE
FOUR YEARS THAT THERE HAD BEEN
FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH WHATEVER
DO TO REDUCE THAT B ROUGHLY
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION AND THAT
MONEY GETS SPENT IN OUR LOCAL
ECONOMY AND GENERATES MILLIONS
AND SALES TAX REVENUE. AND IT
FUNDING OF AN INVESTMENT IN OUR
WORKING FAMILIES AND THE RETURN
ON ITS INVESTMENT SIGNIFICANT
NOT ONLY FOR INDIVIDUAL FOR
LOCAL ECONOMIC STIMULUS THIRTY
THREE DAYS TIME AND MORE I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO INCLUDE THE
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
EDUCATION AND I REGION THE
CURRENT BUDGET THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS AND STAFF ALL THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING HERE. WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL. ONE TWO TWO TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ABOUT LITTLE TO ALIGN YOUR
CRAFTED ORGANIZATIONS LIVING
AND WORKING URBAN MORE BURKE
MERLE AND I'M- ARE YOU. SENATE
BEEN DEVASTATED ME IMPACT THE
BACK COVER NINETEEN AS AFTER
SHOCKS HOW BY DECADE OF
POLLUTING INDUSTRY. WAIT A
MINUTE REGULATORY NEGLIGENCE.
ALONG THANK YOU AMERICA VOTE BY
MAIL THUNDERSTRUCK EXECUTIVE
ORDER I RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR
THE NEED OF TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO MAINTAIN CURRENT
IMPORTANT VOTING CARMEN A LONG
FIGHT. YOU NEVER THINK WE'LL BY
NOW PUBLIC EDUCATION PUBLIC
VOTER EDUCATION OUTREACH
PROGRAM THAT SPENDS MORE WHERE
THEY NEEDED FOR DOUBLING THE
FINDER PROMOTE THANK YOU VOTER
AND INTO. YOUR COLOR OVER HYPED.
AND WE THANK YOU. ALL BOTH
YELLING DRAMATIC CUTS TO IN
PERSON BUT WE'VE BEEN I THANK
LARGE THE VOTER. I LOCATION
COULD BE A GIVEN HELP FOR IT.
WE MUST ACCEPT THE NUMBER OF.
ONE OFF FROM HER TO I THANK
VOTING FUTURE. TO BE HELD
DURING CALL THE NINETEENTH THAT.
IN ORDER. FIND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH PRACTICE. AND LET'S UP.
AND FIND HER IN PERSON BORN YOU
SOMETHING TO CRY BY LAW.
ALLOCATE JOINTED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. IN EVERY COUNTY FROM
NOW BALLOTS DROPBOX IN PERSON
VOTING LOCATIONS. IN ORDER TO
BAPTIZED BY LANGUAGE IS
PORTABILITY EIGHT RATE INCOME
LEVEL DIGITAL INFORMATION GOT
INVITED. JOG THE IN HOUSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER HUNDRED TWENTY IN Q. IF
YOU HAVE MORE TIME MISTER CARE
SURE. ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THREE THREE MAY BE ON
MUTE. HI MARIA FINALLY I HAVE
NO THAT IS I AM I AM A CALLING
TO LOOK FOR. THE PART OF A
FAMILY MEMBER CARDS TOM ALRIGHT
BEFORE BEFORE A WEEKLY INCOME
REPLACEMENT FUND FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS COURT
NEEDED FROM UNEMPLOYMENT.
INSURANCE INCLUDING NINETEEN
FELLERS AND CAL YEAH THE AB
COULD CLEAN NINETY THREE I'M-
IN MY COUNTRY BECAUSE GREATLY
TO CALIFORNIA THEIR 10% OF THE
STATE WORKFORCE AND PAY MORE
THAN THREE BILLION IN TAXES
EACH YEAR I'M AWFUL CALLING IN
ITS SUPPORT. OF MAINTAINING THE
BEAT INITIATIVE IN THE STATE
BUDGET THE THEME AND MISSION OF
WILL HELP OUR LONG TERM
ECONOMIC RECOVERY BY PROVIDING
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIA'S WHAT
MICROGRAPHS AND EFFECTIVE
TRAINING TO START OR RESTART
SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE HI ROAD.
HI ROAD BUSINESSES I WORK WITH
OPERATIVE BUT MOST OF ALL HELLO
BOUT OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
FAMILY MY FAMILY SPECIFICALLY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ARE YOU
STILL THERE. CAN YOU HEAR ME
NOW. THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH
TECHNOLOGY THESE DAYS. RIGHT
THEY'RE SWITCHING ASSISTANT
OPERATORS OKAY SO WILL PAUSE
FOR A WITHIN THE OPERATORS ARE
SWITCHING. IF FOR PAUSING COULD
I JUST MAKE ONE COMMENT
ABSOLUTELY I KNOW BECAUSE-
WE'RE DOING THIS RAPID FIRE-
ALMOST BE DATING APPROACH TO
THE BUDGET PROCESS- ONE THING I
ALSO WANT TO MENTION IS A VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF A NUMBER
PROPOSALS TO ASSIST IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES IMMIGRANT WORKERS
VERTICALLY UNDOCUMENTED WORKER%
SO- VERY MUCH WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD MR COVERS APPROACH-
AROUND- ON TALKING TO WORKERS
AND ALSO AGAIN. THE IDEA OF
EXPANDING THE EITC TO I TEN
WORKERS I KNOW IT'S NOT THE
SMALLEST BUDGET ITEM BUT- WE'VE
GOT TO DO MORE FOR- WORKERS WHO
ARE DOING SO MUCH FOR US DURING
THIS TIME PERIOD. AXIS AND PAY
TAXES. REBEKAH PHONE LINE IT.
SO OKAY SO WITH REFORM THAT
EIGHTEEN T. HAS LEFT SO WE'RE
GONNA GET THEM BACK ON SO
PLEASE STAND BY. A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY PEOPLE WITH OVER TWENTY
COLORS IN THE QUEUE. I'M NOT
SURE. I SAID I HOPE NOT I BET
THIS.
OKAY JUST TOOK UNTIL WE
WERE BACK ON SO JUST SO FOLKS
KNOW WE HAD SUFFICIENT TIME TO
TAKE ALL PUBLIC COMMENT. SOUL
BECAUSE THE PHONE LINES WENT
DOWN WHICH IS NOT OUR FAULT
IT'S THE FAULT OF THE PHONE
CARRIER- WE MAY NOT GET
EVERYONE'S RIDICULOUS CONTINUE
IN TRYING TO EVERYBODY IN THE
QUEUE. SO UP PLEASE BEAR WITH
US IN MY APOLOGIES. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE.
THE. MR MRS FOR
MODERATOR ARE YOU THERE.
SO IN
THE MEANTIME IF WE DON'T GET TO
EVERYONE OUR MIND YOU THERE'S
ALSO ANOTHER WAY TO HAVE YOUR
COMMENT NOTED THAT IS TO THE
EMAIL SYSTEM WITH WRITTEN
FEEDBACK AND I'LL GIVE YOU THE
EMAIL ONCE AGAIN IT'S BUDGET
SUB FOR AT A. S. M. DOT CA DOT
GOV TO THE WORD BUDGET B. U. D.
G. E. T. S. U. B. THE NUMBER
FOUR AT A S. M. THAT'S ADAM SAM
MERRY. DOT CA DOT GOV. THE
WHOLE. WHAT'S SO MISSED THE
PHONE PERSON CAN HEAR IS NOW IN
THE ROOM. OKAY WELL PLEASE. ONE
THREE SIX ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS LAWRENCE- I'M A
FACULTY MEMBER WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
WORK BETTER AND THE FACULTY AND
AN AFFILIATE WITH BEAUTY BIRTH
THE COMMUNITY A LABOR CENTER.
THIS WEEK RELEASED A RESEARCH
STUDY MATH OF JOB LOSSES AMONG
NON CITIZENS IN CALIFORNIA THE
U. S. UNEXAMINED UNPRECEDENTED
JOB LOCK THAT OCCURRED THIS
PAST MONTH WE FOUND THAT NEARLY
ONE IN FOUR PANDEMIC JOB LOSSES
IN CALIFORNIA. NOT THE
DEMOCRATS. IMMIGRANT WORKERS
ARE THE BACKBONE OF OUR ECONOMY
THEY WERE GOOD HOUSEKEEPERS AND
GARDENERS JANITORS AND FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE PANDEMIC HAS
DECIMATED JOB MILLIONS OF JOB
IN CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY IN THE
SERVICE SECTOR WITH SO MANY LOW
WHICH IMMIGRANT WORKERS
CONCENTRATE. WE ESTIMATE SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT
THOUSAND NON CITIZENS MANY
WITHOUT LEGAL STATUS TRACK THE
TO FIT IN A SEPARATE ON
EMPLOYMENT AND THE PANDEMIC
COMMENCED. HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN SUFFER.
THE PANDEMIC WITHOUT AS MUCH
EVEN TRADITIONAL UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. AND WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THE
PROFOUND HISTORICAL AND
HUMANITARIAN ASPECT OF THIS
CRISIS. AND TO DEVELOP PUBLIC
POLICY THAT DOES NOT LEAVE THE
SHUTTLE CALIFORNIAN BEHIND.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE
TWO TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS DOOR ROASTED
LEGAL MEMBERS OF CALIFORNIA. WE
CAN FUNDING FROM VOTING RIGHTS
AND WORKING TO EDUCATE EMPOWER
VOTERS FOR A HUNDRED YEARS THIS
IS ACTUALLY OUR CENTENNIAL YEAR.
WE STRIVE TO EXPAND
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO THE BALLOT BOX.
THANK YOU ALL KNOW AND THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORKED IT OUT
THE WAY WE VOTE WAS GOING TO
CHANGE THIS FALL. IT'S NOT
GONNA BE ALTHOUGH BY MAIL. IT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT IN PERSON THE VOTING
OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE AS WELL.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF PEOPLE WHO
NEED THOSE OPTIONS. LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS IS GONNA BE ON THE
FRONT LINES ALONG WITH MANY OF
OUR COALITION PARTNERS TO
PROVIDE PLAIN LANGUAGE
MESSAGES. OFFER TO MEET VOTERS
NEED TO VOTE WITH CONFIDENCE IN
ULTIMATELY. CALIFORNIANS TO
VOTE FOR THE CANDIDATES THAT
THEY- BELIEVE ARE GONNA HELP US
CLIMB OUT FROM UNDER THIS
PANDEMIC. BUT NORMAL SO
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN. THAT'S
GOING TO BE NECESSARY THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO HAVE
SIGNIFICAN FROM. AFTER THE
COMMITTEES WITHOUT SHOULD
COUNTY FLEXION. VOTING RIGHTS
COMMUNITY AT LARGE TO HELP
INSURE THAT WE HAVE TO SCHOOL.
THANKS TO THE MATH AFTER THAT
EVERYONE FORM OKAY HARDEST BY
THE- OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
PEOPLELOW INCOME PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. LANGUAGES IN
ENGLISH PEOPLE WHO ARE HELPING
SECURE WHO ARE THE HOUSE SO
THAT ALL OF US ARE ABLE TO CAST
VOTES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
COUNTED THIS NOVEMBER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE FOUR EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MEMORY.
THE TO BE JANUARY ARE WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
INCLUSION OF FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THIRTY BE
USED TOWARDS HOMELESSNESS
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY
HARBOR WITHOUT THAT YOU
CONSIDER THE DISTRIBUTION
METHOD FOR THE BOND THAT YOU
CONSIDER DOING A DIRECT
ALLOCATION TO. ALL NOT JUST
THOUGH THE POPULATION THE BOOK
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT
WILL BE INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISION. OUR VIEW IF YOU DO
DECIDE THAT THEY'RE FROM
DISTRIBUTION THAT SHOULD THE
COUNTY WOULD ACT THAT YOU TREAT
THEM EXCLUSIVELY AT THE
PROPERTY FOR THE RESOURCES. AND
NOT ALLOW FOR ANY
ADMINISTRATIVE THE THAT WOULD
BE CHARGED WHICH COULD TAKE
AWAY FROM THE ALLOCATION THAT
DESPERATELY NEEDED BY FIFTY. TO
COMBAT THE INCREASING
CHALLENGES RELATED TO
HOMELESSNESS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PUBLIC SAFETY. THANK YOU. LINE
SIX NINE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JONATHAN
BACK WILL SIGN AN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
THAT CALIFORNIA HOLD A NOVEMBER
ELECTION IT'S SAFE AND
ACCEPTABLE AND THIS WILL
REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT. A STATE A
COUPLE ELECTION MEANS PROVIDING
COUNTIES BUT THE FUNDING THEY
NEED TO PROVIDE A BILL BY MAIL
BALLOT TO EVERYBODY SHOULD
VOTER BEFORE THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION BUT IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT WE GO FURTHER AND
OFFER IN PERSON VOTING OPTIONS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT FOR VOTERS
FOR HOMEBUILDING BY MAIL IS AN
ACCEPTABLE. MEDICAL VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES WHO NEED SHEEN OF
AN ENGLISH SPEAKING VOTERS TO
BE BILINGUAL POLL WORKERS IN
TRAVELER BALLOTS AND HOUSING
AND SECURE OUR HIGHLY MOBILE OR
YOUNG VOTERS. WHO DON'T HAVE
RELIABLE ACCESS TO MAIL. THE
AVERAGE ALEXIAN LOOK ON WHY ANY
ALLOW. AND CAL HISTORY IT IS
CRITICALLY. THE LEGISLATURE
ALSO APPROPRIATED FUNDS
NECESSARY TO EDUCATE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS ON HOW TO VOTE IN THIS
MODIFIED ELECTION TO ENSURE
THAT NO VOTER THE
DISENFRANCHISED THANK. THANK
YOU. ONE ONE THREE EIGHT SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
MILLIONS OF MONEY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION AND A BROAD
COALITION ABOUT GET STANDING
TRAVEL AND TOURISM LABOR MEDIA
AND LOCAL CHAMBER. FOR THEM THE
REVISION EMPLOYMENT IN THE
LEISURE AND HOSPITALITY SECTOR
HAS DECREASED BY FIFTY THREE
PERCENT. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO CONSIDER A ONE TIME
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION FOR
THE CALIFORNIA TO CREATE A
TOWARD THE MARKETING CAMPAIGN.
A METER TRAVEL OF THE COULD BY
THE GOVERNOR SURE SURE
CALIFORNIANS THAT IT'S SAFE TO
TRAVEL AGAIN. AND TO ENCOURAGE
THEM TO CALIFORNIA WHEN THEY DO
SO WE CAN GET CALIFORNIA'S BACK
TO WORK. INVESTMENT WOULD
DELIVER TEN POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN REVENUE TO
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES. AND
EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
DOLLARS MILLION DOLLARS IN MUCH
NEEDED ADDITIONAL STATE AND
LOCAL TAX REVENUE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
ONE ONE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI HELLO HELLO HELLO YES YOU'RE
HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME I. YES HI
MY NAME IS IT IS THE FEAR OF
BEYOND I'M MEMBER NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION LOCATED BILLION
AFFECTS EVEN AND I'M DOMESTIC
WORK IN THE BUDGET NOT INCLUDE
ANY BASIC ECON FOR ANY IN THE
COMING IMMIGRANT IN CALIFORNIA
LIKE ME. THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE
IF ONE OF THE TEN WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA ON WHAT WE HAVE A
CHANGE OF BASICS. WE CANNOT
HAVE ANY WHAT WE COULD NOT HAVE
IMMIGRATION ATTRACTIVE THIS IS
NOT THE THING ALONG THE FRONT
DALY OF DEPARTMENT WE DEMANDED
BY THE AB WEEKLY INCOME FOR ALL
THESE WORKING WHICH- WOULD
THIRD JOB CORPS TO KOBE NINETY.
BETTER PROTECT VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS I'M PROVIDE
DIRECT RELIEF FOR BOTH
COMPANIES HURRIED BECAUSE OF
THE UPDATE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE THREE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PLAN THAT'S NOW WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK SIR IT WIDE
MULTICULTURAL HEALTH ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO
REDUCE HEALTH DISPARITIES WE
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS WORKERS THE ABILITY TO
CARE FOR THEIR CHILDREN ARE
YOUNG OR FAMILY MEMBERS. LOW
WAGE WORKERS MANY OF WHOM ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE HARDEST HIT
BY THE INABILITY TO TAKE CARE
OF THEIR FAMILY FINANCIAL
INSTABILITY NOW MORE THAN EVER
CALIFORNIA WORKERS MUST BE
SUPPORTED TO TEND TO THE NEEDS
OF THEIR LOVED ONES ESPECIALLY
DURING COLD AT NINETEEN I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO ECHO THE CONCERNS
ME BY FAMILY MEMBER CHIU
RELATED TO LANGUAGE ACCESS THAT
THE EDT. OF NOT A LOT OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARE SHOULDERING THE BURDEN OF
TROUBLESHOOTING AND PROVIDING
LANGUAGE ACCESS FOR THOSE FOLKS
ON SO WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK
WITH. EIGHTY BEYOND THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ONE THREE SIX
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS ON SCENE AND I LIVE IN
PARADISE I REALIZE THAT WITH
ALL THE HARDSHIPS. CALLED BY
THIS COMPANY VIRUS IN THE SHUT
DOWN AND IT'S EASY TO SHOP FOR
THE RECOVERY OF PARADISE BY.
THEN I'M CALLING TO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE CAMPFIRE RECOVERY
AND APPEARED I FEAR GET
IRRIGATION DISTRICT. I HAVE
STRUGGLED VERY HARD TO RECOVER
AND WITHOUT DRINKABLE WATER. IT
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO DO SO.
PLEASE RESTORE THE SEVEN POINT
ONE SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
PROMISED TO THE CURRENT I
FIGURED YOU CAN DISTRICT.
PARADISE MUST HAVE DRINKABLE
WATER TO RECOVER FROM. A PASTOR
BECAUSE BY THE CAMPFIRE I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. ONE FOUR
ZERO THREE GO AHEAD. ECONOMIC
THE BILLION BARRELS ON BEHALF
OF A BIT LIGHT INDUSTRIES
ATTACK ECOSYSTEM BETTER RIGHT
NOW IT WIDE INTRODUCED ON WORK
CA DOT ORG AND THE HEIGHT OF
THE COLD AT NINETEEN CRIED AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. THE CAPE COURT BANTER
ANY OTHER TO ADDRESS THE NEED
THE BALLOT HARDER BY THE CAN
DOWN THAT WE REQUEST INCLUSION
OF OUR PROPOSAL FOR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
TO SUPPORT CHANGES AND UPGRADE
ON BE A DOT ORG PLATFORM.
PLATFORM THIRD THAT THE SINGLE
SIDE ESTIMATION CONNECTING
PEOPLE WITH MUCH NEEDED JOBS
AND ESSENTIAL LOOKING AT. THAT
AND DURING THE TIME OF. THANK
YOU SO MUCH HERE. NINE EIGHT
SIX GO AHEAD. NINE EIGHTY SIX
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE. GOING ON AT.
OLA THE NUMBERS ON THE
RECOMMENDED THE NUMBER THE MORE
IT'S A BIT OF A COVER ON IT
APART. HE SAID MENTALLY WILL
NOT FOR MONEY THIS IS ABOUT
CUTS BUT I LOOKS KIND OF. IN
THE PAYMENT THAT THIS. IS THE
MOST OF SEPTEMBER THE- WE DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY ANOTHER KIND OF
THE TALK ABOUT ISN'T GOING TO.
THEY WILL NOT HAVE. MY SEVEN
AFFECTED ME GRABBED DO NOT. YOU
TO ISSUES THAT THAT THAT. WHAT
IS SOME OF THE CHRISTIAN THE AT
THE IT WAS TO THE WHOLE YOU.
INCLUDE OVER THE MONEY GLAZER.
I THINK THE MINUTE BUT I'M NOT.
LINE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
SIXTY SIX YOU MAY BE ON MUTE.
ONE OF WHAT I THOUGHT OF IT
NUMBER AMOUNT THERE ARE REAL-
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE IF YOU LET
THEM PUT IN SOMETHING HE'S CALL
ME THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT. A
BULLY A KEY OKAY A MAN AT THE
BOYS TO. ESTIMATES THAT UP
ABOUT THE HOUSE ALLOWED US IN
THE- THAT. A LITTLE IS THERE
NOT OF TALK THEY HAVE. THAT
YOUNG IS CLEAR ONE OF A BAD
IDEA HAVE A- CALIFORNIA. BUT I
FEW BOGUS BUT BOTH ONE OF MY IN
WITHIN THE DON'T ACCEPT
MINOTAUR. WELL NOT ONLY A GOOD
FEEL EIGHT ONE. ONE AT THE END
THE CLEVELAND IT'S THEY WANNA
MONEY TO GET ON THE- BOAT IT'S
OF SOME VACATION THE- A- BAY
AREA. THANK DOUBLES BY. AND BY
SOME POINT IN WOMEN NO. VOTE
I'M NOT BY I PLAYED A THAT MUST
THE THAT'S DEFENSE IN THE- BUT
WE IN THE AREA GOOD ACTORS.
THANK YOU. FIND ZERO ONE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE NINETY
LINE IS AB ON MUTE IT WILL. IT
WE SURE CAN I PLEASE GO WITH
YOUR COMMENT. CALL MAYBE YOU'VE
ON WORLD TELL COALITION COULD
YOU THINK THAT YOU HAVE
DIRECTOR. AND WE HAVE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND PLUS YOUNG PEOPLE
LIVING ON OUR STREETS ALONG AND
NAVIGATING COLD WITH LOSING
THEIR JOBS. SUFFERING AND BEING
EXPLOITED. AT ON A MANAGEABLE
RATES. AND IF WE WANT TO BATTLE
AND COME BACK HOME WITH YOU. WE
MUST CONTINUE TO SPREAD APART
FUNDING BUT WE DO NOT ALLOW OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE. WHO ARE.
DESPERATELY NEEDS. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DROP. SO I
MASCULINE URGING. THAT WE
CONTINUE TO- HAVE. A YOU THIRTY
FIVE AND 20% THE TO ALLOW
DOCTOR TO REALLY. FOR OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE EIGHTY THREE. THANK YOU.
THE HUNDRED LEFT IN Q. NEXT WE
HAVE ONE THREE SEVEN EIGHT GO
AHEAD WITH YOUR COMMENT. HI
CAROL I'M CALLING FROM PUBLIC
COUNSELED THE NATION'S LARGEST
GREGORY NINE FAN BASE AND I
LIKE. WE SAID LOW INCOME
CLIENTS ACROSS A RANGE OF
SUBJECT AREAS INCLUDING
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
CONSUMER RIGHTS AND I'M
COMMENTING ON THE PROPOSED
CHANGES TO GOV OKAY TWELVE FIVE
THREE ONE READ LIKE IT'S THE
NATIONAL MORTGAGE SETTLEMENT.
ON THE CLEATS FOR MORE MONEY TO
BE DEDICATED. TO LEGAL SERVICES.
I PUT MORE YOU MISTER. THAT
SOMEWHAT FINANCE CRISIS. WE ARE
NOW OR- IN THE BIG FIVE PAY
COULD. MORTGAGE SERVICING CASES
I'M NOT HARDLY ANY LEGAL
THIRTY. WE TALK ABOUT FIFTIES
THAT'S WHAT. OFTENTIMES WE
REFLECT THE FACT WHITE HOUSE
CERTIFIED QUE. I'M MORE
FAMILIAR THE ONES THAT GAVE
THEM WITH SEVENTH AT THE HELP
ACCOUNT GOAL ACCOUNT BECAUSE IF
LEGAL STAMPED. MAKE YOUR BY AT
WITHOUT TO GET HIS THE CAT LIKE
THAT THERE ARE MANY THE CALL
THE PRIVATELY FOR THIRTY ONE
FULLY SAID. HI BUT ALL BUDGET
THE MORE BY. FIFTY NOT ON THE
CONTROL ALL CONFUSED HAVE WITH
THE UNIT CAN KEEP CURRENT THE
STATE OF AFFECTION FROM. FOR
THE LIVING GNOCCHI SEE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK NEXT WE
HAVE ONE SEVENTY BY SEVEN ONE
PLEASE AHEAD. YOUR COOPER
MEMBERS THIS IS WHERE CORD I
THE FIRST THE PIECE FINANCE TO
BUREAU RESPECTFULLY A SENSE OF
URGENCY FROM WORKING FOR THE
LAST ECONOMIC CRISIS I ASK YOU
TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL PER DPO TO
STRENGTHEN THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL OVERSIGHT. IT WILL
PROVIDE YOUR CONSTITUENTS
WITHOUT USE OF GENERAL FUND IS
THE PROTECTION THEY DESPERATELY
NEED TO PREVENT PREDATORS FROM
SWINDLING THEM WHEN THEY CAN
LEAST AFFORD IT. TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE THE CALIFORNIA FAILED
TO ACT IMMEDIATELY WE KNOW MORE
PEOPLE LOSE THEIR HOMES AND
LIFE SAVINGS THEIR CREDIT AND
ACCESS TO CAPITAL WILL BE
DESTROYED MANY WILL NEVER EVER
RECOVER AND FAMILIES THAT
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO RESORT TO
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS WILL HAVE
NO OTHER CHOICE. PUTTING
FURTHER PRESSURE ON
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGETARY
RESOURCES MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RIGHT NOW MANY SOPHISTICATED
BUSINESSES ARE LOOKING TO GET
RICH. BY MAKING YOUR
CONSTITUENTS POOR PLEASE STOP
WHAT HAPPENED BEFORE IT
HAPPENED AGAIN THANK YOU. YOU
LINE SIX FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SIXTY FIVE WHAT ALARM BUT
IF SOMEBODY THAT ARE SAYING
THAN THAT AND IT IS NEEDED TO
BE BACK BECAUSE OF HOW THAT I
LOOK AT IT BUT IT'S A FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN NINE MILLION GOING
UP FOR MONNING DEATH OF BICYCLE
PART OF THE PROJECT BUT NOW I'M
LOOKING TO CONVINCE THEM PASSED
IT'S ENOUGH THAT THAT. IF WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF THE MANY
OTHERS WHAT THE **** THE THING
THAT YOU HAVE IN MIND WHAT IS
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR THE X. CAN
DOUBLE VIçT NAM THANK A
MILLION. WITH THE C<c.cyan>.</c>
HUDDLED UP. DON'T HAVE. SENATE
WHAT IT WILL BE. ONLY SOMEONE
NOT. PLUS OKAY. VIA PEOPLE.
ECONOMY CAR. OF MY- OF THE- ACT.
THE SMALL BUSINESS ORGANIZATION
URGING THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL- FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT TO GIVE A BETTER
TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND SMALL BUSINESSES.
AT A TIME ALL DEEPENING. CRISIS
FOR POINT SEVEN THE PEOPLE
FILED AN EMPLOYEE WERE AT 5% ON
AND- IN A DIRECTOR CORPORATE
RIGHT POINTS OUT THERE ARE. IS
THE OUT THERE THAT YOU COULD
TAKE A- OF PEOPLE IN THE OF
OVER. AND WE CAN WAIT AND
LONGER TO ENSURE THE GPL AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF. PROTECTION IN
HOW DO WE IT NEEDS TO US TO
PROVIDE MORE COMP. TO PROVIDE
OUT. IF YOU ARE TO CONSUMERS I
JUST VIOLATIONS WHAT ARE YOU
HEARING PEOPLE'S. TO GET RELIEF
FROM ONE AND FOR. WE'RE HEARING
ABOUT INCREASE IT AN AGGRESSIVE
COLLECTOR PACKED. AND WE'RE
HEARING ABOUT. STRUGGLING TO
PAY BUILDINGS ARE. ALL PRODUCTS
THAT RANGE EXT. TO QUESTIONABLE
TO GET RIGHT. ON THE WE CANNOT
WE TO COME FOR ANOTHER YEAR OR
A MONTH BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
HURTING NOW WITH WILL ONLY. I'M
SO I ON BEHALF OF MYSELF. AS
WELL AS GROUP RANGING FROM US
CENTER FOR. WORK PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOR FOURTEEN YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE. OUR HELLO NUMBER EIGHT
THAT MEDICAL METAL THE MAN THAT.
ALREADY IN THAT A LANYARD AND I
AM NOT SURE IF THAT'S THE WAY.
OF THE ANY ANNOYING AND ONE NOT
FOR MONEY SELECT BUT I LOOK
BUDGET THE END OF THE LOCAL
THAT'LL SO NOW I HAVE BAKED IN.
THAT WILL NOT A BAD IDEA EVER
HEARD TO. MAKE IT FOR THEY WILL
NOT THEIR YEAH WELL YOU KNOW
WHAT. AND I. THINK THAT THE AT
YOU KNOW I THOUGHT THEY NEEDED
ARAMBULA NET THIRTY. AFFECT THE
MIND. BODY FEEL LIKE FAMILY
YEAH BUT IT'S A BLANK ON A
WHOLE NEW. EIGHT MILLION
PROGRAM ADDING INVOLVED IN
BLACK BUT THEY MIGHT. BUT I
DON'T A LOT. FAMILY THE THICK
AND AFFORDABLE THE LEADER
FAMILIAR THANK YOU.FOUR FIVE
IN CREATING INCREASE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AT THE
PPO. WITH COMPLETE CAN NOT. A
ROBOT ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
WITHOUT PROTECTING CONSUMERS.
WITH NEARLY FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS MAKING CLAIMS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. AND IF
WE HEARD EXTENSIVELY TODAY
STRUGGLING TO OBTAIN BENEFIT.
WE THAT CREATES SEPARATION AND
IT PUTS PEOPLE AT MAX THAT
SHARK THAT COLLECTOR AND
DANGEROUS ONE. THE BEAUTY OF
THE PROPOSAL IS THAT WITHOUT
HAVING GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
YEAR CONTROL WHITE PLAINS YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. THE PROPOSAL WILL
PROTECT VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
ARE ALREADY BEING HAMMERED BY
FALLOUT FROM THE CAN DOWN. THEY
CANNOT WAIT AND WE URGE
ADOPTION OF THE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE FIVE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FOUR ONE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH YOUR
QUESTION. HELLO CAN NUMBER THE
CATALINA SANCHEZ WITH CARPETING
HI THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL CONSUMER LAW CENTER
WE'RE CALLING THE COURT OF THAT
THE ESCAPE OF CALLS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S MAYBE BY. THANK YOU.
ONE FOUR SIX THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS EVERYBODY BUT THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TRACTOR THAT CAN BE
RESPECTIVELY BUT LIKE TO
REQUIRE THE INCLUSION OF
BOARDING CARE HOME I'VE BEEN
OUR SMALL PROPERTY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SIX HUNDRED
MILLION IN CORONA VIRUS
RESPONDS BURKE WIRING HOTELS
AND MOTELS I'M HERE PROJECT
RICKY MARTIN CARE HOME POPPER
STRUCTURED SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENT YOU'RE IN
PRATTVILLE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WOULD EITHER BY. THE HOMELESS
WERE INSTITUTIONALIZED. THEY'RE
ALSO INCREDIBLY IN. IN TRANSIT
INDIVIDUAL OUT OF HOMELESS
THANK. MORNING CARE HOME THAT
ACROSS THEY ARE IN HIGH RISK OF
CLOSURE ON DURING THAT TIME.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST A ONE YEAR EXTENSION TO
THE EXPENDITURE DEADLINE GET A
COKE AT NINETEEN CHALLENGES.
FOR THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
TECHNICAL EQUIPMENT FIND. THAT
THESE CHALLENGES ARE
PRONOUNCED- IN SMALLER FOR ALL
COUNTY WHICH HAD BEEN WORKING
WITH SPEND DOWN DO YOU CAN
POINT. TO COLLECT EVIDENCE ON
THE SUPPORT THERE I'M ABILITY
TO APPLY FOR THE NO PLATE BACK.
HOME PROGRAM. HOW THE
INDIVIDUAL BETTER EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WITH THERE'S NOT A
LOT. WITH LIMITED ALLOW TO THAT
CARE CONSIDER A THANK YOU. YOU.
LINE TWO NINE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO NINE EIGHT YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE. AND FOR GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS STARKEY
ABRAHAM ON THE TURNING WITH
THAT STATIC LEGAL SERVICES
MARKET INTEREST I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE TF PI PROPOSAL-
OUR CLIENTS FIND THEMSELVES
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE RIGHT NOW
TO PREDATORY PRACTICES AND I
THINK THIS IS A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE TO
RESPOND QUICKLY TO THE CRISIS I
THINK BACK TO THE FORECLOSURE
CRISIS BUT STARTED TO HELP
EIGHT. IN SEVERAL YEARS IT TOOK
FOR SOME RESPONSES TO GET UP
AND RUNNING MILLIONS OF
POTENTIALLY UNNECESSARY
FORECLOSURES AND FAMILIES WHO
WALKED HOME IN TIME I THINK
THAT THE STATE CALIFORNIA HOW
THEY ARE UNIQUE AND USEFUL
OPPORTUNITY TO START PROTECTING
PEOPLE RIGHT NOW- WHAT THE
QUESTION FULL SWING AND I HOPE
THAT WE CAN DO SO IN PREVENT.
UNNECESSARY SUFFERING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FIND FOUR FOUR EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE WORLD
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVE THE
CALIFORNIA WE REGRETFULLY HAVE
AN OPPOSING WAS MINTED POSITION
ON EIGHT CITIES AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THREE CLEAN UP TRAILER
BILL THAT BILL ESTABLISHED AS
STREAMLINED MINISTER OAKLAND
REVIEW PROCESS FOR AG IMPORT
HOUSING PROJECTS DOES THE
PRODUCT OF EXTENSIVE
NEGOTIATIONS TO ENSURE PROJECTS
ARE CONVENIENTLY NOPE LOCATED
NEAR WORK SITES. WELL
ADEQUATELY PROTECTING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY DOCUMENTS THE
TRAILER BILL SPARKLING CLEAN UP
AND WE THINK IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
PROGRAM EXPANSION IT ALLOWS
THE- PROJECTS TO BE LOCATED ON
LAND BUT AREN'T THE ZONE
PRIMARILY FOR AGRICULTURE AND
SO THESE WOULD BE LAMBS THERE'S
ON PRIMARILY FOR SINGLE FAMILY
RESIDENTIAL COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL PURPOSES. COULD
RESULT IN INCONSISTENT LAND USE
THAT AS AN INCREASE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED AT A TIME WHEN
THE STATE'S REALLY STRONG
REQUEST FOR A LOCAL TO REDUCE
BMT SO WE THINK IT WILL BOTH
LOCAL INPUT ON THIS PROJECT
AND- TIRE HANDS IN OUR ABILITY
TO REDUCE THE EMPTY AND FUTURE-
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUESTED FOR
THE BILL BE AMENDED. AND WE
ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR THE SEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION IN FUNDING
FOR PARADISE IRRIGATION
DISTRICT THAT WAS INCLUDED IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET WE THINK
THAT IS VITAL TO FACILITATE
PARADISE THIS RECOVERY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. TO BE
IN A NINETY IN Q. NEXT WE HAVE.
FORCE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FOUR SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FOUR SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
REPORT ON THE HOUSE OF THE
COMPETITION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING AND HELPING CALIFORNIA
WE SUPPORTED TWO BILLION DOLLAR
COALITION PROPOSAL ON
HOMELESSNESS THAT BUILT ON THE
GOVERNOR'S NEWLY REVISED USING-
FEDERAL STIMULUS AN EXISTING
STATE SUNDAY. THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD ALSO BUILT ON PROGRESS
OUR STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE MADE TO ENSURE SAFETY
HOMELESS POPULATION. IT WOULD
HAVE SINCE FIFTEEN PROJECT ROOM
KEY RESIDENTS AVOID RETURN TO
THE STREET. WE PROPOSED SELLING
GAPS NAY LIMITATION PROPOSAL TO
OFFER RENTAL ASSISTANCE IN A
PRIVATE MARKET TWO OF THEM ONE
PAYMENT. CAP TO CONVERT ANY
POTENTIAL FIGHT TO PERMANENT
HOUSING AND OPERATING IN
SERVICES FUNDS TO ABOUT THOSE
PROJECTS TO CONTINUE TO
FUNCTION. IT ALSO CALLED
TURNOUT FROM LOCAL ALLOCATIONS
THE FEDERAL FUNDS TO COORDINATE
WORK HAPPENING AT THE LOCAL AND
STATE LEVELS. FINALLY REPRIEVE
THE PROPOSED FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION THE
STATE TAX CREDITS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THANK YOU.
LINE FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MANY ASTRONOMICAL WORKER
RESEARCH CENTER A NONPROFIT AND
ONTARIO I'M WITH GOVERNOR YOU
RECENTLY LAUNCHED THE DISASTER
RELIEF ASSISTANCE FOR
IMMIGRANTS ALERTED THE STAR
IT'S NOT LONG TERM HELP THE
PROGRAM IS ONLY ENOUGH TO COVER
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND OUT OF THE
ESTIMATED TWO POINT THREE
MILLION IMMIGRANTS THAT WE
FIGHT IN CALIFORNIA. OTHER
WORKERS CAN COUNT ON UP TO A
THOUSAND EVERY WEEK FROM
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TO MEET
THEIR FAMILY'S BASIC NEEDS WE
NEED A THINKING THAT FOR ALL OF
US TO PROVIDE ONGOING INCOME
SUPPORT FOR ALL UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS HAVE LOST THEIR. JOBS
AND THE NEXT. GET BY MAR. SOME
EVEN WORKING HAVE HAD TO BORROW
MONEY WERE THEY CAN. WE AND
LINE UP FOR BANKS AND CUT THE
ON BASE NEEDS TO PROVIDE FOR
THEIR- AND MANY ARE. IN FEAR
ONE OF THE- WITH OUR LIVE AND
THOUSANDS OF IN BUT IN I DO. A
STRONG SUPPORT INCREASE OF THE
WEEKLY PART INCOME. FUND FOR A
DOCTOR WORKERS HAVE BEEN. BY
COVER NINETEEN AND THE JUNE BY.
THANK YOU. LINE SEVEN NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN CAPTIVE OFFERED THE
FIRST FIVE UNTIL SHE OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
FIFTY FIRST FIVE COUNTY
COMMISSIONS ACROSS THE STATE
THEY WERE URGING YOU TO REVISE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
FOR THE NEW NICOTINE BAYSTATE.
WE DO NOT DISAGREE WITH THE TAP
THE TAXING OF THESE PRODUCTS
WOULD YOU ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE-
HABITS THAT ARE SUPPORTED OF
THE FLAVORS BAD MOVING. THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE BUT WE DO
DISAGREE WITH PROPOSED REVENUE
DISTRIBUTION WHICH WILL
UNDERCUT THE EXISTING TOBACCO
TAXES THAT SUPPORT PUBLIC
HEALTH EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS AS
APPROVED BY CALIFORNIA. FOR
FIVE .COM FINE. BY A FIFTY CENT
PER PACK CIGARETTE TAX AND A
FOURTEEN POINT 8% EQUIPMENT TO
TAX AND OTHER TOBACCO PRODUCTS
INCLUDING THE CIGARETTE. WE ARE
WORRIED ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
THAT BEFORE BY PASSING EXISTING
TOBACCO TAXES AND WE'RE WORRIED
ABOUT THE IMPACT THIS WILL CALL
THE COLLUDED REVENUE DECLINE.
FIRST FIVE IS AN ESSENTIAL PART
ESSENTIAL PARTNER AND ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS COMMUNITIES AND
BUILDING SYSTEMS THAT ARE
HEALTHY CHILD DEVELOPMENT
ACROSS. HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES
AND EDUCATION THE SERVICES WERE
CENTRAL BEFORE COPA NINETEEN
AND THEIR IMPORTANCE. ONLY GO
TO BUY. FOR ALL THESE REASONS
RESPECT ASK. TO APPLY THE TAX
STRUCTURE. ON BAKED PRODUCTS TO
THE NEW NICOTINE BASE
ASSESSMENT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. ONE ONE THREE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
HAPPENED HERE AND I'M GONNA
GEHRY WITH LEGALLY THAT WORK
WITH ADVOCATE THE RIGHTS OF LOW
WAGE WORKERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND SPEAKING TODAY TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR GOVERNOR
NEEDS AND BUDGET PROPOSAL
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR
JOBS WHEN THEY TAKE LEAVE FROM
WORK TO CARE FOR THEMSELVES ANY
CHILD OR- FAMILY MEMBER. THIS
PROPOSAL DOES NOT REQUIRE
EMPLOYERS PROVIDE PAID LEAVE
RATHER ENSURE ONE POINT ACCESS
THE PAID LEAVE BENEFITS THEY
THEMSELVES PAY FOR WITHOUT
BEING FIRED FOR DOING SO I KNOW
THERE IS A QUESTION FROM THE
TERRITORY ALL THIS INTERACT
WITH THE NEW LEAVE UNDER
FEDERAL LAW. I WANTED TO POINT
OUT THAT THE NEW BELIEVE UNDER
FEDERAL LAW AMEND THE FAMILY
MEDICAL LEAVE ACT NOT STATE
LAWS CLEAR THAT RUN
CONCURRENTLY WITH FMLA ALTHOUGH
THE LIMITED FMLA EXPANSION
PLANS AS OF THE END OF THE
YEAR. FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS NOT COVERED BY OUR
JOB WITH ACTION LOT BECAUSE
THEIR EMPLOYERS TO SMALL TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN THE FAMILY HOW
AND THEIR INCOME BUT THE
PROBLEM BEFORE THE HAND THAT
NIGHT BUT OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS AT THE FAIR FROM
THOUSANDS OF LOW WAGE WORKERS
ACROSS OUR CLINICS AND HELP
LINE ONE THING I'VE BECOME
CLEAR THE CONTINUATION OF THE
INEQUITABLE SYSTEM IS
UNCONSCIONABLE. NOW IS THE TIME
THE CALIFORNIA ACT TO ENSURE
THE HEALTH ECONOMIC SECURITY
AND WELL BEING OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND BEYOND. WE ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT INCLUSION OF A
WEEKLY PARTIAL INCOME
REPLACEMENT FUND BRENT
DOCUMENTED WORKERS OF AN IMPACT
THE BACK OF THE NINETEEN IN THE
CAN BUDGET INCLUDES. IN PILAR
THE CAL I YEAH I CAN SEE A.
YOUNG CHILD TAX. POINT BEING
CLOSE ENOUGH STEVEN ACTION AT
THANK YOU FOR MUCH. LINE ONE
ONE ONE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME MY WAY AND ON THE
WAY ORANGE NEW YORK ANKLE FONG
GIVE OUT I HAD A REALLY QUICK
BECAUSE OF WITH THE CHAIR HE WE
CAN CONTINUE TO EXPAND THE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE- AT ME I
FEAR THAT KNOWLEDGEABLE HAD
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE IT AND THEN
I WANTED TO STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE INCLUSION OF WEEKLY PARTIAL
INCOMPLETE NOT. A REPLACEMENT
FIND PLAN DOCUMENT WORKERS HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY COLBERT
NINETEEN AND THE GYM BUT GET
OUR NATIONAL LEADERSHIP BELL
ISN'T PROACTIVE IN PROTECTING
COMMUNITY FROM CODED NINETEEN
AND I HOPE THAT YOU ALL DON'T
BALLOTS THAT'S WHILE I FEAR
THAT WE CONTINUE TO IF CONTINUE
TO CUT BACK WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY THAT ARE HE WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO RECOVER IF YOU CAN
CONNECT LOOK THE OTHER WAY I
WANTED. YOU OFFER YOUR LEADERS
DURING CREDIT AND NOT YOU CAN
TO ALL. INCLUDING OUR AND
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU BUT. ONE
THREE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CAMELOT AND I AM
WITH LEGALLY AT WORK THE
REVISED BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE
ANY FORM OF INCOME SUPPORT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS THIS
IS UNACCEPTABLE THE MAJORITY OF
WORKERS WHO HAVE LOST WORK AS A
RESULT OF THIS CRISIS ARE NOW
ELIGIBLE FOR ANYWHERE BETWEEN
SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY AND ONE
THOUSAND FIFTY DOLLARS A WEEK
IN UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. AND
AS WE HEARD FROM THE LA TODAY
CALIFORNIA HAVE PAID OUT TWELVE
BILLION IN UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS SINCE THE START OF THE
CRISIS HOWEVER ONE GROUP HAD
BEEN ENTIRELY EXCLUDED AND THAT
IS UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS TO MAKE
UP ONE TENTH OF OUR WORK FORCE
IN CALIFORNIA. IN EQUITY MUST
BE ADDRESSED IN THE JUNE BUDGET
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR AFRICAN SETTING UP IT
IS AFTER RELIEF FOR IMMIGRANT
PROGRAM SURELY NO ONE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT A SINGLE FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IF THE PATIENT
DRAFT. UNEMPLOYMENT QUITE THAT
THAT'S WHY WE'RE BEING IN A
WEEKLY INCOME REPLACEMENT
FRIEND WORKERS BECOME
UNEMPLOYED YOU TO CALL THE
NINETEEN TO BE INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE MEMBER CHIU COOPER PORTS.
AND HOPE THE REST OF THE- WILL
JOIN HIM. WEEKLY AT WORK ALSO.
THE INCLUSION OF ITUNES. IN OUR
NEW C<c.cyan> TACK CREDIT THE</c>
INCLUSION OF THE INITIATIVE THE
EXPANSION OF JOBS JOB
PROTECTIVELY UNDER. THANK YOU
VERY. NINE TWO SIX NINE PLEASE
GO. GOOD AFTERNOON YOU OUT
COOPER AND THIS IS YOUR LONG
DEFENSE AND REPRESENTING THE
ASSOCIATION FINANCIAL
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION ALSO
SPEAKING FOR NUMEROUS SMALL
BUSINESS ORGANIZATION CBO IS AN
NGO THAT ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO ENSURE
THAT FIFTY MILLION ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS ARE PUT INTO THE AYE
BANK SMALL BUSINESS FINANCE
CENTER. WHICH WILL HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THAT MORE THAT
THAT MONEY IS DEDICATED TO THE
TRUCK TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED BY COUPLE THAT
NINETEEN HAVE AN ABILITY TO-
REBUILD. THE PROVEN TRACK
RECORD OF THE FINANCIAL FELDMAN
CORPORATIONS OVER THE LAST
THIRTY YEARS AND JUST LAST
YEAR. THEY MANAGE TO HELP SAVE
AND CREATE OVER SIXTEEN
THOUSAND JOBS THEY ALSO HAVE A
GREAT PARTNERSHIP IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THEY ARE
LOCATED IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND THEY THEY
PRIORITIZE TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE HELPING- IMPOVERISHED
COMMUNITIES DIVERSE AND
MINORITY BUSINESSES. AS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE THREE
SIX FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BETTY HUNG
UP WITH THE UCLA LABOR CENTER
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS INITIATIVE TO
ENSURE THAT UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS ARE INCLUDED IN
CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC RECOVERY A
DOCUMENTED WORKERS ARE KEPT
PERCENT STATE WORKFORCE AND
WHAT THE BILLION IN TAXES EACH
YEAR THE-MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION AND THE BABY FIVE.
BUT WILL PROVIDE UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIA MICHAEL GRANT AND
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
EFFECTIVE TRAINING START WORK
WE START SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE
HIGH BOTH BUSINESSES AND WORKER
COOPERATIVE THIS WOULD HELP TO
CREATE QUALITY JOBS AND PROMOTE
DEMOCRACY IN THE WORK PAGE.
DURING THE STATE'S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY WITH DOCTORS AND KEEP
YOUR CAN BY A THRONG BEATING
THE **** IT IS ESPECIALLY
CRITICAL WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
EVEN THE SHOULD THE STATE
BUDGET WE ALSO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TO INCLUDE I CAN BY
LAWYERS IN THE COUNTY I PP
PROGRAM INLAND TO URGE YOUR
SUPPORT ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALL
RICH PROPOSAL. FOR WEEKLY
INCOME REPLACEMENT FUND FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO ARE IN
EQUITABLY EXCLUDED FROM
UNEMPLOYMENT. BUT THE EQUITY
INCLUDE FOR DOCTOR CALIFORNIA
WE CAN PROVIDE A MORE VIBRANT
AND ROBUST ECONOMIC RECOVERY
AND HELP TO ENSURE A CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE A LOT FOURTH FIVE
PLEASE CALL. GOOD AFTERNOON-
JENNIFER PER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE CLOSED THE PROPOSAL
NAY REVISED THE BAND THE FAMILY
LEAVE- WE ARE IN AN ECONOMIC
CRISIS WITH RECORD HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT AND WE'RE GOING TO
NEED A ROBUST PRIVATE SECTOR IN
ORDER TO GET A THOUGHT OF THIS
CRISIS. INCLUDING A TWELVE WEEK
WE'VE ABOUT AN EMPLOYER'S ONLY
HAVE ONE EMPLOYEE ILL BE THAT
THE STATE EMPLOYERS WHO ARE
ALREADY STRUGGLING AS A RESULT
OF THAT AND THEN. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS THIRTY ACTED ON
THE ISSUES MAKE SURE THAT
INDIVIDUAL AFFECT THE CALL BUT
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE
CYCLICAL BUT CAN STAY AT HOME
WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND
RECOVER UNDER THE CARE THAT
THEY PROVIDED TWENTY WEEKS OF
CACTUS LEAGUE. OF ALL. INCLUDED
WHEN YOU CAN ARE YOU ME TWELVE
QUIRK WEEKS OF WHEN YOU COMBINE
THAT WITH THE PUBLIC. ONE THE
BUDGET WOULD BE A- SIX WEEK
WE'VE ABOUT. A PROBLEM. WE NEED
TO DO WITH MORE ENCOURAGE JOB
GROWTH AND NOT. FOR THAT THE
TIME WE'RE ALSO NOT CLEAR HOW
THE PROPOSAL NECESSARY CAN. THE
AND WE BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE A
CALL FOR THE QUESTION THAT
MOVED THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
AT THAT HAPPENED THE PAST AND
FINALLY. WITH REGARD TO THE
FUNDING TO ENFORCE EIGHTY FIVE.
WE BELIEVE THAT EIGHTY FIVE IS
STILL IN IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING WORKED ON JEFF YESTERDAY
THE AUTHORED AB FIVE. DEFENDED
TO BUILD. AND A FAULTY CANADIAN
INDICATED THAT THERE WERE MORE.
AMENDMENT AND REFORMS NEEDED ON
EIGHTY FIVE IN THAT IT WAS A
WORK IN PROGRESS. YEAH WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TO DELAY
ON THAT AND THE FUNDING FOR
IMPORTANT THE LIFE STILL BEING
WORKED ON. THANK YOU. THREE OF
ONE ONE FOUR SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
INSIDE EVEN SMELL EL I'M FROM
PARADISE CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF
OF MY FAMILY. CHILDREN MY
MOTHER AND FATHER IN LAW AND MY
MOTHER AS WELL AS I IMAGINE THE
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
REMAINING HOMES AND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR
BUILDING PERMITTED ISSUED. FOR
ASKING YOU TO PLEASE. PLEASE
RECONSIDER. THE BUDGET CUT. THE
CARD IDEATION DISTRICT FOR
SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS PROMISED- TO
OUR COMMUNITY. WITHOUT
DRINKABLE WATER PARADISE WILL
NOT RECOVER. IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THOSE OF US ARE TRYING TO
REBUILD OUR LIVES. BE ABLE TO
COUNT ON CLEAN WATER SO THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE HEALTH HEALTHY TAKE
THE COMMUNITY. EMILY AND OUR
FRIENDS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NOTHING IN MY NAME IS
ANTHONY NINE AND WITH THAT YOU
SEE LATE LABOR CENTER AND I
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO INCLUDE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS. IN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY
BACK DEPARTING THAT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS- PROPOSAL FOR IT YOU
CAN THE SHOULD HAVE IN THE
STATE BUDGET UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA GREATLY THERE ABOUT
10% OF THE STATE'S WORK FORCE
AND PAY MORE THAN THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN TAXES EACH YEAR.
THEY NEED TO BE DEDUCTED WILL
PROVIDE UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS WOULD MAKE A
GRAND. ACTIVE TRADING THE START
OR RESTART SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE
HI ROAD BUSINESSES AND WEBER
COOPERATIVES WITH DOC AND GPS
HANGING BY A THREAD IF. YOU DID
IT SHOULD IT IS MORE IMPORTANT
NOW. IT'S A PART IN DOCKET
EMIGRATE. AND AFFECT THE WHAT
CAN OCCUR. BY FOR CALIFORNIA
BACK TO PUT THE DIDN'T IT IS WE
ARE OF. INCLUDE OF I CAN BY
ALERT. AND COUNT YET YEAH I. T.
ICY. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALL
PROPOSAL FOR WEEKLY REPLACE
FIND FOR DOCUMENT WORKERS WERE
EXCLUDED. FROM UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AND ARE REALLY
HOPPING AT THAT GET THROUGH
THIS. ENDEMIC THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL HAVE THIRTY MINUTES
LEFT IN THE HEARING WE GOT
SEVENTY FOUR COLORS. ON THE
LINE SO I WOULD IN. REMIND YOU
PLEASE USE THE WELL CITY AT THE
IN THIS HEARING. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE TWO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS KAREN CIVILIAN I'M
COMMENTING ON THE OF
EFFECTIVELY BLENDING IN SUPPORT
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
DURING THE CALL BUT NINETEEN
CRIED BATH AND BEYOND. YOU THE
COLOR AND LOW INCOME. DIFFICULT
IMPACTED BY THE CRISIS BUDGET
WE NEED PROMPT AND
COMPREHENSIVELY. UNFORTUNATELY
FEDERALLY FACT THAT THE FAILED
TO MEET THAT NEED AND STATE.
AND NOW. A GREAT RELIEF MEASURE
WILL BOTH STABILIZE PEOPLE'S
LIVES DURING THE CRISIS AND IT
MUST THAT PEOPLE OUGHT TO
PROVIDE BETTER OFF TO. THE FBI
WILL ACCOMPLISH BOTH OF THESE
OBJECTIVES. IT'S FORWARD
LOOKING DEFINITIONS WILL
CAPTURE THE KINDS OF A
BEAUTIFUL AND IS NOW OFFERING.
HATING LIKE PREDATORY PRODUCT
WHO CURRENTLY. STATE OF THE
SITE BEGAN. THAT THE DEALER
HAVE JOHN THE EXISTING FAT
COULD DEFINITION. SECOND THAT
THE F. B. I. WORK BETTER CALL.
THE BILL IN A LONG BUT PROVIDE
THE COULD WITH PEOPLE TO
LEVERAGE FUNDING THE CLASS BE
TO THE BED. IN THE FACT THAT
THE BILL HEATING COLOR
PRODUCTION BUT THE COFFEE A
BILL FOR PROPOSAL. SO
PROVISIONS. WILD WITH THEM BACK
ON RECESSION THAT WOULD
CERTAINLY FROM CRISIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU N. IN LIGHT OF THE OF
CALLS WE ALSO SAY. GOING
FORWARD YOUR NAME WHO YOU'RE
WITH IN YOUR POSITION WHAT YOU
SUPPORT. THAT WILL USE MANY
COLORS AS POSSIBLE. AND TO BE
COURTEOUS. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE TWO NOW. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS AND IOWA AND I AM
CALLING IN A COUPLE OF THE
CENTER WILL. I SUPPORT DURING
WONDER INTO WORK FOR THE PARTS
ON CLOSER. I WOULD STRONGLY TO
THE OF PAY FROM. FOR THANK YOU.
ONE FOUR SIX SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SH I AM CALLING LAW NOW
LIVING IN CHICO FORMERLY MANY
YEARS IN PARADISE TO MAKE IT
SHORT AND BRIEF I AGREE REQUEST
THAT YOU DEFERRED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
RESTORE THE SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS PROMISED
WITHOUT DRINKING WATER CARE
GUIDE WILL DIE CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S NOT ONE A CAL ONE OF ITS
COUNT PLEASE RECONSIDER. THE
SEVEN POINT THREE WITH YOUR ALL
THAT WAS PROMISED FOR THE WATER
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE ONE
FOUR NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRED MAP BROUGHT ON ME AFTER
THE TEAMSTERS IMPAIRED AT THE
ASIAN DISTRICT I WOULD JUST
ECHO THE SENTIMENT THAT WE HOPE
THAT- THERE WILL BE A
REAPPROPRIATION OF THE SEVEN
POINT THREE SEVEN MILLION FROM
I'M- TED DIETARY GAUGING
DISTRICT. IT'S IMPORTANT- FOR
THE RECOVERY OF PARADISE AND
ALSO FOR HER AND MEMBERS THAT
WORK AT AND LIVE IN PARADISE
WORK AT THE IRRIGATION
DISTRICT- I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE ON. ANOTHER CRISIS
IN THE STATE AND THE TOP
FINANCIALLY BUT WE AB WE HOPE
THAT YOU CONSIDER THE VICTIMS
THE PARADISE MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE FOUR
EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS SHANNON HOW THAT FROM
THE DIRECTOR FOR NAY ROUTE FOR
CHOICE CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF BUT
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS STATEWIDE I'M
CALLING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
THE GOVERNOR THE FAMILY LEAVE
TRAILER BILL HERE THE THAT THE
COMPONENT OF REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM. AND ALSO LIKE TRADE
EMPHASIZE THAT THE MAYOR
REVISED DID NOT INCLUDE ANY
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING FOR
VOTER EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
AND IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE
ADDED TO ENSURE WE HAVE THERE
AND TAKE A LECTURE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE THREE FOUR EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE FOUR
EIGHT YOU MAY BE ON MUTE. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS MARY MARTIN I
LIVE IN PARADISE CALIFORNIA AND
I WANTED TO ARGUE THE COMMITTEE
TO RECONSIDER THAT CAMPFIRE
RECOVERY. EDUCATION SIX I KNOW
I'M REBUILDING MY ST MAIN LINE
HAS BEEN DIRECTED TO CLEAN UP
AND THEY THEY REPLACE BASIC IN
THERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. ONE TWO ONE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS JODY JONES
COUNCILMEMBER TOWN OF PARADISE
I WAS THE MAYOR WHEN THE FIRE
CAN'T FIRE HAPPENED AND I'M
CALLING TO URGE YOU TO RESTORE
THE SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S BEEN CUT. FROM
THE PARADISE IRRIGATION
DISTRICT THAT MONEY WAS
PROMISED LAST YEAR WITH ACTUAL
STRINGS ATTACHED THAT THE
PARADISE IRRIGATION DISTRICT
HAS LIVED UP TO AND WE'D LIKE
TO SEE YOU KEEP YOUR PROMISE TO
THE TOWN OF PARADISE. OUR OUR
TOWN NOT ONLY HAD THE CAMPFIRE
BUT NOW WE'VE HAD THE SHUT DOWN
FROM CODE WE ARE STRUGGLING TO
RECOVER AND WE NEED YOUR HELP
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE CLEAN WATER
WE CANNOT RECOVER WITHOUT CLEAN
WATER PLEASE RESTORE THE SEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SIX ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
THE LEADING MAN I'M A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER FROM PARADISE
CALIFORNIA I AM ALSO URGING YOU
TO RECONSIDER CUTTING FUNDING
FOR THE PAIR RIGHT THERE DAY
CAN GAUGE AND DISTRICT. THE
BACK FEATHER LOST REVENUE AND
SUPPORT THE RECOVERY FROM THE
CAMPFIRE WATER IS THE FINAL
REPORT IN THE RECOVERY OF THE
TOWN OF PARADISE. COURT NOT
ONLY RESIDENTS THAT BUSINESS
AND TRYING TO RECOVER- I'VE
HEARD A LOT OF COMMENTS ABOUT
THE CURRENT- AND STRUGGLES THAT
ARE RELATED TO KOBE NINETEEN
AND PLEASE JUST REALIZE THAT
THE PEOPLE IN OUR AREA ARE
DOING THE SAME THING. NOW ON
TOP. OF THE TRAUMA AND
DIFFICULTIES AND RECOVERING AND
REBUILDING AS WELL. PLEASE
DON'T RECITE OF OUR COMMUNITY
RECOVERY IT IS NOW IN DURING A
SECOND TERM ATTIC INVENT YOU
BANKS IN LESS THAN TWO YEARS
WITH THAT AND THEN I. THANK YOU
THAT. LINE TWO ZERO ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH WITH YOUR
CHARACTER. HELLO BRIAN SHAW HI
MY DISTRICT TO BOARD OF
DIRECTORS THE- DISTRICT I'M
ALSO- GENERAL CONTRACTOR HERE
LOCALLY OUR COMMUNITY IS
ARGUMENT DEVASTATED BY THE
CAMPFIRE. MY RESERVE HUNDRED
REPRESENT THOUSAND
CONSTITUENTS. WHO ARE COUNTING
ON US TO PROVIDE DRINKING
POSSIBLE WATER TO REBUILD THEIR
LIVES. THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLAR REVISION IS AFFECTING
OUR DISTRICT WILL BRING OUR
EFFORTS TO A GRINDING HALT TO
REBUILD THE TOWN PARADISE.
PLEASE BE A CHAMPION FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO CONTINUE TO TRY TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES. AND TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION RE SENDING
THE SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLAR DEFICIT THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS GOING TO BE CAUSING
WITH THIS NEW BUDGET- WE I
THINK WE'VE BEEN THROUGH ENOUGH.
AND WE NEED THIS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME GO. THANK YOU. THREE
FIVE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS MONEY NEXT RELEASE
POLICY INTERN WITH CHIRLA AND A
RESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO I WOULD
LIKE TO URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASH
KALRA CALL ROSE PARTIAL INCOME
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS AND
INCLUDED IN THE TWO AND BUDGET.
I AM ALSO SUPPORT OF THE COUNTY
I TO SPEAK SPANISH AND FOR I
THINK TYLER AND THE GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE THREE ZERO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS AND PACE
AND I LIVE IN CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. YES THANK YOU- I AM I TO
LIVE IN PARADISE CALIFORNIA AND
I'M ALSO CALLING TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE CAMPFIRE RECOVERY.
AND THE PARADISE VARIEGATION
DISTRICT AND TO ASK THE
GOVERNOR TO PLEASE TO FURTHER.
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL TO CUT
SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS PROMISED TO THE
PARADISE JERRY CATION DISTRICT
WITHOUT DRINKABLE WATER PARADOX
WILL NEVER RECOVER. AND WE NEED
TO RECOVER I LIVE HERE MANY
PEOPLE THAT CARE AND WE WANT TO
COME BACK SO PLEASE HELP US
COME BACK THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE FOUR EIGHT ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME I WOULD
NOT. WORKING FAMILIES ARE SILLY
INSTRUCTORS THAT ABOUT TWO
THIRDS OF THE STATE INCLUDING
ME THEY SAY ABOUT ORGANIZATIONS
IN THE SILICON VALLEY CENTRAL
COAST LOS ANGELES IN THE EMPIRE
ORANGE COUNTY SAN DIEGO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE LETTER
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AND
THIRTEEN OTHER LEGISLATORS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT- IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT WE PROVIDE
pREPLACEMENT IN THE GINGER
BUDGET. FOR UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT SO FAR WE'VE HAD BY MY
COUNT ABOUT SIX SPANISH
SPEAKERS SUPPORTING THIS ISSUE
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WAS ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND THE FACT THAT THEIR
SUPPORT HAS BEEN LOUD AND CLEAR
THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL BENEFIT
BAKER WHO WAS PREVENTED FROM
SPEAKING BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
TRANSLATION SO I HOPE THAT THE
CAN CAN. IMPROVE LANGUAGE
ACCESS ISSUE FUTURE- AS WELL AS
SHOW CALIFORNIA STRONG
COMMITMENTS TO IMMIGRANT
WORKERS- DURING THIS CRISIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBER
REVERIE FLOWS FOR TRYING TO GET
EVERYBODY'S COMMENTS IN HERE
PLEASE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
WITH THE SUPPORTER POSE SWING
IT EVERYBODY'S TAKE. ON THIS
THE COLOR PLEASE. LINE FIVE.
BLANKS EIGHT GO AHEAD. YES
RICHARD GALLON OF PUBLIC
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR OUR CAPITAL
WE'VE SAID OUR LETTER REQUEST
ASKING THAT YOU PAUSE ALL
FUNDING INCLUDED THE BONDED
DEBT FUNDING OF SEVEN HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE CAPITAL
ANNEX PROJECT TO ALLOW TIME TO
REPLY IN THE PROJECT WITH
PUBLIC INPUT. AND TO PRESERVE
OUR CAPITAL PARK AND OUR
HISTORIC ANNEX THANK YOU COULD
YOU. LINE THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS THE VOLUNTARY CLEAN I'M WITH
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATE FOR YOU
WHAT THE FOCUS ON PROJECT ROOM
KEY WITHIN THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSED
TO THE REVISION. THAT WE HAVE A
YOUTH SATISFIED LOOK AT THE
HOME WITH THE FUNDING. STATE
BUDGET WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
YOU INCLUDED THAT SIDE OF NO
LESS THAN 10% FOR HOW MUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE THREE
NINE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REVENUE MISTER CHAIR LARA BUT
ON BEHALF OF THE FAVORITE
FAVORITE TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
HERE TO OPPOSE THE GOVERNOR
BUBBLE AS WRITTEN ON THE TAXI
TO GROWTH AND ASK YOU TO
COMPLETE ALTERNATIVE FINAL
POINT DAHLE THAT READS REVENUES
AND CRITICAL STATE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE ONE FIVE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO TWO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS BRENDA KLEIN AND I LIVE
IN YUBA CITY CALIFORNIA
FORMERLY BUT AT THE END SHE
TELL THEM. I HAVE FRIENDS AND
FAMILY IN. RIGHT SENATE BILL
YET AND I'M CALLING TO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
CAMPFIRE RECOVERY. AND THE
PARADISE. CATION DISTRICT
PLEASE GIVE PER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- THOUGHT. AND RESTORE
THE SEVEN. POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS PROMISED. RIGHT
IRRIGATION DISTRICT WITHOUT
DRINKABLE WATER CARED I WILL
NEVER RECOVER AND I BELIEVE
THAT THE TAXPAYER IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO SUPPORT.
THOSE WHO HAVE. IN. PAYING
TAXPAYERS. AND IN OPPOSITION TO
PUTTING THOSE WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
PAYING TAXES THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE THREE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KATIE
WATTERS SMITH I'M WITH A
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION I'M CALLING TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S TRAILER BILL AND
JOB PROTECTED LEAVE I'M I
PERSONALLY HAVE WORKED WITH
MANY FAMILIES OF A LACTATION
CONSULTANT- WHO LOST OUT ON
PRECIOUS TIME WITH THEIR BABIES
JUST BECAUSE THEY HAPPEN TO
WORK FOR A SMALL EMPLOYER. WE
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF A WEEKLY INCOME
REPLACEMENT FUND FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO'VE
BEEN IMPAIRED. IMPACTED BY
COVERT NINE. IN THE GYM BUDGET
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ONE FOUR TWO ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS NICOLE I JUST
AND I IN A SECOND GRADE TEACHER
IN THE AREA AND WE HAVE BEEN
HIT PRETTY HARD AS WE ARE- WE
ARE ASKING THAT WE OPPOSE THE
GOVERNOR'S BILL RIGHT NOW IN
DIFFERENT EVERY DOOR SEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS BUT
WITH HOW MUCH WORK MUNITY. ONLY
CENTER COMMUNITY YEAH AND- FOR
BUT MY FAMILY CAN OFF THE BOARD
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
ONE FIVE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROSE TRYIN I
LOST MY HOME AND PARA PARADISE
DURING THE CAMPFIRE WE ARE
CURRENTLY REBUILDING ON HOME ON
OUR EXISTING LOT WHAT ABOUT THE
CITING FACTORS IN THE BUILDING
A HOME WITH A SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION PROMISED TO THE
PARADISE- ENGAGING DISTRICT.
WITHOUT THE STANDING OUR
PROPERTY VALUES WILL PLUMMET IN
OUR TOWN WILL NEVER RECOVER WE
NEED SAFE DRINKING WATER FOR
CHILDREN ELDERLY AND RESIDENTS
OF PARADISE. PLEASE REPORT IT
PLEASE RESTORE THE SEVEN POINT
THREE MILLION PAIR. PROBLEMS
WITH HER THEN SHARED CATION
DISTRICT AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMAN GALLAGHER FOR
HIS SUPPORT SPENT THANK YOU FOR
TAKING MY CALL. IN TWO FIVE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS YOUR BE A CAT AND I'M A
FORMER RESIDENT. OF SAID
COUNTY- AND THANK YOU MAY I IN
ON ONLY SUPPORT THE INCLUSION
OF A. B. THE INCOME REPLACEMENT
FINE BUT I'M DOCUMENTED WORKERS
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY COVERED
NINETEEN IMAGINE BUT- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND FIVE TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THAT MAKE UP
BUT I BUT I'M WITH THE
WAREHOUSE WORKER RESOURCE
CENTER WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF A WEEKLY PARTIAL
INCOME REPLACEMENT BOND.
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS SLAPPING
IMPACTED BY CORPORATE NINETEEN
IN THE JUNK BUDGET LAST WEEK OF
YOUR FRIEND OF MINE SHARED HOW
SHE'D BEEN ENCOURAGING HER TWO
YOUNG CHILDREN. TWO STREET AND
REST OF MUCH OF POSSIBLE SHOULD
BRING THE CRISIS BABIES AT THE
VACATION SCHERING BUT THE MORE
THE REST OF THE ENERGY IT THERE.
AND THE MORE YOU CAN STRUCTURE
LIMITED PUTTING GOOD. THEY HAVE.
STORY LIKE THIRTEEN SORRY THAT
YOU'RE SURE EARLIER TRIMMING.
ARE YOU HE MY FAMILY THE SAFETY
NET THANK YOU CAN STOP INTO.
HIS FAMILY. RIGHT AND IT HUNGER
AND THE NEW FOR SHELTER NO OR
CARE ABOUT IMMIGRATION STATUS
RIGHT IF YOU MEMBERS TO CARE I
IN SUPPORT OF MEMBER KALRA.
NUMBER TWO. COURT AND I'VE
NEVER OF THE COMMITTEE TO. A
WEEK BEFORE OVER FUND FOR
TALKING WORKER WHO HAVE BEEN
HARD HIT BY A CAR IN THAT YOU
BUDGET WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION I BY. THE CALL EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT YOU CHILD
CAUGHT CREDIT INCLUSION OF EVEN
IF YOU'RE IN THE STATE BUT-
DOCUMENT IMMIGRANT ARE YOU CAN
IN CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
FOR YEARS AND DECADES THE
TRAFFIC UP OFF THE PROPERTY FOR
PATIENT THAT WILL BE LEFT WITH
NO CHOICE BUT TO RELY
CALIFORNIA HOWEVER. WHEN YOU
SIT DOWN TO EAT. HEY ON
DOCUMENT FORMER AND DALY SUPPLY
WITH USED TO BRING OUT THE BACK
TO YOUR PLACE. DON'T TELL THEM
NO. LINE ONE ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL. ANY WITH ANY
GIPSON WITH ENCORE CAPITAL
GROUP AND WE AGREE WITH THE
CHAIRMAN THAT OVERSIGHT BY THE
REBRANDED DPO AND THE BILL IS
TOO BROAD AND SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED FOR THEIR NEXT YEAR
OKAY OUR CONCERN IS WITH THE U.
GAP ALREADY ESSENTIALLY ANYONE
CAN DECIDE WHAT IS WHAT THEY
CHOOSE TO BE UNFAIR DECEPTIVE
OR PIZZA. IF THE COURT WANTS TO
REGULAR TEMPORE HOWEVER THEY
DID BY TWO AND NEEDS TO BE FOR
THE CONSIDERED AN NARROWED INTO
COKE. THANK YOU. THANK. LINE
TWO ONE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS A LIKE A
HOWARD AND I'M A POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH CONSUMER ACTION
ON BEHALF OF LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME. OFF THE STATE I URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE PROPOSED DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT OVER ALL
ESPECIALLY SINCE THERE IS NO
IMPACT ON THE GENERAL FUND- I
HEARD YOU KNOW BUT THE PPO
PROPOSAL OFF. THE COURT. OUR
TOPIC. THE COMMITTEE THAT AFTER
DAY. THE UPGRADE PHASES THE EDT.
UPGRADE OR IN THE CASE THE BDO
PUTTING OF HONG BUT-
CALIFORNIA'S OUR LAST FINANCE.
VOTER DURING THE A BY. OF THE
COMPANY OUTBREAK. IN THE COMING
MONTHS AND EVEN YEARS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND THREE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE EIGHT HE
MAY BE ON MUTE. FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THAT THE
FOLKS BUT I'VE BEEN WHAT THE
UCLA LABOR CENTER CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE INCLUSION OF THE
BUCK AND EVERYTHING AND THE
STATE OWES COLLECTION ECONOMIC
RECOVERY EFFORTS TO THE FEEDING
MISSION OF ALSO CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE INCLUSION OF AYE
COMPILERS AND COUNTY I KEEP BE
ON THE PHONE WITH. A COLD LOOK
FOR A WEEKLY AND QUIRK LET'S ON.
IN YOUR WORKERS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR EIGHT TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ALMOST THREE WHO AND I'M
CALLING FROM MONTCLAIR I'M A
DOCTOR EVERY FIFTEEN AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARLESS PROPOSAL FOR
WEEKLY INCOME REPLACEMENT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS TO PAY
ALMOST THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
TAXES AND ALSO- MAKING SURE
THAT WE INCLUDE THEM ARE WE
INCLUDE I. TEN FILERS IN COLOR
OUR- E. I. T. THREE- AND ALSO
SUPPORTING OUR DEFEAT
INITIATIVE. TO STAY IN THE
STATE BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THREE SEVEN FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO HELLO OF YOUR YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO FIVE GO
AHEAD WITH YOUR QUESTION. YES
MY NAME IS BRENDA PICK KERN AND
I'M CALLING FROM THE CHECK UP
CALIFORNIA. AND MY FAMILY WE
EXPERIMENT STUFF FIRST MY GREAT
GRANDMOTHER DIED IN THAT.
SPANISH FLU AND THEY CAME TO
CALIFORNIA AND NOW WHERE MY
FAMILY IT HISTORICALLY IS NOW
EXPERIENCE COLBERT SO
CALIFORNIA HAS PROVIDE MANY
CATASTROPHE MANY MANY WE WILL
GET TO WEAR THAT. WAIT AND THEY
ATTACKED IMMIGRANT HISTORICALLY
AND WHENEVER TIMES ARE HARD WE
NEED TO ADDRESS THE EMIGRATE
AND SHOWN BY TRYING TO BALANCE
THE BITE. ON THE BACKS OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE VALID SEVEN
THOUSAND MYSELF AND MY
SIGNIFICANT OTHER I BOUGHT A
STABLE. HE IS A DOUBLE AMPUTEE
I'M LEGALLY BLIND BOTH OF US
ARE AND WELFARE ARE PROVIDERS
THEY ARE TRYING TO CATCH. THE
INCOME OF OUR PROVIDER. AND ALL
OF THAT I THINK THE BUDGET
NEEDS TO BE- STANFORD AND LOOK
BACK ON WHAT THERE. I TRY TO HI
I THINK THEY CAN DO BETTER OUT
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO CATCH.
HAS STATE MSF KEEP PROGRAM IS
ONE THAT. HAS BEEN THERE FOR A
FORTY ONE YEAR START AT THAT
OUT. IT'S JUST RIDICULOUS BOB.
BUT I DO APPRECIATE EVERYTHING
YOU GUYS ARE DOING THANK YOU.
FIND FOUR FIVE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIND FOUR FIFTY FOUR IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JEFF AND
THAT YOU'VE BEEN AND I'M FROM
PROTECT CALIFORNIA. WE NEED TO
THE FOR THE SEVEN POINT THREE.
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET WE NEED
TO RESTORE THE WATER TERRACE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND FOUR
NINE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
QUICK RESPONSE IS WHAT YOU'RE
OF THE COLLEGE OF REMAIN
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS BACK WHEN ALL
THE COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
IN SUPPORT OF THE US CAR
PROPOSAL THE FEET INITIATIVE
AND THE COUNTIES THE EXPANSION.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE ONE TWO ONE
TWELFTH PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS ABRAHAM MELENDEZ I
WORK WITH- NONPROFIT TENTACLES
ALLIANCE UNITED PERSONABLE
ECONOMY TELEMARKETER COUNTY AND
I'M CALLING- TO SUPPORT THAT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT INCLUSION OF
WEEKLY PARTIAL INCOME
REPLACEMENT CONFRONT DOCUMENT.
CHRIS TO HAVE AN IMPACT EFFECT
OF THE NINETEEN THIS WEEK WE
SAW THE FACTORY NEAR FROM OUR
COMMUNITY- BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
THAT MEET THEIR NEEDS CANNOT BE
MET UNTIL AFTER THE FACT THAT
WOULD ASSISTANCE FOR IMMIGRANTS
ON OPEN WEBSITE COMPONENT
ACROSS THE STATE CRASH DUE TO.
THE AMONG THE FAMILIES THAT
WERE CALLING AND OF THE STAFF
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN RECEIVING
HUNDREDS OF CALLS SIMILAR TO
THOSE CHAIR TODAY. ANY HELP
UNTIL WE START. THE COULD HAVE
IN THE GYM BUDGET TO. SUPPORT A
FAMILY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE FOUR NINE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ACTUALLY WARNER WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY BATES AND
NOW WE ASK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PRIORITIZE IN THE BUDGET THAT
ELIMINATION OF DEBT FOR TENANTS
AFTER THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
INVESTMENT AND LEGAL COUNSEL
FOR LOW INCOME TENANTS AT RISK
OF ADDICTION INCLUDING AND
DOCUMENTED PENDING. INVESTMENT
IN THE PRESERVATION OF EXISTING
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING HAVE
WAITED LOT. IN ADDITION WE MET
IN MEETING AN ACCEPTABLE IN
PERSON VOTING OPTIONS FOR EVERY
CALIFORNIANS THIS INCLUDES
MAINTAINING IN PERSON VOTING
REQUIREMENTS. ALONGSIDE THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER FOR UNIVERSAL
MAIL BALLOT INVESTING IN
HELPING YOU MEASURES TO PROTECT
WORKERS AND VOTERS AND
INVESTING IN PUBLIC EDUCATION
CAMPAIGNS EVERY VOTER KNOWS HOW
TO VOTE. THANK YOU. ONE FIVE
ZERO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE COOPER MY NAME
IS JACKIE LONG AND CAP HIRING
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN AND WE WORK
TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OVER
TWO MILLION CHILDREN LIVING IN
POVERTY I SUPPORT THE MY
COLLEGE BEFORE ME AND WITH
INCLUSION OF AYE COMPILERS AND
CALLIE I TO SEE. WITH THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM AT THE COMING
OF OUR POWERS MAKE WITH THE
PUBLIC FOR INCOME REPLACEMENT
THE OFFICE OF WORK AND
INVESTMENT IN CALLIE I TT OUT
WHICH TAX PREPARATION. THE
INCREASE THE M. AND HOMELESS
YOUTH. ALL THE- PROPOSAL ON IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL THAT
YOU'RE DOING THANK YOU. LINE
THREE TWO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THREE TWO ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I ONE FIVE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK MY NAME IS PATRICIA TO
SPEND I AM A RESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA I'M THE LAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO RECOVER FROM THE
DEVASTATING CAMPFIRE JUST
RECENTLY WE WERE ALL INFORMED
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAD DECIDED
TO TAKE AWAY AT SEVEN POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS. PROPOSAL
THAT WOULD HELP OUR WATER
BECOME DRINKABLE AGAIN AND I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO
THINK ABOUT. WELL WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH WATER CHILDREN HAD BEEN
THROUGH WHAT THEY'RE GOING FOR
NOW. YOU KNOW THAT AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S THAT
BREAKING EVERYWHERE. BUT WE
CANNOT SURVIVE WITHOUT WATER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS
FOR NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ONE AND
PARTICIPATE- WERE WERE HEALTH
WORKERS BECAUSE SENATE- ON
MONDAY FORTY STATE LEGISLATORS
LED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASH
CARLO. HOLDS A PLAN TO BE AT
LEAST EIGHT WEEKS OF INCOMPLETE.
TO A DOCUMENT. WORKERS WHO HAVE
BEEN LEFT BEHIND IN THIS CRISIS
ONE TIME PAYMENTS WILL HELP
FAMILIES GET BY THIS WEEK BUT
WHEN NO ANSWER THE PENDANT.
EIGHTEEN AND FOR ALL OF US TO
KEEP CALIFORNIA STATE AND
HEALTHY. THAT'S WHY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE INCLUSION OF A
WEEKLY PARTIAL INCOME
REPLACEMENT ONE FOUR DOCUMENT
WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
BY KALRA NINETEEN. IN THE GYM
BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FIVE TWO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME AGAIN
AHEAD ALL AND I WHAT THE
TECHNICAL SERVICES IT'S PAST
MONDAY FOURTEEN STATE
LEGISLATURE FLOODED LEGISLATORS
LED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
PROPOSED A PLAN TO PROVIDE AT
LEAST EIGHT WEEKS OF INCOME
SUPPORT UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
WHO HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND IN
THIS CRISIS. AND THEN I CAN
FIGHT WE NEED A LONG TERM
SAFETY NET FOR ALL OF US TO
KEEP CALIFORNIANS EATING
HEALTHY. THAT'S WHY WE STRONGLY-SUPPORT THE INCLUSION OF A
WEEKLY PARTIAL INCOME
REPLACEMENT FINE FRIEND
DOCUMENTED WORKERS HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY CLOTHING NINETEEN
IN THE JUNE BUDGET. WE ALSO
OPPOSE THE PROPOSAL IN THE MAY
REVISED ALLOWING THE FUNDS
COLLECTED UNDER THE PRIVATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL APTITUDE THAT.
THE GENERAL FUND. ACTUALLY
REQUESTED THOSE BANDS REMAIN IN
THE BUDGET TO THERAPY
ENFORCEMENT PRIORITIES AT THE
AL WTA AND NOT BE REALLOCATED
TO SELL EITHER GAPS IN THE
BUDGET AND PROPOSED IN A
REVISED. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
FUNDING ALLOCATED PATAKI TO
SUPPORT WORKERS RIGHT CONTINUE
TO SERVE ITS PURPOSE.
PARTICULARLY UNDER THE AND
DAMAGE WHICH IS PLACE WORKER
THAT EVEN FURTHER REST OF
ANYTHING AND IT QUITE HATED
WORKING CONDITION THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN A
MINOR SPEAKERS BREVITY TECHIES.
MR NAME AND WHO YOU'RE WITH AND
SUPPORTER OPPOSE. WE'RE RUNNING
OUT OF TIME. SEVEN FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS RITA
SCIENCE I'M A VOLUNTEER FOR A
RP CALIFORNIA AND A. R. P.
STANDS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
GOVERNOR NUISANCE PROPOSAL FIX
THEM TO EXPECT EXPAND JOB
PROTECTION FOR FAMILY
CAREGIVERS. BUT THE WORKING
FAMILY CARE GIVERS WE HAVE
ABOUT FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS PROVIDING HAPPEN
ADULT FAMILY MEMBER WITH A
SERIOUS CHRONIC. ILLNESS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- ASSEMBLYMAN
COOPER FOR CONTINUING TO
ACCEPT. TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
NINE FIVE THREE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ROBERT NO
TOP OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CONGRESS PROPOSAL FOR A
WEEKLY INCOME REPLACEMENT UP
FRONT TRANSACTION WORKERS. WERE
CURRENTLY EXCLUDED FROM
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND ALSO
INCLUDING AYE COMPILERS FOR A
CAL YET SHE- TOOK THE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
CONTRIBUTE GREATLY TO THE TO
CALIFORNIA THERE 10% OF THE
STATE'S WORK FORCE TO PAY MORE
THAN THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
TAXES THE YEAR- AND I'M ALSO
CALLING SUPPORTED MADE HIM THE
TREATED MICHIGAN THE STATE
BUDGET. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. FIND FIVE FOUR SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND THREE ONE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANGELA
BRINGING WITH CENTER LOOK AT
THAT ADDRESS THAT AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE INCLUSION
OF A WEEKLY INCOME REPLACEMENT
FUND FRIEND DOCUMENTED RECORDS
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY CO BUT
NINETEEN IN THE JUNE BUDGET.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE FIVE
ONE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEAR
ME. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HI MY NAME IS TIM AT WHAT
PRESIDENT CAL FIRE LOCAL TWENTY
ONE. REPRESENTING THE MEN AND
WOMEN OF A LARGE PARTY PARK IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
SECOND IN THE COUNTRY. I CALL
ON BEHALF OF MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS AND- OPPOSITION TO ANY
DOLLAR YOU REDUCTION. THAT THE
BAD ENDANGERED POLICY AN
ARBITRARY. WE STRONGLY REJECT
AND HAPPY TO REJECT ANY CUTS
THE STATE EMPLOYEES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE THREE FIVE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH SO THE
RECORD SHOW ON THE A RETIRED A
RESIDENT OF. CALIFORNIA MY
FAMILY MY SON AND- MY SISTER
ALL WALK THE PROPERTY THAT
BEARD A CAMPFIRE WE APPRECIATE
YOU KEEPING UP WITH MINE LOSING
SIDE OF OUR NEEDS IN THE COSTS
OF RESTORING. WE WOULD DOT
STRONGLY ENCOURAGED THE
DIFFERING OF THE SEVEN POINT
THREE BILLION BACK INTO THE
BUDGET FOR P. ID. THERE'S A
NUMBER OF MAJOR BARRIERS SO WE
HAVE OTHER COSTLY FOR
REBUILDING. WE WANT TO GET OUR
COMMUNITY THAT IN ORDER ARE
WORKING HARD DID YOU SEE THIS
MORNING THERE'S OVER A DOZEN
PEOPLE CALLED IN. AND I'M SURE
THERE'S MORE THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN THAT THEY CAN
MAKE THE CONTACT I ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO ENCOURAGE IF THERE'S
ANYWAY IN THE BUDGET. WE'RE IN
THE NINETY FIGURES ON JUST THE
DAMAGE OF OUR PRIVATE ROADS IN
DIED DUE TO THE CAMPFIRE PLEASE
KEEP THAT IN MIND AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
FOR INPUT THANK YOU. FIND FOUR
ONE THREE. THE SEVEN WARRANT Q.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI NAME IS
TOTALLY DIFFERENT ON THE X.
DIRECTOR OF THE CLEAN CAR WASH
CAMPAIGN. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORTING OF THE WEEKLY INCOME
REPLACEMENT BOND FUND DOCUMENT
WORKERS. AND FOR THE COMPANY
AND GYM BUT WE ALSO SUPPORTING
OF THE FEET INITIATIVE IN THE
STATE BUDGET SO THAT
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS ARE
INCLUDED IN CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY STRATEGY.
THANK YOU. FIND FIVE SEVEN ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS LINDA DROP MY HUSBAND BOY
AND MY SON IN LAW AND DAUGHTER
GRANDCHILDREN AND MY PHONE
UNLOCKED MOM LOCK STOCK HOME IN
PARADISE CALIFORNIA DURING THE
CAMPFIRE I'M CALLING TO URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
CAMPFIRE RECOVERY AND PARADISE
HERE CATION DISTRICT. PLEASE
THE FOR THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND RESTORE THE SEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION PROMISED TO
THE PARADISE IRRIGATION
DISTRICT WITHOUT THE DRINKABLE
WATER WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD WE ALL HAVE INTENT
AND ARE REBUILDING IN OUR HOME
IN PARADISE ALONG WITH
COUNTLESS OTHERS AND BUSINESSES
INCLUDE. PLEASE COMMENTS. WE
PROVIDE THE PROMISE FUNDING FOR
P. ID THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU. AND FIVE FOUR ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN CHAIR
NUMBER MY NAME IS MONICA MURPHY
CALLING ON BEHALF OF ALL PEOPLE
RIGHT ADVOCATES AND THE CHART
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK
SUPPORT GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND JOB LEAD YOU ALL
CALIFORNIANS PARKING FAMILY. WE
ALSO URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
INCLUDE ALL IMMIGRANT TAX
FILERS MCCAULEY I KEEP THE
STATE BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. FIND FIVE SEVEN ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BAKER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
OUR TOPIC IS THANK YOU FOR-
GETTING A TIME TO MAKE COMMENTS
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ONGOING SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS CAUGHT THE
COUNCIL'S BUDGET- BUT
PRESENTING THOUSANDS OF ARTS
NONPROFIT ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CONTINUE SUPPORT
FOR THE ARTS BUDGET. AT AN
ONGOING FUND OF TWENTY SIX
MILLION WE UNDERSTAND THE NEED
TO WITHDRAW THE TEN POINT FIVE
MILLION IN THE MAY REVISE BUT
JUST WANT TO URGE THE PORK FOR
ON GOING ON IT'S CRITICAL FOR
OUR CHARACTERS WHICH HAD BEEN.
HIT DISPROPORTIONATELY BY THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC AT WE
HAD TO BE THE FIRST TO CLOSE
AND LIKELY THE LOCK THREE OPEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
FIVE TWO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IN FIVE TWENTY ONE YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE. AND FIVE ONE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS KEVIN IN
CO FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT INCLUDING I
TEN FILERS AND CAL I. T. EITC
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE
TRAILER BILL WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE KALRA PROPOSAL FOR
WEEKLY INCOME REPLACEMENT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS. AS WELL
AS THE SEAT INITIATIVE AND CAL
EITC OUTREACH AND FREE TAX
PREPARATION FUNDING THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ON AND OFF THE BY THE UNITED
WAY THE CALIFORNIA OUR STATE
WHAT MEMBERSHIP OF THIRTY LOCAL
UNITED WAY IS COVERING EVERY
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA URGE THE
COMMITTEE AND THE EXCLUSION OF
IMMIGRANT TAX FILERS IN KELLY
AGENCY IN YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT THE CRITICAL OF THE
STATE ECONOMIC RECOVERY EFFORT.
I ALSO WANT TO QUICKLY
EXPRESSED UNITED WAY STRONG
SUPPORT OF FUNDING TO THE KELLY
AGENCY OUT REGION EDUCATION AND
FREE TAX PREPARATION ASSISTANCE
GRANTS AT A TIME OF ECONOMIC
INSECURITY THE NEED FOR TAX
FILING OF THE DRAFT WE GO OUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THESE ISSUES. NINE FIVE EIGHT
EIGHT WE HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS THE NEED FOR THE WITH
THE MAINTENANCE COOPERATION
TRUCK FIND AT A RESIDENT OF
LIKE WHAT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE INCLUSION OF A WEEKLY
INCOME REPLACEMENT FUND FREND
DOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY KOBE NINETEEN
AND THE JUNE BUDGET IT IS
NECESSARY TO HELP PEOPLE LIKE A
ALL FROM ORANGE COUNTY THAT WAS
LET GO CLEAN JOB AND IS NOW
HOME WITH. PREGNANT AND DOES
NOT KNOW WHERE THE NEXT MEAL
WILL COME FROM WE CANNOT LEAVE
PEOPLE LIKE A FIVE YEAR BEHIND
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE INCLUSION
OF I TEN FILERS AND THE CAL
YEAH LIKE YOU SEE AT THE
INCLUSION. OF THE SEAT AND
YOU'RE SURE THAT THANK YOU. I
YOU. ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I KNOW COMMITTEE
MEMBER BOB MICHEL FAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COLOR AND
UNDOCUMENTED WORKER INCOME
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM THE
EXPANSION OF A KALECKI I KEEP
THE TITAN HOLDERS A. B. FIFTY
NINETY THREE AND THE THING THAT
SHOULD HAVE. UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS THEY MORE THAN THREE
BILLION IMPACT OF THESE HERE
AND WE SHOULD NOT OVERLOOK THIS
CRUCIAL CONTRIBUTION TO OUR
ECONOMY AND OUR ECONOMY
ECONOMIC RECOVERY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
LINE FOUR TO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I YES MY NAME IS FIFTY
MATH I AM CALLING REGARDING THE
SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION. THE
IDEA THAT THE GOVERNOR STOP
FUNDING- HER- THAT WAS PROMISED
I FIRST MOVED UP TO NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN WE HAVE TO HAVE
CLEAN WATER- THIRD OUR CHILDREN
OUR GRANDCHILDREN. I DON'T WANT
TO GET CANCER. PLEASE. I'M I'M
ASKING FOR THE GOVERNOR TO
PLEASE PASS THAT THROUGH AGAIN.
AND THIS WITHIN THREE FOR MUCH
THANK YOU. BY TWO TO THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK TO TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
ALLOWED WHEN THE- NUMBER OF
YOUNG IN THE LAST STORY BUT THE
PROVIDER OF GOALS. THAT ARTICLE
COVERS THE LEVEL THEY WERE VERY.
THEREFORE YELLING BUT ON A
CALIFORNIA MOSTLY THE COMING
BATTLE AS FAR AS- ELECTRIC
BADLY EIGHT BILLION. ALL NOT A
BAD IDEA WELL HELLO THERE THE
CALIFORNIA THEY LOVE IT THIS
WILL BE THAT BAD. THE BILL IS
SETTLED IN THE TO FIELD IT'S
COMPLETAMENTE. THAT EVENING IN
LET ANYTHING. THE DAYS THAT
FOLLOWED IT WHAT IS THE SIXTY
HE MOVED IN. IT YET BY. ONLY
BUT I'M NOT IN MY LAST THAT I
SO THEY GET A FULL BUT I
HOLIDAYS IN THE COMING BATTLE.
THANK YOU ALL. THE DATA. OF FOR
THE THING OF IT IS ACTIVE.
THANK YOU. ONE FIVE EIGHT FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
GABRIELLE CHILI WITH CALIFORNIA
SHOULD POLICY ADVOCATE WE WANT
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
INCLUSION OF I TEN FATHERS IN
THE COUNTY THAT YOU SEE AS WELL
AS THE REMEMBER COLLARD
PROPOSED PERSONAL INCOME A
PLACEMENT PROGRAM PRINT
DOCUMENT WORKERS. THANK YOU.
NINE FIVE NINE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S ALEXANDER
OF WITH YOUR CREATE TURNING TO
LOOK AT THE LINE AND I'D LIKE
THANK EXPRESS A STRONG SUPPORT
FOR. ONGOING WEEKLY INCOME
SUPPORT OKAY MINUTE WORKERS FOR
JOB PROTECTED LEAVE BUT
INCLUSION OF ITUNES BY THE YET
TO SEE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TAX CREDIT AND TENANT
PROTECTION AND FOR THE FEET
INITIATIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE SIX ZERO TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SIX ZERO TWO YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE. NINE SIX ZERO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ALEX TO CAPREOL BEHALF THE
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA DOT THE
PART OF THE GOVERNOR HE CAN
BARELY PROPOSAL TOOK THAT JOB
PROTECTED LEAVE ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKING FAMILIES
BECAUSE NO CURRENT STUFF TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN THE WELL BEING
OF THEIR CHILD MY FAMILY'S
FINANCIAL SECURITY AND HOW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE. ONE
FIVE SEVEN FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELCOME CHAIR MEMBERS WITH THE
FACTORY WITH ME GOVERNMENT
UNLIKE SOME CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA AND
THAT'S FOR THE CALIFORNIA TELL
THE COMMANDERS VETERANS COUNCIL
MOTEL BUDGET. OUR WELL CHAPTER
BE A ONE OF AMERICA TELL STATE
CAL STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSED CLOSER BOSTON BUT FROM
FROM THANK YOU. I CAN'T WAIT.
CALL NINE SIX ONE ZERO THE GO
AHEAD. AT GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN THAT THE DAVID TALK
WITH THE ONLINE WHEN THERE'S A
LOT AND WE'RE I STRONG ENOUGH
TO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED PPO
STRUCTURE MAY RE. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COM REGARDING THAT
ITEM. ON WE JUST BELIEVE THAT
IF YOU CAN EXPANSION OF TO
SHOULD BE HAPPENED THREE TRANCE.
POLICY NOT REMAIN FREE THANK
YOU. FIND SIX ONE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK DAYS FROM PARADISE
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING- THE
GOVERNOR TO. BUT BACK IN THE
SEVEN POINT FORTY MILLION
PROFIT THE PARADISE THAT WOULD
REALLY DESTROYED PARADISE WE
NEED CLEAN DRINKING WATER-
RIGHT NOW ALL THE COUNTY HAS
BEEN BOOMING WITH BOTH GOING TO
VERY EXCITING HE- WERE ACTUALLY
OUT FIRE SURVIVOR DARBONE
SURVIVE. BUT WE ALSO BURKE THE
PROPERTY WITH. THAT SEVEN POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS BOB AT.
OR OUR DAUGHTER THAT IS THE
BAND OF THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY. SO WE'VE BEEN LIKE
IT'S BUILDING OUR FAMILY UP IN
PARADISE AND WE NEED CLEAN
WATER. THANK YOU. ONE SIX ZERO
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
DEMOCRATS FROM MERRILL WHAT
THEY TELL YOU OF CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE PURCHASE OF
HOTEL THE MOTELS ON THE PROJECT
TV BUT LIKE TO ENSURE THAT THE
PURCHASING OF TOUCH HELP THE
MOST HEALTH FOCUSED ON
COMMUNITIES WITH THE GREATEST
NEED AND PRIORITIZE COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR THAT IT'S DARK BEEN
MARGINALIZED AND THIS MUCH
MONEY. IMPACTED BY HOUSING
INEQUALITIES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
LINE SIX ZERO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AT THAT KNOWN THIS IS
JESSICA BACK LOWER THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY. I
HAD A HORRIBLE AND THAT THAT
POLITICS AND THAT. I ENTERED
THE PORT- OUR WEEKLY PLACEMENT
PROGRAM FOR IMMIGRANT WORKERS.
ALSO INTO COURT AND ENDING THE
SOLUTION FOR. OUT AND THE
EXPANSE OF B. B. L. SELECT A
THAT WE ARE PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FIND FIVE TWO ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU FOR
LOOKING TALK WILL BE STOP
PUBLIC COMMENTS I KNOW IT'S A
LONG TIME- IN THE PROCESS I'M
ROBERT ALLOW WITH THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA. FOURTEEN
THE REFORMULATION BUT- THE
OVERSIGHT. AND IT'S A IT'S A
SMALL BUDGET YEAR GOOD FOR
PUBLIC USE RESTRICTED SPECIAL
FUNDS AND IT ACTUALLY WOULD
HELP PROTECT THE GENERAL FUND
TAKING A PROGRAMS FROM GROWING
EVEN FURTHER. IT'S MORE NOW
THAN IT WAS A FEW MONTHS AGO
WHEN IT WAS FIRST PROPOSED. AT
WITH A FIVE MILLION.
CALIFORNIANS FINDING FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT AS YOU HEARD MUCH
OF TODAY. LET ME JUST NOTE THAT
TWO WEEKS AGO ATTORNEY GENERAL.
YEAH THE- QUOTE FROM
PERSPECTIVE HAVING WITH STATE
VERSION OF THE FEAR. BUT WHAT
HE WOULD BE POWERFUL TO HELP US
IN OUR WORK TO PROTECT ALL
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST TO
COMMITTEES. SO LET'S MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR I HAVE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS IN QUEUE FOR US.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH OF WHAT
FOR SMALLER THANK EVERYBODY
FOR- CALLING IN TO MAKE THEIR
COMMENTS KNOWN. WE TRULY TRULY
APPRECIATE THAT. AND IF YOU
HAVE FURTHER COMMENTS. I'M
GONNA ASK YOU TO. EMAIL YOUR
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS TO BUDGET
SUB FOR. AT ASM DOT CA DOT GOV
THE WORD BUDGET- B. U. D. G. E.
T. S. U. B. THE NUMBER FOUR AT
ASM DOT CA DOT GOV- THANK YOU.
BE SAFE SOURCE FOR DISTANCE AND
WASH YOUR HANDS. TAKE CARE.
THAT HIT INS ARE HEARING.